the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the 2022 grand chess tour started off in
spectacular fashion with the super bet
chess classic in bucharest romania the
top players from around the world
gathered for a chance to win the first
leg of the illustrious tour defending
grand chess tour champion wesley so took
the lead early and didn't let up
defeating last year's winner chakriar
mamadiara been staking his claim at the
top of the leaderboard but he was not
alone for long as lavon aronian proved
to be the houdini of chess making
miraculous escapes and racking up points
keeping the two americans tied at the
top throughout the event however
frenchman maxine bashir lagrave was not
content with settling for third forcing
a three-way playoff after defeating
young phenom and fellow countryman
alareza farrugia in the final round
after an intense series of tie breaks
that went down to the wire with all
three players in contention till the
bitter end maxine bashir legrob emerged
victorious to claim the title of the
2022 super bet chess classic champion
following a stupendous event in romania
the players look forward to picking up
the pace as they prepare for the super
bed rapid and blitz poland the second
leg of the 2022 grand chess tour
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody to warsaw poland host
of the superbad rapidem blitz the second
leg of the grand chess tour behind me is
the palace of culture and science one of
the most famous landmarks here in warsaw
we have some of the best chess players
on the planet ready to jump in action
and compete for the title of the
superbad rapid and bliss champion let's
go to the studio and start today's
action with yasher peter and alejandra
enjoy this magnificent magnificent
panoramic views of the polish capital as
we welcome you to the second stop on the
on the trains into gran chester the
super bed rapid and blitz in warsaw
good morning i'm peter swiddler and with
me is the assassin more grand chess
action yes indeed peter i hope you
enjoyed the few days in between the two
events i definitely did me too me too
hello everybody and welcome to the super
bet rapid and blitz our second stop of
the grand chess tour the action is going
to be fast and furious so buckle your
seats and get ready
peter
give us our roster of players absolutely
and here here you see uh the the full
lineup of very very strong tournament
featuring uh featuring some full tour
participants
and also a
large number of wild cards and very
exciting wild cards uh yeah there you
see up up there at the top the the four
players who have played in bucharest uh
bobby wesley uh richard and uh
levon making six wild card players and
the wild card players are yeah there
will be a lot of conversation about the
uh the lineup so i will just note that
uh
there is a very nice mix of experience
and and youth with vishu making a
reappearance in the in the gcg events
yeah well
and also some very very uh
exciting young players uh two ukrainian
players in the field which is
outstanding and our format for this uh
rapid and blitz peter uh the format is
we're still playing ten round uh ten
player round robins uh one for for rapid
and actually two it's a double round
robin for blitz
the time control will be 25 plus 10 for
uh the rapid games the slower side of
rapid uh and five plus two for the blitz
drawfur is still entirely forgotten
and uh the scoring system as you can see
uh
very
it's just basically double the points
for uh for the rapid compared to the
blitz so you're heavily incentivized to
uh to do well in the rapid portion of
the event
and today is our first round of rapid
and our schedule uh peter yeah the
schedule is three rounds per day for the
rapids so we will have today tomorrow
and the saturday to do with the uh rapid
round robin and then we play
uh the entire blitz round robin on
sunday and then the entire blitz round
robin with colors reversed uh on monday
and there will be playoffs on monday if
players die for first most excellent
thank you peter and
alejandro
good to see you my friend and talk about
the new faces in this tournament in
warsaw good morning peter good morning
yasser good to be here with you in the
studio in st louis of course we have a
great event ahead of us another grand
chess tour rapid and blitz and as you
guys mentioned we have a lot of
experienced faces and a lot of new names
here in this tournament let's take a
look at the wild cards that we have in
this event starting with the former
world champion of course the great
vision is returning to the board gracing
us with his presses here in this
tournament always an exciting player to
see always a surprise in rapid chess uh
speaking of rapid chance we have a
specialist in this field in kiril
shashenko from ukraine he has proven
already that he is an incredibly strong
player at this time format he's the
reigning university world champion he
won the lindaras abbey blitz last year
certainly an experienced player when it
comes to rapid and bullets time controls
and of course we have the local hero
young
duda has been an amazing powerhouse for
polish chess he is one of the candidates
he has revived polish chess in the last
couple of years and he will be going to
madrid in june to fight for the chance
to face magnus champion magnus carlsen
for the world championship match next
month of course we have the return of a
friendly face you have it there anton
corbett another rapid especially he's
done very well in our grand chess tour
tournaments in the past always a
fighting chess player and it's exciting
to see him back on the boards
another person that we have returning is
radek voy tasha he is another one of the
local heroes a very experienced chess
professional and chess coach himself
remember that he worked many years under
vishyanam as his second he is the
five-time polish chess champion just
winning it again last week and we have a
youngster international master actually
david gabrielesku from romania he is the
current romanian chess champion at the
current romanian rapid chess champion he
is here to show that despite his young
age and his slightly lower rating than
his opponents he can definitely put up a
fight well let's take a look at who we
have facing each other as we go to our
friends that are in warsaw poland
anastasia and
christian tom
thank you alejandro and welcome
everybody to day one of the super bad
rapid and blitz health here in warsaw
poland from location to call all the
action and give you all the live updates
i will be your host grandmaster
christian carrillo alongside my
brilliant co-host one grandmaster
anastasia carlovich anastasia welcome
back to the show what have you been
doing in preparation for this event for
the past couple of days yeah we didn't
have that much of time but yesterday
because yesterday we had already the
opening ceremony of the event and it's
really great to be here in the museum of
jewish history are you ready for the
games oh i'm definitely ready for the
games what games do you have in mind for
round number one let's not forget we
have three rounds today but what do you
have in mind for round number one i'm
really looking forward to watch the game
between young christophe duda the local
hero polish grandmaster and uh the new
player david gabrielesko from romania
i'm i'm really interested to see how
they will play they will never met
before and he's a young player let's see
i'll keep my eyes on him well
gabrielescu is definitely a rapid
champion he's uh the national romanian
champion in rapid chess but we have
another ukrainian champion and that is
kiril shevchenko i definitely have my
eyes on this young player he will be
facing richie report another explosive
player on the roster here in poland and
we see they haven't met each other uh as
many times only one game and that was a
loss for kiril chavchenko he will
definitely be looking to bounce back
from that loss and take revenge i'm
having my eyes on this matchup how about
you guys in st louis
well thank you christian and anastasia
good matches to be sure but let's take a
look peter at all of the
appearance for round one certainly
uh as usual uh in in every gct event
everything uh looks very very
interesting uh and uh the matchups not
mentioned is a very very exciting game
between wesley and uh anton korobo and
donald
everyone's everyone's favorite player
when he's on song he's just a joy to
behold and he's genuinely a joy to
behold and when you when you can behold
him yeah uh
uh vishy uh vichy plays against radek uh
kirill
on the wide side against richie rapport
and then the game that guy made
almost you know went on
unremarked upon yeah yeah live on with
the white pieces against bobby the the
all-american clash and uh young system
is playing white against gabrielesko and
not an easy start for the tournament for
for the young romanian but this is going
to be in general a very very trying
uh event for him
a beautiful beautiful playing hall
in the museum of the history
of polish jews as we see
the players getting ready to start what
we expect to be an incredibly
intense and fighting event and peter
what are they going to be fighting for
in terms of money
um yeah uh
yeah the the prize fund
uh is uh half of what it was it was in
the classical event but it's still an
incredibly incredibly well played event
considering it's
uh it's rapid and blitz with 44 for
first
and going all the way down to seven for
a photo for last place and just as we uh
saw in romania
if you win the event outright you get an
additional gct points you get 13 points
for
uh for winning the tournament without
tie breaks compared to 12
uh compared to 12 if you time
good face to see return to the
chessboard vishy anan what a way to do
it right you get radic on your first
round i know you're the guy you've been
training with for the last you know 15
years or so
uh is she 52 years young
i've been referring to him in so many of
our broadcasts as a six-time world
champion and i bumped into him at dinner
one of the uh events here in st louis
and i said is that right vichy sixth
time he says well i did win nine
world titles when you count are juniors
they guess who gary kasparov in the
house
peter and gary
gary's making some moves
oh yeah talking talking to players it's
always good to always good to see gary
in good spirits and i know e2 e4
yeah
nice
it's a legendary world champion
yeah and they're
according to our information there might
be an additional uh first move made on
one of the boards we'll wait for visual
confirmation for that
uh before announcing who that might be
but that did not seem to
occur occur yet
they just said let's start the clock
let's race us let's go boys
we'll start with this one the duda
against gallery let's go match because
we highlighted it this is a completely
unknown player for many of us french the
fans the french that's a good thing
about this he's got a lot to learn
but it's nice to see the french defense
i got it with anton in the field we
might be seeing another french as well
i'm starting to wonder if it's a
romanian specialty because i remember
lupulesco using the
times in the last year of last year
bucharest yeah
and the old
variation but this one is shrimp g5 is
slightly off meta right right it's off
meta yes i love that we can use this
word now in the chat world
people have almost exclusively been
playing e4 e5 in this position instead
of bishop g5 but g5 was very very
popular when
you know when i started
facing serious players with white
against the french i basically played
against jf and beret for like 10 years
exactly interchangeably and then jf kind
of abandoned the french and started
playing the caro but
yeah i played this a ton with with the
white pieces with very mixed success
frankly i was never very impressed the
reason they really disappeared was this
morozovic line thank you yeah i wanted
to say oh yeah no question g
f6 is an idea of
mirozovich and then with followed up
with this asics ggf gf definitely
existed before before
which played it but yeah but
specifically i think a6 b5 was like in
my mind in my mind bishop g5 sort of
doesn't give any advantage after bishop
takes f6 instead of gm f5 is
immediately less popular yeah it's
interesting what he means because yeah
593
has not really been supposed to equalize
for quite some time i would say like
it's uh it's considered to be i mean
it's playable it's one of the main
theoretical moves and you can still go
a6 here but the funny thing is that i've
actually played a game of the grand
master chess where my opponent went a6
instead of f5 and i play knight c3
it is a lot it is a line yeah it does
exist queen many many things exist yeah
but okay that's a little bit off the
beaten path too right
queen e2
there's still a lot of yeah
yeah it's it it very much
very much still exists yeah you i think
is this where they go before d5 and i i
i think b4 is like a key move b4 d5 i
also don't have a choice in this
particular
sacrifice yeah before d5 yeah this is
this is
i think they go like bishop cf king of
f8 and game continues
this looks kind of compelling i mean i
gotta tell you guys the this
this one is heating up earlier
a little bit it's probably also the
better move but
yeah it's probably the better move right
but now that d5 is not a threat
we have to draw your attention to the
chat i like the gaming chairs whoa
yeah these i think these are very nice
yeah i've been the bullet and actually
finally bought a gaming chair recently
yeah good good life decision
it seems like the esports was in the
building before we came and they left
behind some very nice looking chairs the
black and white there i'm assuming no he
did not play bishop b7 i was about to
say i would be very anxious to plant
the bishop on the d5 square and he
chooses 25 first because he's looking to
maybe perhaps play bishop g7 even though
why generally is very happily sacrifices
this spawn on c5 for development and the
opening of the central files okay i
think it's more that you have to stop
g45 and there potentially are some
tactical issues with bishop b7 as you
were suggesting i'm assuming king b1
yeah can be one looks very logical yeah
although apparently this is a very
topical position and there's been 25
games wow with c4 yeah and more games
with king b1 so the idea being of course
and what you're saying peter the big
fight for d5 may be resolved in white's
favor so i assume c4 gets ignored i
assume
yeah i would play queen a5 here without
a moment's hesitation to
yeah and something like this and once
again this becomes very very sharp
knight c5 is a movie maybe even default
d5 in that position
even though like i feel like i'm
probably trying to mate myself rather
than
deliver deliver mate in the center here
nothing like a good uh suicide attempt
to
to get us started early in the morning
and let me turn over just uh to
alejandra for a second and uh looks like
a bishop's opening alejandro remember
that we have rapid games today so we're
gonna have to be a little bit quicker on
how we go through the games we have five
for you already and this is going to be
one of the key matchups of today's round
levana ronan with white against fabiano
caruana and we have a bishop's opening
here five essay the move c6 during the
tournament when d5 and had some success
in the bishop's opening between nepo
with the black pieces and farouza we
also had the ideas of c6 and d5 and
instead bishop c5 played no c6 knight c3
and surprisingly i was looking at the
database here castles is rare c6 and d6
are the common moves and here after f4
actually fabi went into a little bit of
a thing and i love the way levon is
playing this one is spicing up you could
take on f4 take on f4 and this is what's
happened i assume that at this point
white is trying to castle queenside and
then use this advantage in space on the
king's side to attack this way and black
is using the time that he has this king
is not castled yet to rip apart the
centers prepare to move c6 and the move
d5 coming in so
black has the initiative for a couple of
moves you're going to have d5 you're
going to try to break up the center can
he actually do so or will white finish
development and start an initiative
office zone on the kingston i think this
was going to be really fun c6 already on
the board and you have to deal with d5
this forces the issue this is the kind
of strategic positions i like because it
forces the issue for both sides clearly
d5 is coming levon with things to solve
meanwhile in the chef chenko against
richard rapport game we have another
fridge this might be the first time ever
that in the gct there's two french
defenses at the same time we have a very
different approach this advanced
variation with the move e5 all the rage
nowadays everybody's playing e5 in the
last year or two years and many
different things have been tried
uh rapport in the
grand prix played queen b6 against vedic
but got a horribly lost position managed
to win the game anyway
and after 96 instead returning to the
main line he went for this variation
with a quick knight g6 g3 and f6 i've
seen this position more often with
bishop e7
h4
and the funny move castles h5 knight h8
with the idea of f6 knight f7 and some
kind of weird regrouping this is
considered to be theory i'm not sure
where it's uh at right now there's even
a grisha carlson game from this position
but instead the quick f6 played by
richard has sent kiril shafchenko into a
little bit of a think you're probably
not familiar with the move we'll see how
this one pans out two french defenses to
start the day off in poland
thank you uh alejandro just a quick look
around the horn as we have wesley soh
versus anton wesley this is a slav
defense where black voluntarily gives up
the two bishops for a very safe sound
structure and looking uh to play c6 cc
this one is extremely extremely strange
to my eyes because i i struggle to
understand why i'm sort of not winning
with white right right you got the two
bishops for free and the center and no
particular counter play i'm guessing
maybe if white is
not doing uh yeah okay i've your
instinct is correct peter i mean you
have the center you have the bishops
your king will be saved soon
i'm even wondering why he had to include
bhp2 on the previous move i could have
maybe started with king of two but maybe
connecting the rooks is never a mistake
right and maybe h2h4 on white said
maybe just rook c1 rook tv roxy water
okay g1 i was wondering if the intention
here might be to play cd4 cd4 e65 to try
to at least fight for something but the
issue is after rook hc1 you just you are
in such horrible horrible trouble
because you don't have a good square if
white were like obliged to play five g5
and you got bishop c5 in that position i
could defend with like that position i
would say i'm probably still worse but
it's defendable if i'm going to play e5
peter i don't want to open up the c file
that is fair yeah maybe maybe this is
the way uh the way to do it but still a
cramped position two bishops we gotta
hear wesley for choice uh very uh
peculiar game very sharp very sharp
it's the one between vicious and e3
spanish and radic as black
where
it's not usual i want to put it like
that in a low password where black gets
in the f5 without having made any
specifically specifically in the uh
english 63 uh spanish lines you do see
the structure
maybe i'm sorry what is rolex time
2627
as you can see yeah 2016.
he's just snapping those moves out so
the guys gained
a minute 30 on 10 second increment wow
that's fast yeah
wow well we we kind of do you know he
works on chess and specifically he works
on chess with with his opponent
here i think this is fine i think i
think this i could very easily imagine
it has to be fine right radix looked at
it yeah i mean he's just snapped out all
of his moves so i don't know which one i
prefer first but like in general i want
to go rogue b8 and bishop f6 you
probably want to play c4 exactly yeah i
was wondering if your queen can't be
disturbed yeah i go bc and uh if you
switch with a knight i get an additional
temp like rugby let's go rugby yeah just
because you don't like your rook on the
and i go c4
so the idea is that if you do drop in
with your we take on c4 here and we take
back
yeah and then this kind of an end game
i'm assuming uh
that thing can be no i you obviously
prefer white but i'm assuming this can
be held like take take rook d8 maybe uh
rook d1 rock d8 yeah rook d1 rook t8 if
you have ruby rb1 knight a5 is
surprisingly not as stupid as it looks
because i do get some count to play
against the c4 pawn with bishop f6 to
come fair we'll keep our eye on that
let's jump back to the game of the
french defense
uh that was the richie game with queen
ef he takes f6 queen takes seven i'm
somewhat surprised by the queen takes
but maybe this was always the intention
i thought maybe
richie wants to really spice it up by
taking gf and then perhaps trying to
castle coincide which if it comes off is
definitely a sensible positional idea
but queen of queen f6 is also of course
playable
playable development yeah development
good development good yeah but also
you know it makes it slightly harder to
pro
push e65 later in the game
bishop g5 provoking the queen yeah i was
arguing for including bishop g5 and
asking where does the queen go i'm
assuming i'm assuming f7 and then just
dropping it back to e3 because i like i
like tickling the queen back we might
want the tempo with knight g5 later in
the game i don't know what for but we
might want it right
but
against that and goes cd4 cd4 knight g4
is an interesting uh
wrinkle there because it seems very
logical to just take with them with the
c pawn to give the knight on uh b1 a
very nice c3 you were mentioning a
moment ago that black is going to have a
little awkwardness with e5 that's not
the case anymore this game
definitely heating up and finally uh
a lifetime between one one game that's
only the second game
nothing between them as they say uh
we've got uh the fabi game just moved
after the move c7 c6 which you mentioned
black has an early initiative alejandro
but then came very quickly d4 d4 and d5
uh very logical issue b4 the response is
also entirely logical pretty much always
gets met by the 75 and bishop d3
94.
oh we should take c4 i mean 92 was
definitely uh
everybody's choice right sort of by
default i think you play knight g2 in
this position
levon clearly feels that
uh allowing the trade on c3 is
unnecessary and perhaps the colony four
is weak because he quickly goes bishop
takes and knight g2 this is a very very
concrete position right because if you
give white time to castle and play
knight g3
or knight takes e4 or not takes c4 for
that matter yeah yeah white will be
extremely happy but that'll be a healthy
part yeah but black
probably has time to develop some kind
of initiative i'm not entirely sure what
you're supposed to do here are you
supposed to play c65 here
what and allow d4d5 g5 bishop g4 i was
trying to calculate if that might be
playable i don't know
i i i i clicked uh around uh sorry it
just you you said c5
in which line g5 bishop g4 i wanted to
see if maybe i can attack the center
this way by pinning both knights and
then like if you castle you actually
lose the g5 pawn means meaning that
that's not nice maybe you have to make
someone slightly awkward decisions in
this position but he goes with bishop g4
first without provoking d5 which is
obviously a much more
uh sort of a sorry director probably
insane and uh
committal much less committal decision
okay i'm assuming if you castle we take
on c3 right we and then we force b takes
c3 and you could have done that any time
even when i played bishop takes e4 you
could have taken on c3 with jack
yes and there was definitely definitely
a possibility i wonder why he didn't
consider it for
consider it for longer but
well yeah it's still still a very sharp
position i'm not sure what i think about
it we'll keep an eye on this one and
finally yeah somewhat shockingly
youngsters have actually played the move
i mentioned and then
got very embarrassed by my own stupid
idea
but now that young sister played it it's
a brilliant really thank you that's what
i was saying yeah i am i am very proud
of my pre-kog abilities here exactly
yeah the king on c1 looks a bit silly
with the dark square is entirely
unprotected around it and the bishop
potentially coming to f6 and a little
later in the game but the black center
is about to disappear so maybe this is
the more the more relevant part part of
the equation here that
there's not going to be a center to
speak of and i got to ask you about this
alejandro uh this this game that we're
seeing with duda with c4 uh peter
mentioned that this has been seen before
what's the what's the verdict
there has been one game played before in
this position not a grand master game
but
tons of variations can be played here by
black it seems that jan schistov is
still sort of in theory he has about 24
minutes left but gary leske's burning
time he's already spent 10 minutes to
get to this position deciding on what to
do the engines are saying you could
castle and on take on e6 blast open the
position with b3 you've kind of saved
your kin you can always stick with the
rook on f7 and after b3 you're
threatening things like queen c3 like
bishop a3 safeguard the king first and
then go for the attack or go full out
take on a4 take on e6 play b3 give up f7
move the king somewhere even taking on
f7 is fine but the engine thinks king f8
is an easier solution and the counter
play that you have here
is just about enough for a draw so you
do have moves like queen e5 you do have
moves like queen e6 you do have some
defensive tries but because these pieces
are sleeping there's no good way of
defending the king but there's not that
many attackers either it's just a bishop
a queen and a pawn and i can't eliminate
the pawn this knight and this rook are
not part of the equation so the engine
just sees perpetuals everywhere in this
position doesn't think it's it's so easy
of course as a human it's hard because
you don't calculate these perpetuals
very easily and your case also coming
under fire so a big decision here for
the young romanian player uh taking on
a4 is okay castling is okay
but i'm sure that there are other moves
that retain some sort of fight
uh just in the position instead of the
move b3 i was afraid of queen e5 so i
was thinking yeah at night yeah perfect
knight c6 in this position and then you
take on f7 you got your king f8
and king of a not here because king f8
queen b2 forces me to take on f7 anyway
okay so go ahead and take because the
knight as you mentioned covers e5 right
and the bishop cover is g5 so there's no
check there's no check right now against
this king and you are bringing your
pieces together black's already better
whoa in this position actually after the
move knight c6 which is perfectly
playable it's not recommended according
to the engine to take on f7 there are
other moves some completely human so
more logical i think queen b2 is a
logical human being move keep the queen
around the king prevent the move b3 hit
the rook with the tempo i think the move
queen b-2 does a lot of good things
but let's very quickly go to warsaw with
our friend christian
thank you alejandro i just wanted to
give you a quick update as the games are
hitting up well the playing hall is
marvelous it is an auditorium of a nice
theater here in the museum and the
players are just playing in a very
exclusive uh playing venue it's very
very beautiful everything is on brand
red and white the polish colors and also
you have the chairs in which the players
are playing in there's one white chair
one rapture one white chair one wretcher
very very beautifully
organized by the guys at super bad also
i am looking at the players and a little
bit trying to understand where their
confidence levels are and i'm focused on
this game between chef chenko and richie
rapport and i have to say chefchenko
generally uh has a charisma about him
has a charisma about his play but i
don't see it in this game he's spending
and burning a lot of time but that is
because richie rapport has not been
playing his usual brand of chess his
usual brand of chess is very much
focused on sidelines very much focused
on surprising uh his opponents in the
opening phase today he's actually
playing main lines right now and maybe
this uh took kyrie chunk a little bit of
back let's see what happened in the
beginning phase of the game after this
move g3 which was played very quickly f6
and richie is playing every single move
allah temple and also this is the main
line so kirill should have known this
unfortunately for him it doesn't seem
like he does and we do have this
position on the board
we got all the way to the position after
c4 a6 a very complicated battle but
right now we see only 12 minutes for
kiril and 23 minutes for richard only
the last move he spent a couple of
minutes to play this move f6 which by a6
excuse me which by the way is the best
move in the position so a very
intriguing battle but i have to say
richie report is looking really good
with the black pieces guys back to you
thank you christian and over do you
alejandro again that's just exploding we
have to take a look at it favi with
black against levon look at what
happened in the last couple of minutes
while we were talking about the other
games we were thinking how is white
gonna solve all these things he did take
on c3 he was forced to take b takes e3
and then he just threw his palms forward
said look these pieces are not playing
this center is closed you're not going
to open it up this is my time to go h4
h5 and of course here black has many
ideas the engine wants to play the move
queen e6 force the knight to g3 so that
you're defending the g4 square and only
then go h6 but you could also go h6 h5
the problem is bishop h7 g5 instead of
that fight we play the move e3 whoa wild
wild stuff gifts of the pawn opens the
diagonal if you take on e3 i'm not sure
i think queen e4 was the idea with the
idea of taking here and taking here but
much stronger is what levon played the
move h5 bishop e4 and then take on e3
levon missing a strong move here though
the move knight g3 according to my
engine would pretty much finish the game
as there is no good way
of defending against both the move c4
and h6 because h6 is such a strong
strategical threat you just destroy the
dark squares in front of your opponent's
king and black has to deal with both the
move f5 doesn't really help you uh
because bishop takes c3 just comes
stronger e takes f6 is also winning
queen e2 threatening c4 is also winning
but bishop takes e3 gives white a huge
advantage anyway you are up upon you are
threatening moves like knight f4 kicking
out this queen you have expanded so
you're up the pawn and it seems like you
have all the compensation as well what
is fabi planning on doing here he has
lost the pawn he has the light squares
but what do you do with them the engine
is hating how favi is handling this
position already giving levon a decisive
advantage wow when you think about h7h6
as well uh for for lavon you really like
white's position and the clocks much in
favor of lavon before we go any further
and know things are going to be heating
up going to put ourselves all on
the mark
who do you who do you think will win the
tournament peter
uh let me consider the field again um
we have the roster yeah we have we
absolutely um
we made a number of grievous mistakes in
in this segment in uh in bucharest speak
for yourselves i am speaking for myself
yes
uh and uh
i'm trying not to overcorrect yes but
uh
see i took fabby in bucharest and he did
not perform
uh
let me pick up pick up okay so i'm gonna
go with wesley so over to you uh why
because magnus wasn't available
because magnus wasn't no because wesley
is fantastic i mean if you're gonna give
me second choice i'm gonna go do that
duda the local hero i like that i like
that
yeah i know
let me pick fabio this
oh okay we're gonna get uh var we're
gonna get we know what mars choice is
check this live one okay
garbage wesley not even lavon what
happened
i picked wesley and we'll wait for
christian and anastasia to uh step in
and
anastasia takes duda with whoa
a woman of culture and knowledge
wow i mean
talk about an influencer nobody's taking
gabrielescu i want christians to thank
god
by the way we have bishop f3 on uh
lavon for christian there you go so
yeah we gotta make it
mix enough field yeah but i thought
bishop f3 was bad because of knight f4
doesn't quite work the move knight f4 we
have to move bishop f3 look at this
beautiful bishop it targets g4 h5 pins
but it's just a bishop right it's
supported by the queen and nobody else
knight f4 doesn't immediately work
because after takes
takes takes takes the engine is saying
you're not as winning as you could be is
it a good position of course you can see
the evaluation plus 1.6 great but you do
have double pawns the knight will make
its way snake its way into c4 not so
easy to convert agreed white is better
right uh instead the engines are saying
give up the h4 the g4 phone go queen e1
or queen d3 take and if you take on uh
g4 at any point go knight f4 you kick
out the queen from the center and you're
kind of pre-moving at this point h5 h6
is going to be so difficult to meet
you don't want to take on h6 it just
destroys your position you don't want to
play g6 because it destroys your dark
squares you can't really do anything
about it the queen is going to come to
either g3 or h4 it's one of those
positions where it's not obvious to us
that white is completely winning for the
engine it's over it's just a winning
attack nothing you can do about it your
pieces are nowhere near your king queen
on g3 is just coming to way way way too
strong way too quickly so bishop f3 a
key decision because you were very
tempted especially in a rapid game solve
your problem solve the tension stay up a
pawn knight f4 bishop takes d1 knight
takes d5 you have to capture this knight
that's very obvious because bishop takes
g4 just loses to knight c7 so you can go
for that and it simplifies into a
winning position what will levon choose
in this crossroads
nice
nice points there and again that h7 h6
so crucial uh because now i've got skin
in the game
just taking a quick look at the wesley
anton and that
game blew up uh you were mentioning you
thought that uh c555 looked necessary
right and that's what he's done but then
he shut things down on the queen side
with c4
and
he just sacrificed the central pawn yeah
interestingly he decided not to
recapture on e5 preferring to it's it's
a it's an idea i've seen uh once again
like my spiritual home uh in the
greenville you you get these structures
and when you do get the structures on
the queen side very often you can
sort of get compromised in the center
because the bishop on itsu is very very
restricted
but he followed it up by taking on a4
and now the bishop 192 will become free
again because the opponent's e4
obviously gets picked up but he does
have a a passer on a3 it will be
reasonably easily controlled though on
the light squares because definitely
yeah
i guess you play rugby two here but
uh you would have massive pawns in the
center yeah you would assume white is
better you would assume that with the
with the control white has in the center
uh and the the a file actually sort of
closed by their
black zone pawn on a6 it will be very
very difficult to actually queen uh or
you know even push it to a2 the the pawn
on a3
let's uh jump uh over to warsaw with
christian and anastasia
well thank you yasser you guys got ahead
of us on uh predictions and uh uh
actually i will let anastasia go first
when it comes to predictions anastasia
who do you think will win this
tournament uh last time when i was
making predictions didn't work so well i
would say but okay i will try my black
once again i i really think that maybe
young duda will show a great result here
because he played last time here in
warsaw in the world rapid and blitz
championship and he actually tied for
the first place in the in the blitz
event and he was thieves in the rapid
event so i think okay apart from that
he's really a great player i mean i
think this might be the situation when
even the wolves help you to play you
know when you play in your city in your
hometown i think it's really it really
can help him this time that's definitely
a double-edged uh sword almost playing
in your hometown some players really
embrace that and play very well some
players shy away from that and actually
don't perform to their standards i'm
going to go with levon aronian he did
really well in bucharest played
brilliant chess unfortunately for him in
rapid actually lost against mvl in the
tie breaks for the title nevertheless i
think he's due for a championship and i
will pick him to win this one also i
like what he's doing yes in the first
round against fabiano so why not you you
guys gave us a few more minutes now i'm
going to pick uh uh
aronian but one game again that is
exploding and every single game actually
is exploding right now is the game that
we've been talking about here in the
studio as well chef chenko versus richie
reporter and i will let you guys take
over on that one because chef chenko
just sacrificed a piece for the
initiative let's see what will happen in
that one as well guys back to you in the
studio thank you christian thank you
anastasia and over to you alejandro as
you've been looking at that piece
sacrifice what's going on it's hard to
explain these games but they're very
sharp and they're very cool we left it
off with the move a6 at some point
hitting this knight on b5 and we left it
off here actually and after pawn takes
d5 hitting the knight pawn takes d5 was
the recapture and you could bring the
knight back but you've helped black
develop right
knight was already on d4 you moved it to
b5 to hit a bishop and then you want to
move it back to d4 not exactly girl says
i don't care about your candidate spot
on your 27 70 91 knight one c3 hitting
this pawn on d5 giving up the knight on
b5
richard says there's no real reason not
to take it so he took it knight takes d5
queen on f7 and now knight b6 is
possible to harass this rook on a8 it
doesn't have a lot of squares but
instead the move bishop c5 was played
ultra aggressive chest simply not
allowing black to castle and free his
king this very romantic style of chess
rookie one coming and just blasting open
the king on e8 bishop e6 was played
rookie one is the current position on
the board and you see this pressure on
the e file it's very real bishop g4
could be a threat at some point knight
b6 is the threat bishop to xb5 will be a
threat so certainly a lot of pressure on
black's position but objectively the
engines are saying the bishop on e5 is
supported by two knights and even though
you have f4 ideas in certain positions
they don't quite work remember that in
many cases after you play bishop e5 f4
and i castle even taking on e5 will be
impossible because now black in some
cases actually i don't know how you
should take c5 and the bishop of the
bishop is on c5 you can castle castle
the other way sorry bishop here f4
castle yes yes because you have this
pressure on the d5 square i don't know
why i was thinking castling short right
good morning st louis rookie one the
engines are saying bishop e5 is decisive
advantage for black but in a rapid game
anything could happen it's also not easy
to find i think there are other choices
for example bishop a7 just evicting the
bishop from c5 is very tempting
but not good enough so a wild sacrifice
here by the ukrainian player and let me
update you guys on what's happened
between duda and gabrielesku because
this game
exploded right position on the board
king on g7 very bare black does have an
extra pawn as white's entire structure
here disappeared let me show you how
that happened we left it off here after
b takes a4 and after queen takes a4 d
takes c6 he did play the move b3 very
brave pawn takes f7 king takes f7 also
all of this playable c5 is the only move
in the position not surprisingly found
by uh john sristov i've actually played
almost our tempo pawn takes a2 and the
point is this queen c4 check forces you
to capture no choice king g7 takes on a2
and after taking on c5 rook he won we
have this position where the polish
player has arrived with 21 minutes and
34 seconds his young romanian opponent
four minutes and 40 seconds with a
almost naked king
this is going to be a tough defense for
the black side despite being up upon
peter yeah it feels like with with
precise play this should be not that bad
for black at all uh considering how much
material disappeared off the board and
we know that
wasn't it
yeah you cleaned the whole board yeah
and and also we do have a buffer of
an extra pawn here meaning that we can
return something at some point perhaps
to liquidate in into some reasonably
fine end games but yeah four minutes
against 21 and this is still a very very
sharp position despite the queens coming
off the board
not going to be not going to be easy at
all yeah as a starter like bishop a3
check just to put if the king comes to
the b5 well that's a magnet for a black
robe okay seven by seven as well yeah
king c2 i assume yeah and then i'll drop
my bishop back kind of keeping i'm very
worried about playing bishop six because
i think we don't have a good reply to
94.
knight david four uh yeah i wanted to
play knight to c6 so that i could play
tonight to be fortunate yeah i mean if
we if we get knight six and we're
instantly fine
but i don't think we have a good reply
to 94. uh
and yeah this this is a this is the
issue here is that if i have to give at
the pawn
i think we guess you made it yeah it's
simply yeah the issue here is not using
so yeah very difficult to play for black
simply i think
like
from a purely human perspective i think
you start with rook fade
uh
you could include the space 3 check i
don't hate that move at all but like in
terms of development i would like to
start with rook fade
there's also the idea of playing c6 and
rook a7 in some order just to sort of
secure the seventh
but
uh once again without good eyesight i
probably wouldn't have been suggesting
that if i'm if i'm entirely honest it's
very difficult to take my eyes off of
alejandra's screen because
in particular at seven in the morning it
offers very useful pointers
uh help a guy yeah
then uh but
uh yeah yeah but now rook fade to
potentially just loses to knight g5 in
some of these the problem is this right
that so many moves just lose the engine
line you'll never find because it's
bishop a3 king c2 a5 you're just never
going to find that
five yeah a5 man talk about slow
yeah basically every move that you
played rook cafe
bishop d6 all of them made your position
worse
and a5 helps because we're gonna play
rook lift yeah well sure let's go with
that let's go with yes
spoken like a man who really has a firm
grip on
the position okay that is that's a crazy
outlandish game but for me the marquee
match-up has got to be between lavon and
fabian what has taken place
in that game alejandro i mean
it looks like favi's busted but
look at look at the activity of black's
pieces and look at activity of white's
rooks right look this work on after this
rook on f1 they're so
ready to gear up on the gnf files start
attacking this king on g8 and tell me
what these rooks are doing you can't
play the move f6 which you would love to
play at some point just to rip apart the
center first of all because your
knight's not controlling any of the key
squares second knight g6 just destroys
you the queen is actually now you see i
think currently is simply a threat
because yeah queen g4 rogue g2 is nice
it's a threat and there's no good way to
deal with it it not it's not such a huge
threat to be honest the reason that
knight g6 is not a big threat is that
i'll take with the f pawn you'll take my
queen i'll take with the gf and now i
have a blockade he took the pawn on a2
he's going to get a gold membership to
be
versus how do you even see that hanging
but he did and that's important
what
h6 is game over by the way
like that's it h6 finishes the game you
don't want to take and if you play g6
then you have to take you made this so
much stronger right right because queen
takes rook g2 is game over like this is
actually gaming h6 h6 on the board yeah
and this might be the first result 18
minutes for levon five it down to five
what a disastrous way to start this
tournament hg7 just wins the game you
can't allow that you also can't not
allow it so
you're done you're just dead here
wow
yeah that's
as you say not a very good way to start
the term if instead of bishop takes a2
he had played h6 yeah h6 was the best
move on it only plus two
that's a lot it is a lot but i mean i
was going to sacrifice the queen after
knight g6 but not true but but the
engine says don't take that queen that
queen oh you're helping me you're
helping me with the queen because you
can put that at the end right knight g6
you can explain to the viewers you take
on g6 you take on f5 and even other
moves but i think gf is the easiest
maybe rook five is the best right and
the point is that you have this blockade
right right that's exactly what i was
thinking yes you've got the c4 squared
the d phi squared maybe on a good day
you're okay yeah yeah and you know some
counter spiel but you're saying don't
take the time take the queen just enjoy
enjoy your position f1 rook g2 all this
kind of thing h6 g6 played i don't think
that level one misses a tactical shot
like knight takes g6
wow i feel very put upon by the fact
that we had to do predictions midway
through the round and uh i still failed
to look at the boards
yeah he actually doesn't play knight
takes you maybe there's hope
not much hope though yeah he's gone
bishop a3
yeah it's a quote-unquote blunder
dropping the evaluation from plus six to
plus three
i mean that's a compelling move it's a
good one
it's good enough
yeah that's it
both three only yeah i'm using huge
inverted okay but
i understand quote marks there so knight
g6 was a plus six situation yeah it was
completely winning of course yeah for
because it's basically the the the same
type of situation we were just
discussing only with the pawn on h6 and
no g pawn which is just meaning that
black gets mated basically exactly
exactly oh my yeah it would have been
much easier to finish the game without
you yeah but he's done it with the
inclusion of bishop 3 and rookie 8 for
some reason and now black has some kind
of a blockade going on but yeah still
obviously not going to be good yeah but
this is the best version right for black
with the rook on g6 like on g6 he could
have straighted away like you play rook
jiwan queen h4 and then eventually i
think black gets mated i mean black
black's lost similar to the game of
young christoph
and gabrielescu because
i mean you can't play that position on
30 seconds you see the position behind
me you just cannot play this move on 14
seconds for him you can't do that let's
just go to the live shot because in 14
seconds we're i want to see what his
reactions are going to be to white's
moves because they kind of play
themselves right knight c6 on the board
and i don't see any reason not to go
knight e6 check pick up an exchange you
can also i don't know r7 might be okay i
mean the thing is he's right now
deciding how to win yeah exactly what's
the most winning yeah i think rookie
seven is cleaner on the snake i i i'm
going to agree with peter on that one
rook d7
i want to make you play p7 and then i
will play 96 check if i have nothing
stronger but he disagrees he goes 96
everything everything wins here it's
really a matter of taste but also
exactitude and in your case rook d7
looked
absolutely yeah i thought it was i
thought it was completely winning i
thought we were basically close to
delivering made there and there was no
reason not to start with it right yeah
he feels he will he will win this very
easily which is also entirely true
position is winning he also is way ahead
on the clock and uh yeah the pawns will
drop yeah so things will just start
collapsing
yeah well that's a very good start for
dude no question about it and then
um christian was saying that richard's
not playing like ritchie he's playing
mainline stuff
i don't know i don't know how much of
that is main light stuff i mean f6 is a
clear sideline right bishop e7 has plus
you know we've
and when we left it before e6 already in
those main lines correct well said
uh bishop e5 kind of the move alejandro
was saying
look you don't have enough for the piece
yeah and i think it's sort of clearly
obvious from the position on the board
right now black has an extra piece and
uh initiative pretty much have operated
white
does have two pawns for it but right and
this thing
i actually find the knight off sides
here and i start looking yeah i mean
with f2 i don't know what happened here
but what happened here in the last few
moves
how did the king in only a few moves get
castled well he got he he's got knight
g7 and castle like it's like it was the
normal business day but i mean this is
just completely lost yeah it's yeah it
looks it looks completely lost probably
because it is completely lost you know
i'm thinking one of those one of those
yeah both 94 and bishop d4 are like kind
of kinda
time that uh
what do they say no time of death
before efficiency for
time of death well we'll do an autopsy
later on this position looks completely
lost in yeah i think richie he has 14
minutes as well against two so he is
choosing the most comfortable way of of
putting this
to bed richie
after bucharest he lost a lot of uh
enthusiastic supporters haven't seen it
for a while let's jump quickly to the
game of vichy versus radic when we kind
of suspect that c4 was on vichy's agenda
and radek actually slowed down he had
been playing
super fast up to this moment
and the players reached this position
here i was thinking about queen h5 but
she said hey i've studied games culture
culture look at that doubling the rooks
like a good
wine rishi
just improves with age um
queen g5 this is already looking very
dodgy to me it looks dicey for black
exactly exactly thinking takes
a b and rook e6 why have we included cba
b
just because i was thinking that there
was a pawn on c4 would
i if i do it right away yeah i thought i
thought we could definitely i i was
afraid that he would take and maybe win
the e4 square for his night something
like this peter so if i recapture i was
thinking the knight would drop to e4
it's still a move even in the other
position but i'm guessing
so i took first just to
cut out such a possibility i think after
rookie six i still have to play knight
e4 which is why i was wondering why
we're why we were including it in that
case but in this case i was picking up a
paw yeah but i think it's probably best
best uh rookie f7 here maybe you're
better off taking on a seven going ef
because here i think your extra pawn
disappears off the board immediately
yeah my intended g4 might uh yeah
yeah
might be clipped rook f5 h4 over here
yeah so you can take only seven instead
on the previous and go ef
try to make some pretensions but i'm
one two three four one two three yeah i
mean obviously white is better the
question is whether this is closer to a
draw or not because the queen side is
liable to disappear and yeah um but yeah
it's not okay it's not enjoyable for
black for sure no no no for sure and
again we are up to date with the players
and uh
okay over to you alejandro
uh we have this end game between anton
korobov and wesley saw crucial decision
here for anton because look at the
position thousand pawns in the on the
king side you see that the queen has
gotten off the board there's two rooks
for the black pieces more than enough
compensation but it's all about this
part on a3 generating the counter play
this is the pawn that's going to tie
this queen down to defending this
constantly for the moment there's a
couple of threats by white you can
imagine e6 is a threat trying to get at
this king and the engines are screaming
take on c4 not an easy move to play to
give up your rook for a bishop but the
point is that after rook takes queen
takes e4 rook d2 rook it also kind of
works rook d2 and a2
white can't really ever make progress
the king is kind of stuck a2 will always
threaten something along the lines of
bishop c5 d4 and white is the one that
needs to start looking for counter play
to remove the setup of this past pawn on
a2 and needs to find a perpetual check
so it's actually white that needs to
make the draw after the movie can you
explain to me why bishop d5 wasn't
played h3 just confuses me me too
good question
[Laughter]
king h3
is a bizarre move bishop d5 is very
strong because the bishop holds on a2
and of course the moment you sacrifice
here pawn takes and this pawn is running
that's a very different scenario bishop
d5 was a very strong move big advantage
for white you're absolutely right peter
the move king h3 is very strange because
it allows rook takes c4 but it's not
been played yet maybe anton is debating
whether he wants to play this move or
not but a fascinating moment here in
this game for the ukrainian grand master
rook takes c4
more or less draws the game according to
the engine
but i also don't think that if he plays
another move he's dead lost or anything
like that
but it's so confusing because obviously
throughout all of our chess careers what
we're trying to do is get a safe king
for ourselves uh open up our opponent's
king and to my eyes the king on g4
exactly yeah i was just trying to figure
out why it's not even attackable
actually you know you can't play f5
check that's illegal to begin with i
just couldn't imagine what prompted
its removal from
generally doesn't play these moves very
much and he's taking on c4 and enjoying
his stuff
that's why we invite him to the gct
because this guy can find good moves
he's been leading these rapid events in
the past and he's showing why
yes that's really a great very very
perceptive moment there by anton to feel
that if bishop d5 had landed on the
board as you said peter i think his days
would have been numbered even though the
computer engine may say black holes but
this is so much uh superior as he's as
black gets gets put upon on a2 and he
need to find a perpetual also i want to
say that let's say if after queen c3
a2
i have a feeling white doesn't lose the
position after queen takes g2 and we
have our first result as we expect 11
ardonian has converted that position
against fabiano carolina an excellent
way of starting the tournament for levon
and fabi coming out of
the mall chose bucar is not starting the
best way here
no not at all very nicely converted by
yeah and another game that we were
expecting to be decisive duda has an
absolutely crushing position against
gabrielesco you can see that black is
missing quite a bit of material
in this position yeah
somewhere around here you you are
perfectly justified and not continuing
yeah and that's it and there we have it
a double handshake right there thank you
magic of television uh victory for the
local hero
ending with a bang starting with the
banks certainly let's take a look at
richard because i think that's going to
be the also decisive game by the way
their king on h3 does not look so
healthy no uh
as i'm eyeballing knight f4 check no
it's white to move yeah i know i might
as a threat that white's got to deal
with and that's not an easy threat to
deal with peter yeah i wish that i wish
white had more material at least right
well it's funny because after knight
takes d5 rook takes d5 you're almost
expecting that some kind of an accident
very much puts uh
yeah this diagonal those ideas you know
and you're thinking to yourself you know
bishop c4 you know you're pinned well
no you're not the rook on e6 you know
it's in the way
and it doesn't quite work out yeah
exactly
but because of the threat of knight f4
he's played he's played queen c4
straight away but he's also down to down
to fumes and also i'm not really sure
how it helps neither for just wins the
full queen there right because you have
to take and then like you're you're
going down it's not very very exciting
but he was on 14 seconds so
yeah let's not criticize movies made in
14 seconds very seriously anything wins
well i mean not anything most things
yeah queen of five checks probably not a
mistake
but why not just play knight four and
then rooker four
exactly knight f4 you're threatening me
actually bishop b2 kind of no queen
decks have to exist i was i was about to
say the the queen of three is weirdly
caught on f3 there it comes pretty i
mean considering it's in the center of
the board sort of it's kind of close it
is a little bit funny right yes there's
a there's actually only one square for
it if we don't count location check
which frees up a bunch of other squares
we do have the knight for what you're
saying and rook takes he'll play with
pizza but then yeah yeah like whatever
whatever you want to do here rook h4
actually is there a case for maybe it's
a cleaner solution you go rook h4 and
then you go rook d4 check and
this is where your opponent resigns yeah
because after king goes back to h3
you've got now which is goku in a five
quarter
not that quintex f2 doesn't win but this
really is just complete and other end of
game
that's a very nice sequence too that
whole rook h4 but also queen f2 is made
in 12 so that is what it is not a
mistake yeah they're not a mistake as is
known in the business not a mistake
rook is
hoping the guy goes queen takes g4 yeah
not on 10 minutes though yeah against
against three seconds maybe uh a very
cute move
as where we are waiting for this
handshake a very very cute move was
played by by vishe
uh in his game against radek he's played
uh g3 and radik i thought this was the
the most critical response radic spent
some time and picked up the gauntlet
there by playing c takes d3 and now both
h4 and f4 win a piece
because the only square the queen can go
to is g4
which relinquishes control over the e7
square so we take on g4 and we take the
knight on d6 but we end up in this
strange situation where everything is
connected past everything is pinned in
black plays c5 c4
right and yeah i was sort of trying to
calculate uh yeah he goes f4 which i
think is very understandable because it
gives us the access to the f2 square
okay for the king i think it's
definitely the pref the the
right way to go yeah the the the better
way to go about things yeah fg d6 i'm
assuming he'll just play king of two
here because the pawns don't really run
they're kind of stuck actually yeah it's
actually a huge big difference because i
was also calculating exclusively the age
for queen g4 position and i thought it
might be unclear this one really doesn't
look unclear to me this one looks like
white should be able to uh
uh this looks like just a simple extra
piece for this for vishy he starts with
rook d4 which is a bit surprising to me
but here the point is rook f7 would have
been a very strong move here if not for
the fact that the knight exists
so black has to spend a lot of time here
to uh even create a threat to the knight
on e7 something like g6 king g7 might be
in order and that's two tempe you just
don't have to spend right like something
like rookie five might just be winning
here rookie five and then we just take
on c4 next move very very
uh kind of cold-heartedly and not even
wasting any time on king of two uh
nonsense
um see if is she seemingly in very good
shape here g3 is a such a cute move
i wonder i wonder though ah okay this is
why maybe you had to start with
94 anyway
because i i wanted to say we can still
play 94 here but then h4 or f4 is very
strong so knight h were here
here but yeah but this here just loses
to one of those two two moves right
it's just because you're just trying to
knock the queen
away from it it's completely unplayable
so if you wanted to play 94 you needed
to do it immediately after rook e6
similar to our position that we
discussed earlier but within with the
pawns steel on c4 and a6
which favors
one of the two sides yeah correct i mean
or maybe none yeah yeah
i'm not it's too early in the morning
yeah
yeah to figure out
whether this makes any material
difference these deep thoughts are worth
thinking through more carefully uh
didn't happen so it all went uh
catastrophically wrong
seemingly yeah we uh for for radic
yeah catastrophically is right although
i don't understand anything of what the
engine is saying after rook takes d6 the
decisive mistake was c4 rook v8
apparently was equal but that is beyond
my understanding of chelsea i i have no
idea why but f4 was a mistake
i i mean i'm just telling you what the
engine says yeah rook d8 is equal
but if the pawn was on h4 instead of f4
yeah then then it's better for white oh
that was my first instinct but i didn't
want to contradict you and
we're not going to alejandro for the
rest of the day we're going to actually
let him just the more i think about it
are we going to let him stay in the
corner all by himself
uh nobody but unfortunately nobody puts
alejandro
was the blunder
yeah oh my word so yeah the problem was
actually that after rook takes d6 c4
doesn't actually come with a threat and
it will never come with the threat
rook d4 g6 as you said as i was saying
yeah rook takes e4 currently blunders
the knight only seven because of g2 but
i think this is the issue right actually
the more i think about it c4 is just a
blunder it just blunders your opponents
like if you play rook the 8 you keep
your pawns yes and rook d and c4 just
blunders though
that's the difference that's the
difference yeah it's very cold-hearted
and it's very calculation based but
i'm thinking just rookie 5 just to
sidestep the move d2 for a moment this
is what we're doing
room v8 maybe would be something to try
because
yeah yeah otherwise otherwise the xc4 is
too strong of a thread but i'm assuming
white somehow consolidates i don't know
exactly how but i think it's like g6
what's your next move
we tried rookie five no no but like what
is the main oh g7 but the rook d7 randy
forces forces you back
also yeah so we can just start with king
of two start with king f2 yeah yeah fair
point you're not making too much
progress here
i love king f2 just one of those moves
that just brings your king a little bit
closer to the action
gets yourself off the back rank so
there's no right checks and but that's
the thing right like king g7 never
processed the threat you want to play
rook f7 that's the entire point because
king f7 is not your point right you want
to play rook f7 but it doesn't help you
exactly
and vishy
looking a little bit nervous reaching
for his king king after
yeah
wow yeah
i think he was looking mainly here at g5
making sure it wasn't
yeah g5 he's got f5 to shut it if he
needs it if he needs it but the rook on
d4 is so strong defending everything so
yeah he doesn't actually need it
i'm not quite sure though
like king g7 rook d7 rook f7
oh you do it like that yes but i meant
like on king f7 i have rook d7 oh okay
and you don't have rook f7 right now oh
yeah okay so we play a move so king f7
so now we can go rookie five but yes i
think you can go rookie now we can go
rookie five yeah the engine really wants
knight c6 actually yeah why are we why
are we being so complicated knight c6 95
pick up everybody yeah stop thinking so
hard
come on humans thinking is well there's
always played 1966 yeah yeah
now he breaks the
brings his knight back into the game
yeah that human is perfect that human is
pretty good at chess yeah yeah
um nice nice and in the in the other
game that is still running wesley wesley
versus anton this is the queen versus
yeah black is still fine i assume right
it's become it's become somewhat sharper
i mean there was a i saw it with a
maiden two and i was like my eyes were
looking at queen f5 and queen h5 me but
then it was black black
very important
yeah i assume it's just a draw here
because yeah pretty much any square you
put the rook on i think is kind of fine
because the queen cannot take take the
rook on almost any of them i would
actually kind of suggest choosing a
square which is not connected to the a1
square like root b2 would be probably
the last square i choose
would you choose b2 or d2 if you're
giving a chance like d2 hangs the rookie
movie yeah i think i think you actually
i think you actually choose d2 right
yeah really so that if you blunder it if
you blunder it after some check that if
like if it gets taken a1 is still a move
right right if you blunder it on b2 it's
just
which is also kind of an understandable
choice an additional plus side to rook
d2 was that it was threatening rook g3
or k3
ah and rook c2 does not create a threat
of rook c3 or k3 so this is a like an
additional layer of why you would maybe
choose rook g2 there yeah at some point
wesley needs to make a draw right
because bishop
at some point
it's going to be scary
yeah a lot of moves make a drone yeah a
lot of people just make good jokes
yeah
most queen moves to a light square will
make a drop because queen e8 starts
the king yeah yeah the only thing very
interesting
blunder queen h5 or queen f5 mate
yeah yeah seems like a very interesting
game which i'm assuming wesley missed
some chances but whoa
obviously it's fine anton
what a move that's why we invited that's
what we invited wesley saw was black
yeah wow no no repetition for you sir
he's on five minutes against 30 seconds
as well so
you've got an additional an additional
layer to this yeah maybe he says i don't
ride a risk i have a pawn on a2 i'm
playing bishop f6 you find that drama
yeah 25 seconds please yes
make move sir sir but there was also f5
check yeah and visually has one in the
meantime as we've expected 25 i guess
with the idea of bishop f6 e7 no f5
check perhaps
as well pick up that kind of strong pick
up that rook yeah you pick up it up with
check which is important
[Laughter]
actually it's funny because if you don't
pick up the a2 and you don't have a
check you might still be worse yeah
but at all but it's all threat queenie
fights and it could if it's a kg move i
like it actually yeah
yeah no we're not we're never leaving
the second rank because you've got to
also as you just about just mentioned e7
is on untapped for white
so any bishop move like bishop f6
besides f5
so you could have a sequence that went
check king here bishop f6 where it's all
gone wrong yeah
suddenly for
black is this a draw yes after bishop b
savage is the draw hp7 and maybe even
rook h8 i was wondering
is also a draw but rook hate is a bit
risky
oh because of king age six
king h6
by the way what's the clock times uh
30 seconds for wesley on five four
minutes of 44 for anton he's played
it's putting that pressure i love king
h6
sir on 15 seconds
wesley wesley
he's not used to this kind of stuff no
he's the one that's usually putting the
pressure that ansar is such a beast
queen a5 went back back to a5 f6 e7
bishop take c7 we've made progress big
huge progress
aren't we just winning bishop f6 can i
go queen a8 oh yeah hang on with king h7
queen e4 check
unfortunately you're never winning i
mean if you ask the engine you're never
winning it's all zeros like the moment
you give up on e7 and you have to take
bishop takes e7 any move with the queen
to the last rank is just about i mean as
long as you're controlling
yeah but it's uh
but again it's cagey but it does say
that everything's a drop for four
minutes for anton
uh 15 seconds for wesley and this is the
type of moment that you just relish as a
grandmaster that you've got that you've
got this excessive amount of time to lay
a cunning trap peter you're just
thinking to yourself okay you're
calculating as fur furiously as you
possibly can how can you trick your
opponent uh
e7 instantly not no choice right yeah no
checks no nothing but but what about
queen to the eight
closest to the h4 check i think
and then a one and you don't have fusion
and there's no prepared yeah there's no
perpetual for you yeah
and now has to play queen a8
and shockingly apparently this is a draw
i'm not so sure how shocking that is
and he's done it yeah he has done it
he's got to
check him from behind
yeah
you know one good thing about the black
position now is that even like as long
as you don't blend the mate you can now
blunder the a2 pawn and you're still
very easily making it very easily yeah
so you know even if you have to play
something like you you panic blindly for
some reason you go rook h for checking
g3 i don't know king h7 is a very very
comfortable draw for you yes absolutely
so so
no there's no question zero zero risk
involved but
you can still lose this position
no because there's a bit i found a very
cute way to lose this position because
it's not actually losing to a check
and then queen takes chito
and it's a one queen h3
but we have bishop h4 giving us a very
important d7 square to run
bishop eight yeah otherwise i get mated
on f6 actually yes i get i get driven to
f6 and mated there
recently
but but bishop h4 actually gives me the
e7 square in this position like the
anastasia mate by the way
the the the i don't think that's the
construction yeah what's the anastasia
i'm not sure i'm very very important you
have the like
800 level chest knowledge yeah it just
went down ooh
we have king g8 he's ganging h7 king g8
instead of a check reach to check is
just a bad move obviously you never play
that but the mate is just a back rank
made by with rook and knight
what that's what it says i just googled
it let me google that for you
yeah king g8 queen a check yeah there's
always going to be perpetuals here you
would have to assume like that no that's
the light square the light squares are
too weak and if you play bishop eight
you can't create a thread which buffet
probably stops perpetuals
but the issue is with the bishop on the
f8 you can't really make any sort of
bishop on f's you need the bishop on f6
so yeah the problem i see with this is
even something like getting a five or
whatever yeah well just kind of okay
five and then back it's it's just kind
of immediate that i don't want to
provoke g6 i don't want to even invite
the calculations of g6 bishop g7
i would i would very much like yeah no
but he's done it in a way that g6
yeah with the bishop on the f8
you might still be able to draw off the
g6 but i really really don't want to be
calculating that so g6 queen takes e7
here it's completely impossible yeah so
you have to go back you have to go
somewhere yeah
or age six yeah or h6 why is h6
unplayable here 6 28 we had that
position actually okay
and a draw agreed yeah perpetual
they will now be slightly scolded by
arbiters i assume because i don't think
they didn't do the three reputations
three times repetition but yeah i'm
hoping the arbiters will be slightly
lenient yeah because yeah i mean it was
a very very hard-fought game and it was
a repetition alejandro starting with a
bang four decisive games out of five
that's the way uh
we like it that's why we play rapid
chess yeah it's not classical anymore
it's none of this one decisive
of action gameplay
beating favi to me is the big news of
the day we did have some matchups in
which you had favorites and the
favorites crushed young kristoff over
gabrielesku
richard rapport over chef chanco and
this one is not such a big difference
but anand over radic so we did have a
lot of the favorites taking game one for
themselves and remember rapid counts for
double
double the good for our predictions that
won their first round it's gonna be a
fun event already with the first round
we see that some players are just out
for blood here in warsaw even that game
that ended in a draw it was a game that
was full of them and absolutely and also
potential decisive yeah i should be
scolded and not the players because they
actually did make it a three-fold so
yeah i'm completely full of it
first things first a little housekeeping
let's go to cue boutique we're not going
to go on break because we have some
special guests in the house but first
what what can
folks get
uh peter absolutely uh yeah the the item
being promoted today uh from the
cubitique stl.com uh store is
a limited edition 2022 t-shirt which
features these very nice baggage tag uh
marks on both the front and the back of
the shirt with all the stops of the
grandchild store 2022
on the shirt there very nice pastel
color i saw kitay and tyler sporting
these shirts earlier in the day so they
obviously know
uh what's uh on sale
the goods
but let's first jump over to warsaw with
uh christian and the special guest gary
caspar
thank you uh yasser we are here with a
man that needs absolutely uh no
introduction the 13th world champion and
the patron of the grand chester mr gary
casper of gary first of all welcome back
to the show we haven't seen you since
romania no long time tell us a bit what
have you been doing in those last uh few
days
um yeah i
flew from romania just you know one
event in europe so
in switzerland then back to america it
was a few very busy days and then flew
here you know to poland so it's the life
is busy
mostly this of course it's it's
interviews and all the
events they are related to politics to
ukraine uh but there's always room for
chess so and and for uh
other things like you know machines
decision making
ai so it's the yeah i
i
never suffer from lack of attention
absolutely let's start with the
beginning yesterday we had an amazing
opening ceremony tell us about your
first impressions of that as well as
round number one
look i think it's uh it's very natural
to have a big event in warsaw now poland
is now uh
chess powerhouse um it's not just young
rich dududa uh
it's it's overall rise of interest for
the game
and um you know i
i thought it was you know just it's a
it's a great location
uh it's it's
we we know that superbed
has been trying and very successfully to
to set up new standards for organizing
events in europe so we we know that
saint louis now had its uh its its
standards but uh i could
i could see now and everybody can see
that that's uh super bad is doing
absolutely everything to make sure that
europe will be on par with with america
in in paying respect and how much to the
game and the players tell us a bit about
this partnership super bad is a new
partner for all three uh tour stops here
in europe tell us about that and the
development of this new partnership
look uh we know that superbet has been
founded by sasha druggage a former chess
player so and
and it's uh it
was a few accidental meeting i had with
him in bucharest
having one event it was a dinner
and uh and then he just he's he called
me and said so well probably you know i
could do more for the game of chess uh
super bet was rising uh uh it's getting
bigger and bigger and uh and uh with
superbed growing in size uh so the
the appetites to support chess also
growing so it's a it's a match made in
heaven
i think we had probably one of the
strongest chess sponsors in history
somebody who played at the master level
in in in in former yugoslavia and now
is very happy to see how chess
is being promoted of course their
area of interest so far is is uh eastern
europe but i believe it could be
expanded and
and i think that uh the european segment
of um granchester is safe for many years
to come one thing that i really love
seeing whenever i come to the opening
ceremony of this
tours as well as the rounds you see a
lot of young participants in the opening
ceremony in the simuls what is the
impact that this tour has on those young
aspiring players look it's it's a part
of the philosophy of superbed but it's
also as part of my own
promotional philosophy it's uh it's the
combining the granchester activities
with cosportus foundation activities and
uh
superb
now is is a very aggressive pursuing the
um chess um
uh
educational programs uh in
in in romania so i think it's uh
it's just a matter of time before they
succeed in just in putting chess in
romanian schools and we could see that's
in other countries like poland so uh
it's
it's not
centralized but in many parts of poland
you already you already have chess
programs and and these two trends they
they have to work
in synergy so you you need public
interest you need kids getting in the
game uh to offer uh incentives for
sponsors but also you know just as this
is you need them for you know to find
talent so it's a it's um
it's a self-sustaining
sustaining system and uh and uh poland
probably is now is it's most likely it's
still a leading country in eastern
europe but i will not be surprised to
see romania also catching up soon and
then again this is when you have few
countries just making so much progress
i'm sure the others will will try to
also to to
catch up in this tournament we have six
wild cards and once again the emphasis
is on youth how important it is for guys
like kiril shevchenko david gabrielesko
to play against the best chess players
in on the planet at this stage in their
careers you know i think it's again it's
very natural choice because chess is
getting younger and
and uh
[Music]
one of the problems of grant's two or
many
events of that type was that oh we had
the same faces you know moving from one
place to another it's like you know like
like a circus uh and having uh young
players though may not may not be at
this you know yet at that level but it
just offers them opportunities so that's
that's the way to to
to bring them in and just to to to to
train them but also it creates more
excitement because uh it's it's
people like to see new faces so we still
have old usual suspects but it's great
you know we have kerosene chengdu and
vishan and you know playing in the same
tournament so i'm really really happy to
see that you know we we are now here
just you know bringing the general
players were generations generations
apart
absolutely and speaking of excitement we
came uh from romania and we were seeing
three four draws per round in this class
it was
of course in this one we started off
with almost all decisive games the last
one between wesley was uh and korobov
was a draw but that one was very close
to being a decisive one as well now
let's go through the games what the game
uh did you have your eyes on
yeah the uh the the first game i looked
at was uh the duda gabrieles
yes so that's the yeah uh
yeah it's you know it's interesting
played very quick very uh um
uh
it's
quickly
and um i don't know and and i but but
but dude also just you know that was
blitzing out blitzing
all these moves and again i i i would be
very concerned about black's position
here this but but even like when you
find out after c4 i think he just you
know he
stopped yes he stopped yes yeah but i
don't know where the position was that
bad naturally this is this something is
wrong you know just you you have to
develop your pieces you know in a more
uh um
traditional fashion that's but still
there's one moment in the game that you
know just remains this is for me another
yes queen a5 b3 b7 d5 do the blade take
take take take the okay here that's the
did xc6 yes
yeah and here i think it's a c plate b3
yes which is in the which i think it's
not a good move yes that's again but
that's what i
maybe the only chance was was knight c6
knight c6 absolutely no because you have
to develop the pieces yes so and uh is
this that clear no absolutely not that's
that's what i just you know i i i looked
at it because i was doing my interviews
there and i said definitely
it's look bad but then i just if you
play knight c6
yeah but you look at your pieces out
yeah but look at white pieces you know
rook on this is there's still you know
way behind it takes f7 you can take all
the king of eight i don't know you can
take one you know already black seems to
be better nobody no but i know this
stuff the knight c6 by the way black can
always you know this castle is still
short castle is still possible
and after knight c6 you know it's
important this knight because this
knight eventually went on d4 and e6 so
how can you keep an eye on i would have
played nice to see you know just without
even thinking because without thinking
no you develop
instinctively just basically
yeah you're developing pieces that's
that's that's what i learned was a kid
perhaps a lack of experience for the
young superstar
it seems like it maintains the balance
at least from what c5 was very strong
it's not an easy end game to defend yeah
but this is but then again that's here
here you go the position that is just
you know that's the yeah it's uh yeah
it's really hard to actually do it's
i'm not sure it's his position is okay
yeah it seems to be but you know
but you need but you need to to
to
be a computer so yes
what's the what's or what was the only
movie i don't know
perhaps bishop to a3 would have been the
only move after cafe already immediately
not g5 yes 95 and the game collapses
a very difficult game for uh gabrielescu
but a good start for the young polish
superstar now let's go to this game
between uh i want to start with this one
chef chenkov versus rapport yeah because
we once again see another french yes
this time with e5 and we follow this
variation and another striking thing was
that rapport was blitzing out his moves
while his opponent was burning quite a
lot of time
up to this point still within theory
i think siri yes theory was also
not not not yet not yet i think we are
already out of theory i believe c4 was
the first move out of theory
yes so he played this move bishop to uh
v8 quite fast richie that is and after
c4 he had his first thing with his move
a6
now
at this point shevchenko had only 16
minutes and it seems that he was
struggling how did you uh assess his
position
i don't know i just it's uh
look
if
white succeeds in destroying black
center it's really dangerous but after
e6 you know
he ended up sacrificing the he did he
played the move knight to c3 and by the
way he blitzed out this moves after
giving up his piece and unfortunately
played this move bishops to c5 quickly
which is a mistake
not b6 yes knight to b6 wasn't necessary
in this position but once again it's so
difficult to play right because you have
to actually take on d7 and then just
simply take on b5 it doesn't feel very
natural
yeah but it's probably it's the uh
it's probably the dynamic equality yes
yes i would yes yeah yes
yeah and he played this move bishop to
c5 after which it seems like a report
interesting yes took over
yes this is it took over so a shaky
start for chef chenko now do you know
kiril at all have you been following his
career up to this point i think i just
you know i played him in the
simultaneous simul in kiev
in
2014 i was at the end of the 2014 so he
was quite young yeah he was he was very
young so yeah it's it's it's it's a it's
very spectacular career or so and i
think he's he's i don't know what he's
already the strongest ukrainian player
but he's definitely now going to to
going this way and i think this
tournament will be very helpful because
that's that's very important you know
even if you know what to do so you still
you have to go through this test you
know playing all the best players in the
world and i think this tournament will
actually help him to to
to um reveal his true potential and one
more game that i do want to take the
pulse from you is this one the clash
between a man that you know so very well
anand versus voit and they played this
quick uh theoretical
lines is it theoretical now it seems
like it was theoretical but uh it's uh
voitershek was playing really quickly
and at this point he had 26 minutes on
the clock and she only had 20 minutes
five
five
take take this is the moment vishu had
20 minutes and after this it just felt
like he took over
tell us about this how is he still
playing so well
i don't know it's that's it's uh
okay i remember wasting this mislove but
you know we just
wish you but actually which is is has
probably you know um
i know i'm thinking this whether coach
nori
like salvation now is 53 years 53
cautionary
yes
that's the only parallel so but still
you know i think rishi
is is is
doing
probably
as well probably even better and it's
not even only about the age but he's
quite inactive and he took second in
croatia now he starts off with i think
he's just you know that's important you
know this is probably it's part of the
character so he's just you know he's uh
he feels fine so he's not you know yes
at the end of the day chess is about
making decisions and it's there i think
she found this is the right
approach to the game so this is and it
it counts at rapid chess so but just he
makes moves you know he
doesn't work it does work so he's this
this calm and and and and and and his uh
the way just you know he just approaches
the game so i think it offers him you
know some kind of a psycho advantage and
maybe it's also being felt by the
opponent so and and look he knows how to
put the pieces in light square so that's
that's as you saw here is and it's very
quickly knight on the five knight c6
9197 and just you know all right pieces
arrived at the station on time
gary thank you very much for joining us
now before i let you go i'm going to put
you on the spot who's your favorite to
win this evening
no i don't know i i think
young christoph yeah so he will be it's
it's home tour but
look it's anything can happen it's it's
it's a it's a tough event it's blitz so
i would yeah but i won't be surprised if
we should as well so this is yeah
uh but again it's it's it's it's this is
the beauty about this tournament is this
you don't forget we have wesley saw we
have leonardo all of them can do really
well so gary always a pleasure to have
you on the show thank you very much and
we'll see you in the next few days
and we're actually going to go on a
break stay with us and we're going to
come back shortly
[Music]
it's a beautiful day in warsaw welcome
to the opening ceremony of the grand
chess tour we are going to have a
drawing of lots for the rabbit and blitz
event so let's have a look
[Music]
[Music]
let me say that you know i think with a
great certainty i can say that in this
whole
you have most likely one of the
michael's carlson's opponents
for the match
[Music]
it was an amazing opening ceremony we
heard these speeches we saw the ceremony
of drawing of lots we saw the
simultaneous exhibition and now it's
time to get back to the games
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
uh welcome back to our coverage of day
one of the super bed
uh rabbit and blitz in warsaw poland as
uh we we show you the playing hall
a very very beautiful venue
one of the most striking venues we've
seen in recent times absolutely um
and we had some uh footage of a uh
a opening ceremony a move
but we'll get that to you not not just
firsthand first
the standings after round one and
as you see on your screen uh
a very clear indication that you get two
points for a win here with
people already on two points despite
only one game
being played we had a very very decisive
round with only game being drawn is the
uh the the being the game
uh between wesley saw and anton korobov
which was also a very sharp very uh
combative
yeah
and and there we have the
the the footage of uh radix sitting down
to play game two against kiril
shivchenko and uh
a kind of a slight preview of our
pairings for the round this probably is
wesley versus fishy one one of the
ethernet the bearing for the round yeah
the
and this is the pairings
for round two uh there's there's a game
there between uh corvo and gabrielle's
the risk also starting with with a
double black this is really not fun
right not what you want
yeah in your first in your first ever
tournament of this magnitude to start
with with a double black is not great uh
fabi is white against young schustef in
a kind of a slight canvas preview there
it's a great game fantastic
richie is white against levon also very
very nice nice pairing uh radic plays
against kyo shivchenko and wesley are
white against vichy i like these pair
especially this one this is always a fun
game
yeah fabio against duda have produced
some amazing games through the years
well to begin with just that but also
again as we're saying the candidates
preview
as they will be going to uh madrid next
month to determine the challenger and we
saw there on our break that we were
listening to gary kasparov gary kasparov
saying that he expects the challenger to
emerge
from this field remember the field has
three candidates in it it has fabiano
caruana has jan srishav duda and it has
richard rapport so certainly three
players that could contend against
magnus carlsen for the world
championship out of those i think
and we do have our first move yeah this
is the first move and this is
radoslavidnyak president of the polish
chess federation and grandmaster in his
own right
uh making the first move in radix game
uh
uh against scale shivchenko radick and
radic
yes
if you could very quickly stand between
them you could make a wish
wishbone and you just break them apart
or just
nevermind
radical
to think of it that way uh we saw some
french defenses in round one and that
really perked us up uh
what are we expecting more french
defenses oh
sicilian in in the uh levon game against
uh
bishops
is he going to play h6 again now lavon
tried that that was played against him
that was actually against
him yeah that would that didn't work out
very well what do you mean he was much
yeah but
this is a reason to play h6 again right
right that's true
yeah bishop c4 this is what christian
was talking about earlier about richard
using the sidelines in every variation
and d3 played and we're almost out of
theory already yeah
declining too i mean i think h6 was
played first but a6 was also played in
the game so you were not really
deviating that much uh
just yet and we're referring to uh
arguably the decisive game of the maybe
not even arguably actually the decisive
game of the uh bucharest tie break in
which mbl needed a draw with the black
pieces against
uh against uh levon in the the final the
final uh rapid tie break which mvl won
he won three games in a row
on the final day to clinch
the first place in the bucharest class
interesting that uh we heard already
things here i'm guessing the choices
between uh
sort of a4 and bishop b3 and c3 even
though
of those two i i mean they all they both
allow knight a5 i think i figured out
why he's thinking and i i hate the idea
of giving up this bishop so much that i
actually probably would have played a3
or a4 there
um because knight a5 because knight a5
once again even bishop b3 doesn't save
the bishop because we don't we still
don't have the c2 square available to it
so if black wants it
uh you you can definitely consider
playing knight a5 here and uh
trading yeah it's it's slightly uh
time-consuming for black
but my
general feeling about you know picking
up the bishop pair is
so favorable that
would be i would be very seriously uh
considering it but levon actually does
play h6
uh the move that uh mvl played in a very
similar position against him h7 and
remember that yeah was to hide the
bishop playing
c2c c3 bishop g4 played yeah uh
preserving the bishop preserving the
bishop for sure and also white event i
assume expects to
uh be pushing in the center at some
point this is still very curious to me
uh yeah now bg2 e6 blade
yeah and we can we can actually go in
with a very similar idea that levon did
uh in the game right we could play h3 g4
knight h4 and therefore and a four in
the end blunders a pawn right so you
might have to play knight g2 but then
black expands with g6 d5 these positions
uh
in my mind they're much more associated
with
some of the bishop b5 check
lines that lead to or at least
could lead to positions like this but
seemingly bishop c4 also now
uh
results in these types of structures
obviously white is not obliged to do any
of this but
they could
all right well we'll let this percolate
a bit and turn over to alejandra as
we've got your favorite benko gambit on
the board alejandro spencer gavin it's
not a common guest at this level of
chess always love to see it this
variation with d4 knight f6 c4 c5 d5 e6
is the benoni there's other things to be
played but b5 straight into the banco
gambit
good old strategical ideas here
unfortunately nowadays the banker gambit
is regarded as a dubious way of playing
for black the computers have really put
a damp on the theory here for the black
side but a curious little way of playing
here for the black side after big takes
a6
bishop takes a6 and g6 are really the
top two
lines bishop a6 considered to be the old
line g6 the new line but e6 played in
state by shivchenko it was tried during
the late 80s early 90s as an alternate
way of playing the bank of gambit to
immediately strike in the center never
really gained a lot of popularity
because of the move knight c3 pawn takes
d5 knight takes d5 and a lot of players
felt that this only helped white didn't
really help black that much but kirill
always working hard on chess always
believing in sacrifices must have at
least an idea of the compensation in
this position objectively i don't think
this is good for black but in a rapid
time control and with the practical uh
choices of the clock i think it's fine
you get the initiative you're able to
play a bunch of moves on a row you
should be you should know the move
bishop g5 i mean it's
kind of a very forcing move and you gain
this time advantage you gain the
initiative you sacrifice upon is it good
enough to play against the player like
radik voitashik very prepared but also
very well versed in theory right some of
these players you want to take out of
theory some of these players you want
them to think on their own grounds and
here we have it white's up a pawn
but has some problems hasn't finished
his development of course the amb file
the typical benko gambit type of
compensation where you have this
pressure against the queen side pawns
this is going to be fun
yeah talking about fun i see this uh
huge heavyweight clash between wesley so
and vishy and nan yeah but we'll get to
that for now we're going we're going
back to warsaw to take a look at a
special interview that we have prepared
for him
thank you uh peter we are here with
radoslav yadinyak the polish chess
federation president uh radoslav welcome
to the show tell us a little bit about
how difficult it is to put a tournament
of this magnitude together
uh well this is so um this in class of
tournament it doesn't happen very often
and it's always difficult and there's a
lot of new new things and new tasks uh
some things you have never done before
and this is this is just such a
prestigious event full of top players
it's not the first such tournament in
poland we had world championship we had
european championship over the last year
and there are so many uh
problems of course because we have so
many players every player has
has its his own um plans uh
wishes uh and you know it's it's it's a
long story and difficult thing
i like that the tournament takes place
especially here in the polish jewish
museum
and this is a this is especially uh nice
because it reminds us that
we have great connections between polish
and jewish
people
polish and jewish fought to
play it just together before the second
world war uh we both both nations uh we
won uh gold medal in chess olympiad in
hamburg 1930 and many other many other
great results especially in chess
olympiads players like akiba rubinstein
and mingo naidov just to mention the
most important and the best players
of polish national team were of course
of jewish origins and that's great we're
playing in this absolutely quite a
wonderful place important and tell us a
bit you took over four years ago and
polish chess has pretty much exploded
how important it is to see two of your
best chess players uh do the voitasha
participating against the best chess
players in the world
yes they are well today
they are they are well they work so hard
that it was quite obvious they will be
in the in the top of the world
especially youngsters of duda will just
who will play the candidates a
tournament in madrid uh just to to
challenge magnus carson if if possible
uh well
i like well i like them playing here
another another tournament especially
such
such a big event as super but by many
consider as the strongest tournament
ever played
in poland in poland this is possible
when you look at every trading this is
possible probably you have to calculate
it somehow but i think this is true very
close very close very close it must be
the strongest event and uh
well that's that's great they are
playing here but this is not like a gift
they deserve uh playing in this
in this big tournament
but i also can't that
they will lead polish national team to
medal on the chess olympiad
and how important it is for the younger
generation to have two leaders like
these two players spearheading the
revolution in polish chess that is
extremely important i remember as i'm
just grandmaster i remember when when i
was young
and we didn't have such leader but still
we had some round-robin tournaments with
even with anatoli kaiko with some
players and i went to watch them live i
wanted to see the
best players in the world
but they were not polish but now uh
young players they see duda and voitacic
who are polish and this must be a much
better boost and there is nothing uh
strange that this we have so many young
people starting address tens of
thousands new polish
players young
just five six seven eight years old uh
they started playing they they watched
duda and voitasha and they will be more
and more and in probably ten years we'll
have another duda
or something like this well um probably
in the audience right now because the
theater is packed with young players as
well now i'm going to uh put you on the
spot before we go back into the games
who's your favorite to win this evening
dude it is thank you very much i think
he'll win he's especially good
in rapid and with stress he is indeed
thank you very much for joining the show
thank you guys back to you thank you
christian i'd like to immediately turn
your attention peter if you will to the
game of wesley so versus vishy and then
for me these are the positions i like
the most where the kings are on opposite
sides and both players are you know
trying to
attack the other
opponent's king with everything they've
got now in the
in this moment
wesley is king is actually the more
vulnerable he has less pollen
in this respect yes but
structurally white is of course much
better so uh white gained a lot of space
by pushing e4 and black pretty much
ignoring it allowing e4 e5 uh
doing this with the king on g1 would be
very like pretty much unthinkable i
think because it kind of ruins your
position ruins your position to such a
degree and gives white such an easy
attack on the king's side long term
that
it's just a very bad mistake to not
challenge the white center like this but
uh the viking is on c1 which is a whole
whole other deal
yeah and
that's a bold move people are listening
listening to you i think
you are becoming you're becoming a
little bit too much of an influence in
world chess i think i think i just lost
control but fear i'm not i mean i'm a
pond grubber but man that's that's a hot
that is that is a very very um wow risky
move uh wow and wesley must know what
he's doing here because after let's say
queen a5 i think of an a5 is by far the
most natural reply sure uh
it looks
very scary but i guess maybe we can go
all the way back and then go like knight
ec3 and pretend that everything is sort
of connected knight
maybe take on before first and then
knight c3 because if you if you keep the
queen on c6
it gets attacked by both rookie six and
bishop like take with the rook here
and this is one way to i think lose your
queen right you go knight c3 yeah and i
go bishop b7 26 rookie six and it's gone
just that's just gone that's why he felt
grabbing the pawn could have issues so
that was why you went back right away
yeah i i think this might be what what
uh wesley is intending because otherwise
i like i can't imagine staying on six
and remaining safe for very long
my goodness
vicious starts by taking on d2 first
which is also possible i'm i'm i wasn't
sure why we're supposed to do it uh this
early it didn't seem like it was gaining
us any particular
uh temporary queen a5 yeah it looks so
yeah is king takes you to ever move i
mean rook takes it to his plate
automatically and he has already played
it but i was wondering if maybe there is
some argument for getting the king away
from the c file and yeah perhaps like
walking it to safety
but it's a bit too i would have
considered it uh
i don't know
yeah fbs creeping on a day i don't know
this looks really really uh yeah and i'm
wondering i'm wondering if fishing tends
to go like 95 de bishop d7 or something
but
there will be one explanation for why
we've taken on g2 but i don't think it
works i haven't been able to make this
work yeah even clean takes d5 if all
else fails it just leads us it leads to
like an end game with a with an extra
pawn on e5 at the moment i still don't
see yeah but also but also
the x is fine yeah yeah rook c8 knight
ac3 and g5 g4 is not a move so we can't
really
make this really be a move
with um oops sorry yeah so
i'm not sure why we've
why we've taken on g this early but
if we can still play queen a5 i assume i
don't think
a lot has changed necessarily
one of the reasons why i might
get behind bishop takes d2 but it's it's
a long one i get to go queen a one check
one day and i've got something like the
rook is hanging like so
something like this of course i
understand you're going to drop the
bishop yeah we have bishop b1 it's it's
so
that was the only reason i can imagine
why rook takes
it it does confuse working honestly it
does confuse me a little bit i i didn't
think it was necessary at all to um and
also just to continue the point once
more
you know
why did he take on d2 not sure alejandra
what have you got for us you're looking
at the uh benko camping of course i'm
talking and looking at the pink coat of
course you are queen e4 on the board we
have a couple of moves since we laughed
at bishop e7 knight takes e7 just give
me the bishop not only will i be upon
but also the pair of bishops what does
black have in return tempe knight is
developed knight is developed about to
castle these guys
it's going to take a while it's going to
take a while to get them all out of
their back rank and after the move
knight f3 h6 was played and now here
white has a choice you could take on f6
queen takes f6 hits in pawn on b2 though
you could retreat the bishop to f4 or to
h4 and the engines really like bishop h4
is the only good move but bishop f4 was
played and this is the issue queen e4
very nice move by
attacks the bishop and says this doesn't
this help white develop doesn't it just
help me play e3 and bishop d3 yes it
does and no it doesn't knight before on
the board this is the current position
and now you have this deadly threat of
knight c2 check you'd love to play
bishop d3 not on time to do so because
the knight also guards the d3 square a2
is hanging knight c2 is a threat the
edge is saying you must play the move
rook siwa and give up a2 the position is
a huge mess both sides with their
chances because black does give up a
couple of tempi himself e3 was played
the knights already developed so in some
cases you can even destroy all of
white's queen side and not get an
advantage because white will be the one
with compensation with the pair of
bishops and active play but that's all
we're talking about we're not talking
about the typical bankrupt component and
i'm pushing forward in this position
this is a mess here between voitasha and
chef chenko
meanwhile in the game between levonado
with the black pieces and richard report
we have another huge mess both sides
opposite castling king on b8 will
certainly be safer than the king on g1
but there are some tactical ideas for
example if you move the king this knight
might disappear from f4 and allow the
move bishop f4 they could manage the
diagonal take advantage of the weak in
c5 you could play knight g2 you could
even consider taking on h5 like a good
yasser would do the engines are saying
the knight g2 is definitely the better
move but after queen f5 check you could
also consider queen d7 i like black's
position because you're a little bit
better developed and you have this
pressure on the pawns the engines are
saying it's not a big deal chances are
about equal i don't understand why they
say that i love black's position from
the get-go perhaps analyzing a little
bit deeper you start to realize that
it's not so easy to coordinate black's
pieces and then white still has chances
of course there are some pawns hanging
in black's position namely c5 and h5 and
there we go
yeah knight g2 probably needs to be
played because you do have to start
threatening bishop f4 and you need to
develop this bishop uh at least the
knight or nfr i think has to go
somewhere right in order to be able to
play bishop f4 oh very exciting games uh
i must say that i like the way this
round as
do we say tatted up yeah it's shaping up
very nicely uh the the one game there
that is a slight exception i think is
the game between the two candidates the
game between fabi and yang shishtov
uh where
they're debating this this line that
we
actually
uh discussed
without putting pieces on the board
there this end game that uh that yasser
now uh brought up on your screens
uh it's the kind of a the new and
potentially improved version of this
really strange end game with the double
def pawns where black includes h6 to
have the ability to play bishop h7
instead of bishop g6 as this game yeah
and uh the current position is i think
it's a demonstration of what black is
trying to achieve in this line you have
these permanent weaknesses they're not
going to go away you're never trading
the f5 pawn for anything unless white
finds a beneficial way of pushing h3 and
g4 but in general these are you this is
your structure for the rest of the game
it doesn't look very appetizing
but you get a very decent square for
your uh for your knight here it went d7
b6 c4 d6 e4 and looks very very
long-winded but incredibly difficult to
stop for white
uh if white ends up pushing it away with
f2 f3 that weakens white's own pawn
structure a little bit and then i guess
it goes back to c4 and exerts pressure
against the e3 pawn
and the pawn f5 yes it's weak but it's
very difficult to push against attack
exactly and it's only a weakness as if
you can attack it right and castle's on
the board castle surprises me a little
bit i thought the king belonged on e6
but right
it still can make a beeline there
nothing not nothing ventured nothing but
it did it did seem to me that you wanted
to
right here after the move rook you did
want a kind of a structure where as you
say your king steps up to e6 you defend
the pawn very nicely your rook will
slide over
and like you say even though the
structure is very favorable for white
black's very solid
great boring strategic chess we'll keep
an eye on that peter let's uh let's go
to more definitely lighting past
the more exciting position exactly one
more end game we have here are kind of a
typical issues come from this is like a
queen's gambit with queen a4 no this was
a this was a rug goes in uh with queen
a4 check where
uh anton is playing for a small but kind
of a stable plus here 96 is a clever
little move by gabrielesko using the
fact that rook takes b7 currently is
impossible because knight c5 picks up a
full piece
attacking both the rook and the bishop
on d3 meaning that the rook will have to
go back and then very importantly for
black black is just in time to play g5
d4 in such a way
that e3 4 is not great in response
because we have knight f4
exactly
i wonder if it's still actually
something that white needs to choose
like play king d2 here knight takes g2
and rook c7 perhaps
and start switching to like tactical
compensation and then playing
and playing for dynamic equality yeah i
mean other quality dynamic compensation
yeah with the king coming to uh
d3 i i would say that uh this is you
know still
a three result game where absolutely
because
yeah because if plug gets to trade the g
g-pawn for the e-pawn first of all even
tactically it's slightly awkward for
white to meet the with the king on e1 uh
still there in in the sights of the rook
on e8 but even if you could find a
comfortable way of doing it uh
black i think equalizes very comfortably
if you don't play e4
and uh
you do have to mention that uh you know
in this tournament uh the young romanian
will have a very very large you know
side sides painted on his back and yeah
it will be a challenge yeah there's no
question about it no what i mean is uh
anton in general is he he is a very very
uh ambitious player uh
the best one you know against wesley
exactly but uh white against gabrielesco
he uh will not be uh trying to
sort of
allow very safe equality he will now i
think the reason something like rook
situ hasn't been played yet is as i now
realize you can play rook g7 here b7
loses a piece rook d7 doesn't which is
funny because you're inviting the same
kind of fork but only this time if you
fork uh the rook will actually cover and
protect the bishop with rook takes deep
exactly so maybe rook d7 is a better
choice the question is like rook g8 you
will have to take yes
but then we do get time to play
something like king g2
and claim that we're possibly ever so
slightly better because this island is
still in isolani right you're not
getting rid of it yeah if you give this
position to somebody like vichy
i think you might as well just offer a
draw here with white vichy has been
holding these positions for the last
like 25 years with his eyes closed and
you know one arm type behind his back
but you know this is not this is not
vishy and like i i personally probably
would not equalize here
it's it's one of those where i think the
quality of the defender on on the black
side is very very relevant
okay and going back to uh the game of
levon for a moment because this was just
the moment where alejandro was
saying the knight on f4 has got to go so
that you can play the so you can
threaten the move bishop f4 you don't
want to play knight takes h5 and mess up
your king side structure but
uh knight g2
covering up threatens bishop f4 if
if
force bishop d6 well there goes a piece
i'm enthralled by the match of shirts
here
the match of oh
richie is trying to uh
give levon some competition in the
situation
yeah baby
beliefs
yeah
very nice and then just uh randomly some
kind of uh
uh
like a an emblem or a medallion there or
around the shoulder you know the
yeah i i i'm telling you it's a rare
thing for me to say but i think levon
got outplayed on this one wow it happens
every once in a while it happens the man
is human i mean
can i get an amen
yeah
yeah
i agree i mean i agree rich's riches is
definitely the more the more adventurous
of the two and you don't you don't get
to see that very often
out outstyled right in the short
department what do we feel about his
position though that's now now now we're
talking uh
this is
a challenge for black right crazy knight
g2 because okay
first of all
g5 could shut down the king's side and
that would be
not what black wants to see black would
just generally love to take but i don't
think that this piece actually it
doesn't seem to work out right it's
queen takes f6 here and you know you
don't have time to play gh because
bishop to 86 gets the queens off
exactly this is the problem yeah
otherwise maybe you could consider it
right that's you would consider it
probably doesn't work anyway because i
really don't see anything up against
knight e3 understood but you consider it
but it's just a deadline right so knight
g2 with this
a concept of bishop f4 is
by the way c5s hanging uh there's issues
there's issues for black to solve i
think they're pretty clear
i mean i
i'm not happy that
no no i don't know no
maybe you got an id4 and just buy the
bullet
bite the bullet knight e4 says alejandro
and bishop d6 yeah and something like
knight takes c5 here and you go i don't
know hg and start opening files on the
queen on the king side
it will cost you your entire center so
you know who knows if it's good or not
but
it's something it's yeah it's playable
it's
it's kind of hope chess a little bit
something like this you mean
yeah 94g for you and sort of let's go
but i'm not quite sure where the the
the optimism in the let's go comes from
rook g8 and just claim that the white
king is not very safe but
i i kind of barely believe myself
you never met that larson did you
dude was ruthless in such fun
you know you would point out to me
nobody believes you yes
it was like
he was right uh yeah i don't believe
that pawn sacrifices either i was
thinking about this move he played them
with king eight after a
long thought but i didn't know how it
really improved the queen
like did you really want to go bishop
before queen b6 i think that's the
intention otherwise i don't really
understand the previous but the way that
work i can take on c5 right exactly
isn't that just like a tempo
well we'll find out
and yeah there he goes queen b6 and he's
you cannot take on c yeah you have to
play
you cannot take on c5 no you can't you
know you you actually have to play
something like queen b5 here which is
really weird yeah he's done it he's done
it and queen b5 played instantly let's
see well he wasn't about he wasn't able
to blunder a piece in for a penny in for
a pound as uh
levon
has gone
sacrificial mode full rogue
for rogue
yeah rook a1
rook ae1 that may be a nice start ideas
of rook takes c7 i don't know how strong
that idea is but looks
like
maybe it needs addressing
i guess he wants knight e4 i don't think
he cares about the f7 pawn one one with
look
when you lost one two what's the third
i mean we're in
i mean
x5 has now moved we can start
considering black is black is dreaming
um
peter
anything to be recommended for let's say
just shutting down the kings i mean
it's like yes you can't blow up the king
side yes it's much it's much harder to
open it up i can play f6 and claim that
the pawn on g6 will get picked up when
if it were i played
uh h4 a la tempo and i suddenly realized
i don't have to you don't have to yeah
kg1 or bhp3 or yeah i should be maybe
not so much i should wait for you to
coax
the move
h3h4 out of me i don't know lavon is
going to have to really prove some
skeptics
hear that his
double pawn sacrifices sound
alejandro what's happening over in the
vichy
uh wesley so matchup
well this queen has been brought all the
way back from the position it had on c6
it was on d6 at some point but it got
kicked around and whoa uh it got kicked
around and this was the compensation
that vichy has in this position a lot of
initiative he's down upon but look at
this king look at the major pieces that
white has they don't make a great
impression bishop a6 bishop c2 didn't
want to trade the bishops the engine
hating the idea of bishop c2 takes on e2
was great because after rook takes a2
rook a6 puts yet another question on
white's position this pressure on the a
file can be quite annoying knight b6
knight takes a4 there's certainly an
idea queen a5 and knight b6 is an idea
tons of ideas in this position for black
queen d3 was played and quickly we'll
have to move queen a5 and this is the
situation wesley with 12 minutes fishing
with 17 extra pawn for white but not
clear where your plan is because black's
plan is simple you keep attacking things
on the queen side you keep putting
pressure until something hopefully
collapses whether you have to move the
knight and you get queen a1 and queen
takes b2 whether you play rook c8 and
exploit some sort of pin somehow or
another you're kind of hoping the
white's position collapses the more
pressure you put on and every move that
you play comes with pressure you have to
get rid of this c2h7 pressure at some
point but besides that everything is
running with tempo right knight e6 will
come at some point knight b6 will come
at some point this rook on a6 could
always improve to the c6 square tons of
pressure on wesley's position
not the type of trust that he really
likes he likes the safe advantages not
getting pressured he likes converting
positions in which he's minimally better
but visually sacrificing him pawn and
saying look i'm going for the initiative
and going for the kill and i think this
is making the american very
uncomfortable absolutely i love the
knight on f8 which completely blunts
the
attack along the diagonal but is ready
to leap into the fray any moment with
knight e6 love this idea like if i'm
black in this position i'm really
eyeballing peter the move rook before
if i can get the knight to drop back
then i can go even night beast honestly
the idea of 96 is so important here i'm
willing to spend the tempo on
g6 uh we're attacking on the queen side
but i think if if we get to play 96 the
y position just collapses because the
pawn on d4 will be very weak now the
four ideas will start coming in
currently it's sort of impossible
because i don't think anybody allows
queen takes h7 check even though i guess
in some positions you could maybe dream
of it right because it goes to like we
play king f8 we play king e7 if needed
but generally speaking i don't think
white will ever have time enough to play
h4 h5
meaning that we can quite safely
spend the tempo on g6 and then go 96 and
as i said i think the inclusion of that
knight in the attack pretty much settles
the game which is i think why
i i saw briefly that the engines were
toying with the idea of throwing in e5
yeah that's the top of the engine just
to make a steak with the pawn and to
make sure that and make sure that
yeah
giving up the one you know very nice
extra pawn on e5
just to make sure that this particular
beast doesn't join the phrase the the
fray
yeah but okay i haven't said that i mean
i understand the knight on e6 but like
i'm just going to put a move on the
board for white for a moment i mean i'm
seeing this move and i don't see the i
am happy to
leave the knight stuck behind like how
do you make significant progress after
let's say knight c3 yeah that was the
night that i wanted to i wanted to go
queen a1 check force bishop b1 in the
near future drop a knight on this
doesn't really look like mate but maybe
it will in a moment right i'm wondering
if i can actually sort of continue
ignoring it but i don't think i can
takes b2 an issue sorry i apologize
rugby to us
that might be a real issue
like in my mind my king is already on d2
in all of these lines
you're ready to get out of dodge i'm not
i'm okay pretending it's safe on c1 i'm
sort of running in in most cases i was
even considering running after
i'm thinking that more and more i'm
looking at it you you you may be running
but you're probably going to start with
b2b3 yeah yeah i think i think it's
needed i was also going to suggest rook
before b3 honestly instead of knight c3
okay but yeah be three with the idea of
maybe playing queen jitsu or perhaps
just king like king t196 i'm really
worried you will actually give up on h7
to to take on d4
right especially if you put your king on
the e1 especially
exactly correctly
right it's it's very scary for white it
certainly is it's very scary for what
wesley upon to the good he's facing a
decision where he has
to make a choice of e5 e6 that's not an
easy no
move to play burning time yeah he's
burning time we've been talking about
this game for a while yeah and he has
not made a move he's down
yeah
vishy was still 17 basically
this is very tough situation for wesley
so yeah no question and you have to say
that
one facet of
why this position is so much better for
black and at least in practical play
it's just how much easier it is to just
throw things at the white at the white
gate
and hoping
you know that something sticks whereas
for white you do
hear i think feel very acutely that oh
yeah what what a strong point is
man is not bad at chess i mean
i know fight this move that's remarkable
what it's really what's
truly yeah recognizing that knight f8 to
e6
will be
incredibly powerful hitting the pawn on
d4 as
uh peter has been mentioning that the
knight on e6 combined with the rook
coming to b4 is too powerful we still
like black here but uh yeah the the fact
that he came to this conclusion is very
very impressive i think yes
yes
but even after though he
no his decision was still bad it's not i
can magically fix things but it's better
what's what's the follow-up though uh
alejandro well i'm not really sure what
the follow-up is we're gonna leave
wesley do it you have to play b3 at some
point i think you do have to play this
defensive move at some point just to
secure uh your queen side otherwise it
will fall maybe i should try running you
know like quinjitu king jiwan king one
king of two right it feels very slow but
black also isn't really winning the game
that easily now that you know we've sort
of secured the pawn on d4 for the
immediate future look at this but it's
it's obviously still very uh very
attractive yeah okay
i think he still goes b3 here and maybe
he wants to like try to meet 96 with
rookie six now
knight b6 with rookie six yeah maybe wow
and alejandro what do you have for us
well this
mess between richie and levon
came down to this position the move g5
was played in this position the knight
did get spooked to e4 and then the move
rook d1 came on the board very logical
targeting the central part on d5
developing the rook and now there's a
lot of choices here for the black pieces
rook hg8 is possible that was played in
the game f6 is played in the could be
played in the game immediately and it's
better to do so right now and i'm going
to explain why in a second if you play
f6 right now the main line runs rook
takes d5
rook takes d5 queen takes d5 and the
intermediate f takes g5 so you are
hanging in the knight but i am
recapturing on g on f4 the bishop you
cannot take on g5 it's officially
defended so there's still counter play
here it's a weird position instead the
game went rook h8 h4 and now f6 and here
i think levon forgot about something
because after rook takes d5 rook takes
d5 this was not played in the game rook
takes d5 queen takes d5 you're not
longer just hitting the knight on e4
whoops
you're also hitting the rook on g8 so
actually lose a ton of material
immediately after the move rook takes d5
your position more or less falls apart
and the difference is that if you take
on g5 immediately after rook takes d8 i
distracted rook thank you for the free
tempo with the move h4 because here
after rook takes d8 h takes g5 h takes
g5 still not played actually rook takes
dna not played yet h6 g5 could come on
the board and let's count them white is
currently up two points you could take
one with check but do you really want to
do so because what about the resulting
end game i mean you have this powerful
pawn on the g file this knight coming to
h4 bishop better than the knight this
king in the middle of nowhere when it
comes to an end game so you don't want
to play bishop takes c5 if you pin
yourself with knight takes g5 then well
your pieces are all here you don't want
to trade on b3 we talked about the end
games just push your pawn push them baby
g6 comes from the board hard for black
to stop this because of the activity of
white's pieces the engines are saying
this is a winning advantage the mover
takes the eight rook takes the eight was
followed with a bishop c7 instead of h6
g5 a completely different type of
solution but also a solution because now
everything is hanging on black side the
bishop is attacking the rook on d8 the
knight on e4 is hanging you could play
rook e8
you could play rook e8 it defends
tactically the knight on e4 because of
bishop takes c5 i'm pretty sure
yeah i'm not sure about that rookie
that's two pieces in a rook for her a
queen no queen takes c5 checks it's with
a chat yeah quintex five check wins
material there right but i think you
don't have to play winter c4 after okay
there are
other other options available and i'm
thinking one of them might be queen g6
uh looks like richie's in
the driver's seat in that game just want
to turn our attention to our candidates
match up with fabi versus duda and you
were saying peter that this pawn
structure of blacks you know the static
f5 f7 you're kind of like i didn't
mention that g4 is maybe the one way and
yeah to do something about it and even
after allowing the exchange or the
undoubling of the pawns you're still
black i still love people you still
prefer white here yeah for sure and
after rook g8 i'm thinking you know
white all the way here he just gets to
play f3 and maybe start yeah okay h1
knight g3 yeah yeah the h6 spawn is weak
there's still no real counter play on
the queen so it's like some way away
from starting anything on the queen side
help me out alejandra there was a game
that wesley so needed to win as black
against sam savion and he got the
structure did westley
and it was he played that for a while no
he didn't slide for a win with black
that's that's the striking part for me
like i don't really understand i
understand people playing this line i
just don't understand playing that in
the must-win game yeah it went exactly
as you would expect uh
sam savion made a draw from a position
of great strength in our in our
that's not what happened let me just do
this again sorry
anton by the way did follow our analysis
for quite
some moves in his game but nida 4 is
this to me
it looks
it's like horrible
it's not horrible for black but it's so
i mean it's a clear
every time i see this line i just don't
know why black
never plays it whoever plays it it looks
like on the great games i see they make
an easy draw yeah and like most of the
games i see it's some kind of some kind
of suffering right yeah yeah yeah
it's true by the way let's just check in
with anton because when we left it we
were right here in this part yeah roxy
seven and you were you you and just one
small one small mention here uh i think
anton played roxy to specifically
inviting the line that we see on the
screen right now and talking about you
know vichy and end games and things
instead of d5 d4 just very briefly on
move 21
i think maybe it was better not to get
sort of baited by d5d4 just play rook c8
king king f8 king 7 king d6
i have a feeling i have a feeling you
know sort of a wiley by the old folks as
visual issue would just kind of ignore
the whole d4 excursion because what we
got in the game black might be fine in
the game but i think
it's exactly what it's exactly what
white wants a much sharper position with
very very double-edged play i think b5
is a good move because stopping bishop
c4 was a priority
uh and now yeah it seems like black lost
the f7 pawn for nothing but the the
young romanian correctly correctly
calculated that he wins the ufo pawn
but the bishop on g3 is so strong but i
want to point out this really cool movie
i love king d1
because
when you play fast chass rook c7 94 you
just think you take on east you take on
e4 f3 you put the rook on f7 because i
don't think you can prevent that right
right rookie 6 g6 i guess right right
then you see that rookie 6 rook g6
actually holds relatively comfortable
you are up upon us black it's going to
take you forever to
get it back and by that time i'll have
enough counter play for equality but
king d1 is an excellent move
you just move the king out of the way
the knight is completely dominating f7
is still a threat your cap7 is still a
threat and the bishop is just a better
piece you keep the pressure up yeah
despite despite black being
up up upon here i'm picking i'm picking
white everywhere all day long like rook
c6 and
your domination is such and the king on
g8 actually is sort of weak enough that
white is never worse i don't know how
much better
white is but white runs zero risks and
it's very very good practical chess by i
think
black probably should be holding this
with very precise play because it's
difficult to create threats
yeah well like very hard you know the
one the one move i that occurs to me
even in this position is like king g8h8
and i still don't know what my next move
is left like white goes king g2 here
right what's my next move
the rook is frozen uh yeah this rook is
if you go rookie seven rookie five you
probably also resign so you can't do
that either the pawns aren't really
going if you go to seven g5 you probably
get mated
uh you you can't really play g6 rook f6
you also kinda resign you can play
knight of fade but what kind of a move
is that yeah the more the more i talk
about this position the more i want to
retract my earlier statement
it looks borderline lost despite being
upon up wow yeah it's pretty bad
actually wow
okay we'll definitely keep an eye on
that as the wily veteran uh
tries to take down his youthful uh
opponent again dropping in on the game
between
um
richard rapport and lavonna rooney and
this this
moment i think richie probably had
cleaner solutions yeah rookie one is a
good move i think but after that takes
e5 i still don't understand he has been
completely ignoring the very simplistic
idea of taking on g5 i think at some
point you kind of need to
stop he does have a pressing threat
after bishop d6 right yeah like i can
take on b3 right
how bad is that end game like i take on
b3 you take on b ah there's rook a1 made
there in the end yeah that's uh it's not
made though i have knight a7
but like if we continue like he played
bishop b6
bishop david yeah which appears to force
the trades
but how about he goes knight d3 that as
well yeah that that maybe is a better
choice yeah that this one knight takes b
yeah like takes takes a bgh like why am
i losing
just because of rookie
knight h7 knight a7
i just i still don't really we've traded
so much and there is nothing left on the
king's side
but this looks jewish to me
i want to play b6 king b7 eventually
i'll i'll unpin myself because yeah but
like how do you create threads well i
had a foreign but by the way uh sorry
knight d3 which is a choice i think i
think that's a clever choice there by
levon because i like knight d3 it forces
the issue yeah much
cleaner and i'm assuming he's moving his
rook
where rookie two i suppose because i
don't think we want to allow knight
takes between knight c4
um although h6 g5 is also a strong
threat right maybe rookie three
so let's it's within those two the other
squares make no sense whatsoever to me
no because then yeah yeah walking into a
fork right which is why i was saying
rookie two but it's also like rookie two
maybe there's even time to include gh
and then go about your business yeah
very important move because you want to
break the pin
by playing for h3 with group g this
looks fine for black i agree
um
this is not the clean i thought richie
was actually in
the driver's seat for sure i'm not
exactly sure where he let it slip i can
show you i can show you exactly where he
let it slip it was a tactical detail
that he missed and perhaps one that he
would find in classical chess but in
rapid i think it's tougher the move
bishop d6 is certainly tempting because
of all the pins and the potential
checkmates we saw on the a1 line if you
force knight takes b3 unfortunately what
richard missed was the move knight d4
and the engines are loving this move not
a lot of squares for this queen for
example if you take down on b2 just the
idea of knight takes pawn takes and
destroying uh your position on the kick
on the king side sorry not the king and
the queen side by the king is going to
be sufficient queen g6 wins the tactical
rook takes e7 also wins but why
calculate it when you see that queen g6
just hits everything so you can't really
go anywhere with the queen after knight
d4 but if you take on d4 pawn takes we
have a very similar situation except
this knight on c6 no longer exists so by
the time that you move the king's the
knight somewhere let's put it on d3
again i take on b5 and oops
i
take on b5 take on b5 go rookie 3 and
again you have some issues with
checkmate but more importantly the move
bishop d6 is coming on the board taking
advantage of the fact that this is a
full pin on the rook and black ends up
losing so knight d4 was a huge move in
this position and missed by richard
because bishop d6 did allow the move
knight d3 very precisely spotted by
levon and we get into this double knight
end game
i would still prefer white the engines
are saying not a chance it's just a draw
two knights are going to hold this
easily especially after knight d1 i just
noticed that c3 cannot be different if
not you want to knight a4 yeah the
entire queen side disappears and even if
the g pawn ends up questing you the
knight by that point your entire queen
side is gone like you play knight h4 and
knight f4 here knight takes c3 g6 and
honestly like knight takes just just
just remove the chance to blend or
something i
i think this one will end up in a drop
yeah it just goes yeah yeah he's very
professional he spends zero seconds
in zero seconds and they'll find all of
the white pawns just disappeared
they'll find a way to make a draw we can
switch out of this okay there's plenty
of chassis very good i wanted to do
wesley is in trouble against vichy let's
go to
wesley yeah of course when we left it we
had just seen the move rook h1 to e1 now
black has the initiative yeah black is
hunting the king but more importantly he
hasn't sacrificed anything more than
that he's up upon oh he's even won upon
oh one upon he's a bottom a7 is free and
passed our favorite living conditions
and ten minutes against three for
vicious this is fishy's game right
okay this has to be vichy's game exactly
night on a6 threatening night before
finally this sleeping horse
wakes up with a decisive threat i don't
know how you save this position i mean
black has very few weaknesses they're
all held by this knight on f8 as we
expected the draw between rickard and
levon
lavonne's saying i escaped dude you had
me yeah i mean look at that look at that
smile like okay now the houdini-like
escape peter it's on a roll by the way
this is one of my um
well
i'm not going to say i'm insightful or
anything like that but one of the things
that vishy
throughout his career he was very very
active player sometimes i felt he played
too much right now he he's coming back
to the board and he's hungry he's
feeling it you know he started with a
win which is always a nice feeling and
he just did he just resigned he just
resigned he just said oh straight up
yeah i mean like yeah i don't even know
what to do he's facing knight b4
and that's just going to win the house
but
resigns yeah yes vicious
gets respect respect
i mean he wouldn't resign against me
yeah
not in a million years when we signed
this position i'm uh i'm a little
stunned by that decision yeah it's it's
it's a bit early but but you know it's a
bad visual i will pass the the mic to
somebody else here on the subject of
resignation
early resignation
and for me i mean ooh wesley dude guess
about wesley richie's two out of two
yeah two out of two to start the
tournament true that true that uh a game
that we haven't looked at is between
radic
and kiro not in a while yeah right
because relic is a bit better
relic is a bit better specifically
because black had to trade queens on the
g6 square meaning that the bishop on c3
is a bit of a monster i see what you
mean right there yeah with a ball on f6
here i think black is completely fine
but upon g6 actually f2 is still hanging
yeah i have to play something awkward
like rookie 1 or rook f2 which
yeah those are not the squares rookie 2
or rook f1
which limits our rook activity very much
i thought i could play rook a1 my my
speech about white being a bit better
was based on the idea of playing rook a1
here which is not really a move because
nobody gives up on f2
exactly
does anybody give up on us tonight i
play rook a4 here no way
and let's jump to warsaw for a quick
comment by anastasia
hello everyone i was actually hearing
you talking about wesley saw and why he
resigned against vishanand and it came
to my mind the game which wesley saw
recently played in the grand chest in
the grand prix in berlin against uh
tabata by iranian player and when he
also resigned in the position was
actually equal amount of material and i
i asked him about that after the game
and he was like it's obvious for me that
the position is just lost and um to
bishops or just killing me and this is
what he said and i think that's the same
case when he understands that this his
position is lost he just simply cannot
play this position anymore i mean i've
seen it twice already and i was also
shocked same way as you
like like how it's possible and uh yeah
okay with the atmosphere in the plane
hall is pretty tense and i'm sure you
want to come back to the games so back
to you
to the studio
and back over to you alejandro's we've
got developments in anton's game
well we were only considering this
position after the move knight f49 e6 we
found it very difficult to play this
position for black and i think david
also thought about this position as
difficult because after the move rook c6
what do you play right a6 is hanging we
mentioned that it was difficult to find
moves for black somehow we found king h8
to be the movie yeah
but of course you have to calculate what
happens on bishop e4 what happens when
rook takes a6
rook a6 knight c5 is an idea so a lot of
potential here bishop e4 is very
dangerous and still white is better
instead rookie 3 was played with the
idea that if king d2 knight f3 check is
going to be decisive but you have this
intermediate bishop takes p5 quite
obvious if you take on b5 and i think
you have to take on b5 otherwise bishop
c6 the bishop actually rearranges itself
or bishop's e4 check with the temple
both very strong i assume the idea is to
take but after you take it and you take
black is a serious problem take as an
issue rook f7 is an issue this rook
really wants to join the fray but isn't
able to do so easily for example the
move rook f8 it looks like it creates a
lot of threads here but first of all
takes takes pawn takes h6 these end
games are not so easy because this pawn
is going to be very weak another
problem this beautiful move
ouch rook g7 king takes pawn takes the
king is tethered to this rook and if you
go back i'll just keep chasing your king
eventually
you take on f8 i think everybody
remembers
idea of
h6h7 it's not the same poem but the same
idea of the king being tethered to this
rook's defense so i don't know if he
just realized this but he's stuck after
bishop takes b5 this is not the moment
you want to be stuck in you played
rookie 3 bishop b5 had to be played and
now you're stuck as a defender minute
and thirty for gabrieles goes six
minutes and thirty four core above
things are going downhill for the
romanian champion well
this is the big leagues right
welcome to the big leagues and talking
about the big leagues let's turn to fabi
versus duda because uh when we left it
we kind of
well let's be fair we thought fabi was
definitely pushing the action and after
the move f7 f6 he dropped back with the
knight i think and very suddenly yeah
very clear indication than the young
sister agrees because uh f6 was pretty
pretty clearly played with the idea of
knight takes f2 because otherwise you're
ruining your bishop on g5 if you give
white to tempo here to play something
like knight fe1
on knight g2 even followed by f2 f4 your
bishop on g5
this will look a bit silly uh so yeah
not the xf2
here by bayan shrestha if you take with
a piece i guess you're the king yeah i
think we're taking with the king bishop
takes e3 and just going king g3 and then
just asking
rook eg8 probably is the idea here right
right edgar g8 well i got to cover http
i think no g4 is i think more important
than g4 i was going to trade off but
okay bishop takes d4 here is what i and
now go rook h6
ah i mean
i might like i'd much rather go knight
to f2 i think
giving up with the the f5 is annoying
though
five is way too annoying to allow yeah
okay let's let's make your move your
move is stronger okay yeah i've i really
didn't want to give up on d4 but yeah i
can very much understand i can very much
understand why
uh it's and obviously
white white is much better the question
is whether there is enough defensive for
resources here in particular in the
rapid game to maybe have
reasonable drawing chances i'm not sure
um i'm not sure the light on h2 like
once the knight on h2 gets to some
normal squares
yeah it's but it's just a temporary
thing because the double rooks
are actually not going anywhere with the
knight on h2 but okay uh
by the way
this sacrifice do you think of it in
practical terms like it's just something
you've got once once once you played f6
i don't think you have much of a choice
i was really like i didn't see knight
takes f2 and i thought what is he doing
with f7 f6 because
the very simple threat of knight to any
kind of a normal square from f3 and then
f2 f4 just looks crushing right exactly
you you even with 2 tempi basically to
deal with it you still are very unsure
how to
exactly yeah i think i think he did it
because he
like really really just liked his
position even on a previous move
but it doesn't seem to be enough takes
uh if you take with the rook you give up
yeah he's taken with the knight which is
very ah it's clever because rook takes
b3 bishop takes e3 i don't understand
anything anymore about that three was
definitely the better move for okay
and then i was going to play knight
takes g5 knight g5 and we win material
right no no no no no no no no there's
still rook be one check and rookie seven
this is the one that you may have missed
yeah yeah yeah because king e2 seems
like it's winning on the spot because
ruka fan 96 czech picks up right
you're still
winning material yeah 96 king i guess b6
knight g7 rook f2 king c3 or something
but maybe black has some drawing chances
instead bishop takes e3 was played wow
but that seems completely lost to me
bishop b3 d3 is a strange turn yeah yeah
he's trying to get his collect as many
pawns as he can but that's not as many
like if you don't lose scraggly looking
pawns too yeah if you take on f2 and g4
here you're just completely lost because
white preserved preserved the important
pawns in the in in in the structure like
you don't even get your palm back i mean
you're just picking everything up yeah
rook h6 or
bishop takes e3 help
no no it was just wrong it was wrong
okay sorry alejandra i just like
okay so
and as a bounce back for for fabi
but actually right an important one
91. and i think it was a very cagey move
i love you playing the three first
three he's playing you three first no i
think he played knight
bishop f4 king d3 no no no no really yes
okay let me just refresh my board just a
second oops
where are you fabi
he went king d3 first you're welcome
just checking to make sure you guys get
it right yeah yeah
get it right from now on okay now it's
all about making progress right i i like
the computer's move once you put it on
the board you see aha that move is great
perhaps it takes a little bit of time to
find it rook hh1
rook h
yeah we want rookie one we want to get
at least one pair of rooks off the board
and then the control over the e file
becomes completely irrelevant this is a
clever move yeah
this is a clever move
rook h and yeah you can get to it in
particular if you have time and i think
he does have time he does have time yeah
it's such a nice movie
it's not not a ton of time and
the the the reason you might not make it
is that i don't think other moves are
bad oh no absolutely it's just that it's
right it's clearly the cleanest solution
but
i think your mind immediately goes to
something like knight g2 and then you
realize that after bishop g5 the bishop
on g5 is actually very annoying
um
yeah maybe maybe you need to actually
play knight of three back
yeah rook yeah yeah fabi if i be no
better chess either
no i this is such a great technical move
you if you analyze this with an engine
it's no real difference between rook hh1
knight h4 whatever but from a human
point of view oh yeah this is how you
play take off a couple of rooks maybe
even all of them
and your yeah the issue is
yeah and
immediately getting the rooks off the
board immediately will be a bit tricky
because like 93 allows rookie three
check right in both cases yeah yeah so
there yeah and he was planting the rook
on e4 just to make sure
that he's not but now we can go 92 lose
the g4 pawn no you don't want to be
losing the g2 for the g4 pawn
we don't but i know because he loses g4
yeah we lose it
those
one of the moves that i'm kind of
attracted to frankly is knight c3
attacking the rope by the way maybe the
rook doesn't move but here once again
i'm angling for rookie one because this
rook is
unprotected but you can probably start
with rookie one and then go knight c3
with but with similar ideas he goes
knight c3 yeah he goes knight c3
as as you pointed out
black can for at least one temple
continue ignoring it because knight
takes e4 is not a threat just yet i
agree something like king g7 might be
useful just to have the rook on e8
protected agree in some positions it
might be useful for us to have the
specifically if you play rookie one now
it's actually actually varying yeah it
actually blunders the light on f3 which
isn't a second earlier yeah that is
absolutely true peter yeah
although in this position now i think i
can just simply play knight yeah this is
this is the issue yeah now in this case
before simultaneously
yeah bishop takes d2 rook knight takes
e4 is embarrassing so rookie three check
and this is i think the position where
i i'm driving the rooks off the line how
did you guys get here what was the move
you played he played
he gave a check instead of king d7 which
is understandable why why be
yeah very interestingly king d7 or any
passing move actually instantly lost to
knight h4
because after
the rook actually runs there are no
squares there are no swords
oh
yeah it gets caught only three which is
very very unusual but there are three
things to do on the board yeah
and now maybe not as
an foreign it is still a threat
absolutely oh
this knight on c3 is really doing a
great job well you got more pieces i
think we've talked about it in the
broadcast before that it helps it really
does help to have four pieces doesn't
matter what the name of them are
you have more pieces you control more
squares it doesn't matter how many pawns
you have i mean okay you have two extra
pawns for the piece and what are they
what are they doing what are the pawns
controlling yeah outside of the d5 pawn
uh the b7 pawn which is a pawn and it's
useful is not controlling anything uh
rook g8 on the board
yeah in the meantime uh yeah anton will
beat uh david gavrilasko we don't have
the switch but yeah okay it's a very
very clearly technically winning endgame
he is not going to let go of that
and uh kell shivchenko is completely
fine against product now but probably
will be a draw i think that that that
was a bird's-eye view there of the
clocks between
fabi and duda and again for us um
this match-up between these two
candidates a kind of a prelude if you
will
looking towards madrid
really is uh
well i i don't know about you peter but
i always felt like getting one
win against a future rival
was uh yeah we've watched i i can't
remember exactly which interview it was
i think it was maybe with jan uh in
in bucharest and he just flat out denied
it meant anything and yeah i don't
believe i don't believe a moment already
yeah yeah yeah each event is different
and you know like no no no no
yeah i think when he bit for rojo
he got asked by christian in in the
studio in bucharest if there was like a
special victory considering madrid he
said no no this is this is a separate
event i don't care uh
nobody believes that nobody
pretty sure that was that that felt good
that really did pretty sure that wasn't
entirely truthful yeah
okay bishop d6 and finally he's facing a
technical task
here and it's still not
that easy
not at all right by the way he he made
that move with a little concern for his
clock
i don't know if you noticed it but uh
it's not got that much time 38 seconds
ago and by the way doesn't that invite
bishop to b4
yeah and we probably won't because
everything else appears to lose material
he goes wrong just six g6 just kind of
okay defending the blind
boy i've seen rooks defend pawns
before but that is like an ugly looking
defensive maneuver i mean the rook is
kind of self
okay
it's attacking g4 so yeah it still has
some active active models
it was clearly headed towards that
square yeah
so yeah
brooke
i want to say rook g2 but that allows h5
we definitely want to preserve the pawn
on g4 for quite a bit whoa knight f4
that's rather a forcing move i mean
we have rook h2 check in response i
think he actually yeah starts by h2shek
pretty much always and then consider
d3 whether he wants to go rogue rook g8
kind of blunders the pawn on f6
potentially he has to calculate some
lines that's what i think it does no you
got to take on it yeah we have to take
on a four and then you probably play h5
oh he's reaching for his rook he doesn't
want it
it's the human thing not to take right
on yeah
yeah you don't want to be trading
bishops for knights
e6 jack and rook f6 is going to be
costly
also yeah
knight e6 check gift me the pawn i think
maybe it's a bit trickier than we
thought like king d7 rook of six king e7
knight ce2 is a great move yeah let's
see that's a fabulous move it prepares
h1
by the way anton has indeed won
an expectation for some time from
ourselves but just making it official
king d6
run for the hills get out of dodge
sidestep 96 check and you were
mentioning that the movie it actually is
playable
it actually is playable even
g2 what a curious way of doing things
yeah so if i take on g to take on g2 i
don't like this
i think do you greedily take one f6 at
the end yeah
yes
yes
yes
of course why not why not yeah and now
you have to take on g4 because allowing
93 you will never you will never get to
that then you'll never get you have to
do it right away and you have to hope
that yeah
he doesn't even go rook takes f6 which
you know we were kind of uh
white is still probably winning long
term because of how stable the queen
side is and black really cut
definitely harder to win without the g
pawn yeah i'm a bit i'm a bit surprised
he's done it he's done it this way but
he's still favored to convert this
eventually because of just how little
counter play there is and like knight fa
by the way clock king a7 yeah we go
knight to five for bish performance
eight nintendo do you ever consider just
hardlining rook g1 saying all your end
games are lost because your kings are
away
yeah and you can't challenge the queen
side at all right we play b5 if we
ignore
yeah it was a wonderful game maybe but i
i don't think it's required i think
this is a curious move though i don't
really understand what that achieves
he wants to really
no i thought simply because i thought
neither 594 was very strong exactly i
don't i don't know why he is just not
doing this
well
king b6 king a7 king a6
is a clear indication that white can
take his time doing whatever yeah setups
he wants pretty much uh
but now having said that what's the
ideal setup peter
i wanted not a five kingy three king of
three though yeah okay so he does he
does nice trade rook g5 i think is
clearly the way to play here
try to at least
at least improve the structure if the
rook trade happens i don't think it whoa
whoa i was not expecting that bobby
making some very i was not expecting
surprising decisions it's almost as if
he's like convinced
every ending is winning and is it it may
be but like blood goes b5 king b6 b a b
a and c five and everything disappears
apart from the ac
even even cleverer is that a word c5
first
clever keeping keeping yeah yeah keeping
uh yeah
i always played knight e3
keep the move c6 c5 and check you're
running out of pawns
precisely luckily you have a partner a4
that's not a light square but it's
very very hard to trade yeah perhaps
fabi was not informed that i picked him
in the fantasy thing maybe he was or
maybe he was and he is you know
ripping me for some slights
yeah the engines hate how he's played
yeah right i mean they actually think
black's not even worse
knight h5 okay so you've got the
wonderful blockade but that's not what
this is about yeah this is very
mystifying to me i cause who's gonna
who's gonna pick up the pawns
right okay so you're going to go knight
f5 knight f6 and knight d7
ah knight f5 knight f6 and knight t7
it's a lot of hopping peter yeah yeah
but you'll get there and
hops when you have five seconds man
they're they
they are they are rough those those yeah
p7 actually kind of improves that line
okay
yeah tickles the bishop forces it's but
someone somewhat remarkably the machine
just doesn't care about the h6 pawn at
all maybe not remarkably but like it
just it just gives it away straight away
and uh which for me i mean i would be
loath to just and
he goes bishop of faith but now now you
go knight f7 now you definitely go
knight f6 and you ask the question yeah
97 if he goes king c7 he blunders the d5
pawn so yeah he's right he's put himself
in the position to blunder something
king c7 allows a b and the d5 pawn as
peter mentioned would be lopped off
and that passed deep on that no no
that's a completely different scenario
right i don't think you could play kings
but that also makes the c65 plans a lot
slower so
yeah you can go 97 and pick up the pawn
on h6 yeah why does it perfectly white
has made huge progress definitely
progress here yeah i don't know if it's
winning but it's huge progress when you
take on g h6 you yeah just take on gc
block it again on g4 you start crying
your pieces
and you go through the whole regular
roll and the knight on d7 is great it
just prevents c5 yes forever
i think maybe young should have thought
that there will never be a threat ever
again in this in this game and he kind
of forgot about it yeah sleep walked
through a couple of moves and and now
he's back in the
in a lot of trouble yeah it's just
definitely have you heard that you
picked fabi for
yes very upsetting very upsetting
i think you just pick up the g5 pawn you
start hitting it somehow yeah like 95 96
on an eagle king c2 i mean this bishop's
diagonal on f4 c1 is short this is what
i mean yeah 95 96 and then king c2 he's
gone like gf6 i'm not exactly sure like
ab5 is a threat now i guess this is the
point but i would be actually kind of
loath to take it yes because then i get
g4 g3 and a4 and that allows and i get
those yeah i get those you know yeah no
no trouser legs trousers trouser legs
well trousers yeah that's what they
watch out watch out for the trousers
okay this is very nice play by uh
um
fabi as he's keeping this bishop
on c1 honest
here's sort of light you can put your
knights in all kinds of knives
this is the way yeah
and it's almost like an invisible
barrier the knights control all of these
squares so that black's king is
essentially in a box and that's why we
see the move king
c5 yeah you have to assess whether you
will be able to take on f4 which is why
i liked it more with the knight on g4
and i thought nothing about the knight
on f6 is it time for king c2 but i think
we can say i think we can quite safely
go king c2 and then take on f4 because
the other knight will do all the
blockaging on g5 sorry
no i may go bishop f4
yeah if we get to take on g5 i think we
win reasonably but i think it's just
that yeah
the king's in the square yeah the king
is in the square the knight goes to c5
and there will never be a single shred
of count to play on the queen's you have
to bishop bishop e3 exists but we've got
knight g4 bishop g1 king g3 and then
with acorn g5 right love it yeah love
it yeah it's just kind of gone right
so you have to play four against three
on one side but then you know with only
one flank to go to concentrate on white
wins very very comfortably yeah it's
like the mvp you just you just snap take
here and go 95 and and the game ends
uh just a little um
christoph duda has just been shaking his
head i mean it's very easy to put a
knight on d3 oh the knight on d3 is the
dream square off anderson live for that
oh my goodness
yes
yeah yes this is just completely gone
yeah i just resigned here i think you're
just resigning yeah
what king
he's bouncing back from very important
victory round one and we still have one
game remaining right there ignite versus
rook
uh wait have you ever had an experience
with this yeah it was very frustrating i
personally haven't i have
i had the rook at night against the rook
and i was
so frustrated how hard it is to make a
threat correct it's you can't even like
you can't even
come close to showing the king to a back
rank exactly yeah exactly it is really
really uh yeah and yet i've seen grand
masters lose this
yeah but i think
mainly when you start already cut off on
the background then then you and there
are some issues yeah there's some issues
and there are some positions which are
actively sort of actually lost but but
yeah
starting the game i remember i remember
too i remember me lost this right
carl
and that was a game that invested vessel
in i think and one
linares i believe it was kasparov
but i think volga already started in the
in a yeah
it wasn't like back ranked but i
remember that pogba started in like she
heard that she heard the draw but it was
tricky it was tricky it was
her position you can imagine losing yeah
i'm not sure what
i mean
laying down markers for the future or
something because i think generally
these days people kind of offer draws in
these end games like um no
tour peter we're playing this the 50
whole moves yeah until radik proves that
he is going to make i also wonder how he
lost the bishop
didn't he have a great bishop not that
long ago your hands are bleeding yeah we
don't let you uh leave the board
uh knight g4 check as you hear saying
it's so frustrating to even force the
like king e2 would be a dreadful move
because in this case alejandro as you
were mentioning you could force the
kingdom to the back rank and even the
problem is after g2
yeah
we go 93 chance and you're just kind of
like f2 yeah yeah like
and we actually have managed to put a
king on the background somewhere that's
incredible one of the back ranks i will
go wow whoa
what are you saying about king and two
making a terrible move
i'm down with this guys
knight d3 check
knight e5 is a funny way very
interesting yeah i mean if you're aiming
for d3 why not get there
we got 26 more moves as the producer has
told us remember there's a 50 move rule
in play in feeder rated games that means
that if there are 50 moves played in a
row without a capture or a pawn move
capture or pawn move
the game is immediately drawn and this
is
what yeah
there are sort of
ring i mean
you need to be aware like for for
somebody who's played professional chess
for the last 30 years for instance i'm
not entirely sure on what the
regulations are on whether you're
allowed to use the electronic board to
count moves for instance the whiteboard
no sorry they're obviously not writing
down moves on the scoresheet so whether
you can whether you can use the
electronic board to make it oh yeah i
think you're always
allowed to ask the arbiter where are we
yes that is also true
uh yeah and and
another feeder rules if you hit 75
the arbiter interferes
ah you you go past 50 to such an extent
but you're actually it moves 75. the
arbiter will will interfere at that
point yeah
yeah and kirill clearly has made some
progress this is sort of the the
dangerous setup is this not with the
knight on the third because the knight
on the third doesn't allow you the king
the king to hide in front of it that's
true 94 king d3 is the dangerous setup
the problem is the king is already on b1
uh so it's it's far enough away that you
don't have to worry and also yes you can
set up a position where you will be able
to give a check from the third exactly
when you're in doubt in this end game
pin the knight
yes
yeah this is unnecessary this is fine
but unnecessary better you could have
just kept it kept on d8 on d8 keep it on
the a pin the knight when the king runs
to c3 boom attack goes to d3 pin the
knight it's actually very similar to the
bishop end game though easiest way is
usually to pin the bishop yeah the
difference being that the knight
controls far fewer squares so
the these
seemingly
like before philidor setups don't
actually create amazing threats so you
are very very safe we just saw the move
rook g8 would you have advocated in this
case for the move rook g4 alejandro find
the knight as you say yes i think so i
mean i like always spinning the knight
from the long like as far away from the
king as possible
so i like the rook jade but the rook was
already
[Laughter]
i was thinking rook g4 but yeah i mean
he played rook g8 these are all rook f2
yeah these are all sort of
taste considerations you as long as you
don't don't go
very very badly wrong you're
you're going to be safe in the games i
can't recall immediately if i've ever
had this particular ending i've had rook
and bishop versus rook
numerous times like i mean like seven
times in my career it's pretty
remarkable but rook and knight
i think i've only had three to only
remember sergey kudrin i take it back i
think i
no that was rook versus a knight i
apologize no
yeah my history with that end game with
the rook and bishop i mean is not very
proud
even
you know the the the legend says it uh
it it cost lawrence a phone uh a phone
yeah there were a lot of things that
happened i i spent a lot of evenings
with favi after that candidates
analyzing rook and bishop because of
that game yeah
oh great great like thank you peter that
was really fun
how did you spend your evening yeah
yeah
reportedly lawrence was watching the
game online and through his phone
the phone did not survive the
final the final moments of the game yeah
get that king backwards actually like i
defended really well for like 35 35
minutes and then i just
panicked about something and suddenly
allowed allowed the philidor but that
was we were basically playing
on increments
like he didn't he didn't
have time to be slightly inaccurate
anymore no it was like proper accuracy
was yeah yeah yeah yeah and he went a
bit wrong and i
reestablished the setup and also got
very close to 15 the game was drawn yeah
king b1 perhaps just sidestepping any
issues yeah we've kind of seen this
position before but the rick was on g8
we're going to keep an eye on this game
but christian has a special guest with
us over in warsaw
i don't hear anything
thank you thank you guys yes we are here
with an anton karobov after a tremendous
victory anton welcome back to the show
first of all you tell us whenever you
come
here on uh set you tell us your goals
for the tournament what is your goal for
this tournament
okay for this tournament after this game
i can say that here at the first half of
the of the game my opponent was trying
to test my blood pressure because i
missed some night jumps but then after
exchanging the night i asked my body are
you ready to fight or we have to what
what we are playing for win or for loss
for draw and my body is quite okay so we
are increasing here our expectations
excellent and how are you feeling my
brain and my body how is your body
feeling up to this point full of ecstasy
full of accidentally full of energy now
tell us about your compatriot you are
telling us that he's very tenacious tell
us about his chances in this game to win
it rook and knight versus rooney
okay 25 percent 25
that's bad
and you are going to be facing next
round one vishyanan who is on fire yeah
two out of two how are you uh planning
to stop him
oh i don't know but you know rishi is
keeping to some very interesting
practice he's sometimes he's willing and
in the next game he's trying to defend
the points maybe he's not going to be so
aggressive we will see perfect anton
thank you very much i won't keep you for
long because we know you have another
round in just a few minutes and we'll
let you go we'll see you next round
thank you very much guys back to you
thank you and uh
i would like to petition basically the
the the polish studio like whichever
game finishes you just interview cora
both right
like all the other interviews are like
clearly i
yeah and uh 25
wait a minute
how far away are we
we're not that far right
nine moves were being told by our
producer yeah nine kind of scary moves
to be honest because the king is a
little bit cornered
yeah and also
i think this is also what happened in my
game against fabi
you you feel much less confident when
it's like on the a or h files i think
because you kind of have to look at it
sideways and sideways is difficult you'd
rather look at it from the first or
eighth round yeah like compare compared
to defending like i was defending very
comfortably with my king on like c8 and
the rook on d7 and then i got turned
around
and once fabien managed to to like turn
around yeah
like you had to take your seat and move
it you know particularly it's actually
my favorite hobby horse the discussion
on whether it's you you're at this point
whether you're allowed to actually get
up
and sit and stand at the like stand
across the side as if you're defending
the you are allowed you are allowed you
asked the arbiters about this
oh i i read the regulations on on
twitter like pretty carefully at some i
thought i was like grandmaster and at
some point i should actually read the
peter handbrook
and you're allowed to look at the book
wherever you are and even behind your
opponent as long as you're not
disturbing him okay because i i think it
legitimately helps in these end games
because you can sort of re reorient
yourself a little bit yeah because uh
the problem now is the
black knight is uh far away from the
white king very hard to create mating
nets as the knight is in the pin don't
king b1 is okay but i thought the move
rook g3 in order to give yourself to
give yourself more more checks as well
yeah checks on the fourth or second but
yeah it's it's unclear what you can
blunder here though like even if you go
like king a2 i'm still not sure what
we're blundering king xi2king a3 just
runs that is a good point yeah it's
the only thing you can blunder is like
rook h1 or some wow
okay
that's that's that's still a draw but
that is a lot of move that would come to
my mind i'm sorry i don't know why we're
owing so much because
it's because you know why you don't you
know why the kings are in front of each
other you don't have your blundering
rook something to the first rank made
right right right no no no but peter
says come on that's totally legit i'm
like but but yeah
he had at least managed to actually get
get raleigh to play some somewhat close
to the the increment right because when
we started watching radik was on three
minutes and it looked like he will just
stay on but
in two seconds and he can still lose
that's right
that's absolutely right you can lose on
time
white has checkmating material
yeah king c3 is a three-fold so you need
something more clever and by the way too
by the way is a good move here isn't
that a three-point game you want kingitu
was winning the night
i just want to point out king d1 i'm
sorry it wasn't yeah okay
yes you understand what she meant
to wasn't the legal move okay i i got
over excited sorry i i wanted to but
he's defending this yeah
now very very well
rook f6 this is not a three-fold because
now that works on f6 is king
k1 is fine king d3 king c1 i don't think
you can really make a mistake in this
position honestly which is like unless
you just blunder a rook in one move but
he has played king d2 and it was that
awkward pin now that's what i was saying
if the rook was on g3 at this exact
moment it wouldn't be the move rook g2
but we're just running towards a384 we
don't really care all that much of
course um
by the way this is the frustration that
alejandro was saying that's 50 but they
have to claim it yeah and our server is
saying drawn because you know online
this would have been drawn by the server
by the server the service would have
interfered
but this is not this is not true
again you mentioned the move the 75 move
rule but
i mean come on it's very obvious to
anybody that white is trying to draw the
game and he's got a legitimate claim
right why can't the arbiter
make this that's that's the thing that's
the feeder rules feeder rules are
heavily
favoring lack of arbitrary intervention
yeah so the more
the arbiter can stay off the game
the better it is seen in like feed a
fetish period of the game and generally
i i agree with that i think i think
that's sort of how it's supposed to be
but yeah it does it does feel slightly
open to i mean not abuse but
uh
yeah unnecessary yeah continuation here
i think people and this is why i asked
and i feel slightly silly because i you
know
i'm supposed to be a professional chess
player at least in the past
uh but i think people don't realize that
there is really no penalty to just
asking or claiming and there's there's a
penalty
i mean
you give two minutes
to your opponent
but you get hard info on how many moves
it is but that's why i was saying can't
you just simply ask the arbiter yes
are we on move 50 are we at move forward
i think i think people don't actually
know that like people aren't very
comfortable doing that people people
don't know it's it's an option it's an
option they can exercise very freely so
now we're informing all of you guys now
you can
actually talk to your friendly arbiter
ask them what they're going to have for
dinner
you can ask arbiters whatever you want
exactly and is this a a 40 move or 30
move or i don't know it's like 60. oh my
gosh yeah by this point we're right by
this point
actually looking wait a second wait a
minute wait a minute i'm going to claim
wait
okay
girl's not counting
he's done
we're done too to be honest
all right rook and knight vs rook leaves
its logical conclusion and very nice a
draw between these two great players i
love it venko gambit resurgence proves
successful no problems for black in this
game actually yeah pressing till the end
by uh
is playing the vanco gambit as it makes
a
two draws two draws and a significant
amount
of decisive results let's take a look at
where that puts us on the standing board
after two rounds of chess in warsaw here
it comes yeah this is the only one on
100 there uh
yeah two out of two uh levon plus one uh
ritchie on plus one and then and anton
korvo as well okay last one and then a
bunch of people uh not a bunch actually
uh and both of them with two decisive
games which is maybe not that yeah
that's very surprising
considering the amount of decisive games
in the tournament exactly
but
we're going to take a break on our side
and we'll see on the other side of this
spring see you then for the last round
of the day right
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
team welcome back to the first day of
the warsaw super bed rapid and blitz
very exciting so far out the first
rounds produced seven decisive games out
of ten could it could have been more
uh
with the positions we've seen and these
are the standings going into the final
round of the day uh vichy starting very
very well winning a very nice game
against his long time second raleigh
quartershook and then destroying wesley
with the black pieces in round two just
absolutely beautiful
very very nicely played by this in a
very topical line richard lets uh
lavon off the hook yeah uh richard could
have been on 100 as well he won a very
nice game in round one and then uh yeah
was completely winning at a certain
point at least against livon
but uh failed to uh as is you know the
story for the second event running live
on getting very very you know dodgy
positions and then not losing them bobby
getting the best of his fellow rival
duda at the candidates and our parents
for our final round of the day peter
yeah uh
the only pairing we've actually had
spoken of on the air was in that
interview with anton corbett where he he
said that vichy sometimes defends his
pluses in the tournament i don't know
whether he was
you you never know exactly how
how dungeon chick he is but yeah
a very interesting match up
anton definitely capable of beating the
best in the world with the black pieces
the white pieces the green pieces
whichever pieces you want to give them
right uh kerosevchenko who
had that rooken knight against
rook previously white against wesley uh
leave white against radek wojtashek
uh young shishtov is white against
richie also candidate matchup exactly
that's a good one and our wild card uh
the young romanian player david
gabrielesko finally gets the white
pieces to play against fabi but no easy
no easy games for him in this tournament
that's for sure but due to report duda
versus richie will definitely be a
marquee matchup as the candidates it's
just a month away how exciting is it all
and we get ready for is round three i
must say
uh seven out of ten uh decisive results
peter i mean
that's
is it it's high it's it's high cons
considering this is the slowest rapid
time control imaginable this is sort of
the quote classical rapid time control
yes in terms of like we started with
this when when the rapid tournaments
became
game 30 or whatever yeah yeah
i i don't believe i've actually caught
any game 30 i think
for me
serious rapid tournament started with
the the uh pca
uh
tournaments in like 94 and 95 now
even before that they actually called it
active chess yes and the active
i think they were already 25 minute
games yeah i i believe they were already
all uh 20 no not game 30 they were they
were gaming yeah yeah those turned yeah
emo bar maybe was still 30 yeah i
thought but when i started playing in
them i think they already were 25 they
were not 30 anymore and these days the
sort of universally accepted
time control for rapid is 15 plus 10 but
this is the
kind of a more
way in relaxed way to play this
weigh in if you will alejandro your
preference of uh the rapid chest you
think this classical is a little too
slow for your taste as the players get
started i don't mind 25 plus then i just
prefer
15 plus 10. i i don't think that 25 plus
10 is a bad time control right i don't
think it's too slow i just prefer the
other one like a lot of people do i i
also don't want to see bishop c4 making
error i was about to say there's no mc4
first of all
can we not
by the way can we can we please not yeah
like
in the game of vishy anand our
tournament leader versus anton i said
anton in the tournament you're going to
see a french defense and guess what
we see a french defense
i love how this guy plus trust i mean
anton
he just doesn't care what the trend is
he doesn't care what he sticks to his
because he likes his guns and he sticks
to them he loves playing this nimzo
indians with the white pieces say e3
queen c2 lines doesn't care what the
newest and lateness of theory is he
likes his setups he likes his french he
likes playing these positions and
sometimes his feel for them just matters
so much more than the engine evaluation
and having said that the same is true of
vishy vishy's playing the advance
french
he's got a lot of experience peter some
kind of new thing actually i don't i
don't associate vision necessarily with
with the advanced french i think he's
been a knight c3 player forever for
forever for
most of his life he crushed me with
knight c3 and the olympiad in 2004. so
he's been a knight c3 player
forever yeah and a very very established
like very accomplished player player of
those positions as with most other
positions in chess to be honest but yeah
h6 is a very kind of a surprising
approach and confused yeah okay uh
help me out i don't know what that does
yeah i don't think we want g5 i looked
at it for a while actually with h6 i
don't know why i was preparing the
french for somebody and h6 is not such a
bad move it it's kind of zuzwangi in the
sense that yeah it was like a useful
passage it's a useful pass you're
waiting for black to determine the
situation on d4 and if you put your
bishop on e3 sometimes when you do
eventually get your knight to f5 once
you hit it with g4 i have the extra
ability of taking this bishop on e3
so it's a it's an interesting move i
think h6 in so many different variations
is making some kind of claim that the
movie h6 is more useful than we give it
credit for i've even seen h6 in catalans
lately and i'm thinking well you can
play h6 in the catalan you can play h6
anywhere yeah that's so that's a
statement uh right there because yeah
catalan is not not a opening you
associate with
like having tempi to make weird moves on
the king's side
and in case you just joined us vichy's
currently the leader two out of two just
and beautiful chess beautiful it's just
black yeah where wesley saw's position
in the previous round
and after this move bishop e3 i think
we're seeing queens
played yeah uh i'm slightly surprised by
that because i also felt that you know
the intention of this setup must be to
we sort of provoke b3 and then just go
either the immediate 97 even that i
thought was playable or maybe cd4 cd4997
but anton says no no we'll play queen b6
for now we will ask the question whether
you know white wants to find a way to
sacrifice the pawn on b2 or whether you
want to make some kind of an awkward
move like queen g2 which maybe takes
away squares from your own pieces a
little bit
and then we'll play maybe cd4 cd 497 and
push for knight f5 um yeah very unusual
looking uh
for me the question i would ask is if
you take on c5 bishop takes c5
bishop takes c5 queen takes e5
interesting that interesting though
precisely zero seconds were dedicated to
the idea of queen takes b2 but i guess
he actually is still following some prep
so he knows queen takes b2 is unplayable
it wasn't really clear to me at all why
it was so unpleasant unpleasant queen b3
yeah i mean i can take on a one take on
f1 and claim i have better maybe my
development is so poor that i cannot
play that position with the bishop on it
i would have at least spent like half a
minute
pretending pretending to be
right right right right but anton
clearly knows and and so well
so vishy just took the game into a very
strategic
channel of he's going to play knight b3
he's going to play bishop to d rookie
one might be three and then he's going
to cement
you know iron control over the defense i
quite like this for white i've always
been a huge fan of these types of
structures in particular when there is
no immediate counter play on the queen
side and no good way for black to trade
the bishop on d7 for the bishop on e3
precisely for that line of strategic
play it's going to put a rook on e1 he's
going to leverage this pawn on e5 to
some type of king side attack whether he
gets it with rookie 3 knight d4
or
maybe
lining his queen and bishop
on the long
diagonal battery of h7
white's for choice absolutely but
you know i think when i was like a 12
year old kid i would suggest this like
as borderline winning for white these
days i understand that it's nowhere near
that good
got a lot of work yeah and and black is
a lot more resilient here than i would
have given it you know given them credit
for when i was uh
you know naive and hopeful
but
uh obvious obviously we still we still
choose white here and alejandro has news
from from uh the outer boards yeah girl
chef chenko decided with the banker
gambit i can sacrifice a pawn let me see
how i can sacrifice a pawn with white in
the berlin not a very common variation
but here we have the normal berlin setup
chefchenko playing against wesley so
knight takes e4 rookie one we've seen
this a million times but after knight d6
he didn't take on e5 not when he was
offered right now and after bishop f1
bishop e7 could still transpose into
those variations take on e5 go into deep
theory tons of games played in this
position but instead he just develops
his pieces says i don't want no stinking
pawn that's going to free up your
position let me leave it in the center
for the time being wesley says you know
what that's an important pawn i'm going
to defend it f6 holds on to the pawn and
now we have this
weird position where black is weirdly
developed right the knight on f7 is
weird the pawn on f6 is weird the bishop
27 is not very active especially when
you consider that the move d6 might come
the bishop on e7 definitely does not
look active but it's a pawn and it's a
central pawn we talked about in the
previous game between duda and fabi what
are judas pawns doing it's they're extra
compared to the piece but they're not
controlling anything this pawn on e5 on
the other hand it closes down the e file
puts pressure on d4 itself it's a
bastion of black's position and you can
see the black defending it with all his
might so clearly white has compensation
he has the activity he has a development
he has some nice space
but what do you do now this is an
interesting game i love the way chef
chancellor plays chess uncompromising
does not worry about losing pawns
against his higher rated opponents he
just wants to play a fun position
i'm reminded of uh bob zuke a canadian
master he's 2300 when i was a young
teenage boy he said to me yes sir
control the e5 square and good things
will happen
and when you look at wesley's position
he's controlled the e5 square king's
indian defense
duda versus richie yeah and let's jump
to that game because this is very this
is a nice uh peter it is very nice it's
not an opening i understand particularly
well but
particularly specifically the interplay
of the last couple of moves is very very
surprising to me because they're playing
the absolute classical line exactly
of the sort of the main line of the
king's indian and what i want to ask you
is
why hasn't bishop g4 been played yet
thank you
me too i'm sitting they're saying what
is happening how how could you how can
you not play play yeah everything i've
been trained
all my life yeah exactly like
like
it's very because we'll say if you trade
off the likes of your bishops there's no
it's like why aren't you playing bishop
g4 and why are you playing g
five and knight g6 before playing before
playing
this entire this entire sequence left me
completely baffled and now we had that
we're back into some kind of normal
territory exactly
but but you know how we got here is very
strange yeah
rook g7 if you showed me this i wouldn't
be surprised but
both of them both of them you know black
allowing bishop g4 and one while saying
no thanks
it's it's bizarre to me i don't quite
understand why why there was it feels
like some inexperience going on no maybe
they mix up the move order i don't know
i don't know but they're back into
normal lines of theory right this is
right it still has
tons of games and tons of variations
analyzed
and do you know what the latest and
greatest are is as far as stat stats
white wins 52 percent or something like
that specifically this position only six
games sometimes they transposing to each
other especially if the bishop makes it
to f2 or you go a4 and it transposes
into a previous game where they started
with the move a4 but specifically from
this position i only have 12 games
white wins
33 percent black actually wins half
so yeah dangerous position for white as
well 17 and in draw so we expect a
decisive result on this one i remember a
game between
yurum piquet he was a top
dutch player at the time against gary
kasparov
and the final move of the game gary won
the game as black there was a rook on f2
there was a queen on a7 and a black
knight on g3 the black knight went to h1
i think i think i i know
and won the game uh but uh yeah i mean
this is definitely a three result
topsy-turvy position theoretical
absolutely we'll keep an eye on it just
let's continue our walk around the horn
as i've got the game up on my screen
between david and fabi
yeah this is a very very sharp line of
the the bishop e5 sicilian uh
arguably the most like the weirdest and
the least
kind of standard uh structures that can
arise out of the bishop b5 systems are
are found specifically in mission b5 v6
bishop takes b takes
and yeah like if you if you look at this
position uh without understanding the
dynamics involved you think black has
done horrible horrible things to uh to
his his structure right and you know
will eventually get punished because you
especially you expect it takes e6 to
happen uh rather rapidly yeah black will
take and white will i don't know put the
knight on e4 put the bishop on e3 win
the pawn on c5 and the game with it
but
uh
life shows that black plays like e5 f6
bishop b6 the poland c5 is actually not
as easy to win as you think and even if
it does fall
black generates so much activity uh in
the center and on the king's side with
the knight jumping to f4 the bishop
coming out to g4 maybe in some positions
the queen often goes to d5
black has a lot of
dynamic counter play for you know the
very very obvious weaknesses that you
know you do create in your position a
different approach by white by the way
david did not capture on e on d6 and go
down that primrose path
that we've just looked at and said
queenie too he wants the same structure
but well he would like i guess together
get the knights off the board like if
black steel takes on e5 we can we can
get the same type of position but maybe
trade light on the thing for dreams
for white yeah yeah i think it would
make sense yeah because 96 is actually a
very useful uh useful piece for black uh
it does yeah use good things it jumps to
f4 currently knight the 4 looks
attractive but queen e4
is a good reply if you take on g2 it
never comes back from there so it
doesn't quite work
for a second there i thought maybe d5
here yeah but unfortunately there is the
a4 yeah if not for that exactly the
night would make a triumphant re
return yeah uh okay well we'll keep an
eye on that exciting game and i'll turn
it over to alejandro alejandro what have
you been following
uh pretty much you guys are following a
little bit of the french defense here a
little bit of that here we have this
game between vichy and anton corbin this
is the kind of position you don't really
want to get with the black pieces
because in the structure where the pawn
on d4 and the pawn of c5 disappear
there's a danger strategically for black
that you run out of things to attack
normally the french defense is based on
the pressure on d4 tying white's
position to the defense of the pawn
without the defense of the pawn
sometimes you can start considering
rookie three rook g3 you can consider
h4h5 even g4 g5 opening up things on the
king side when you don't have to defend
on the other side and look at this pawn
on c3 does a great job of preventing the
rook from coming down closes down things
on this side of the board so the engines
are saying advantage white i don't think
it's as big as the engines are showing
but i don't like exactly how koro buff
has landed in this french i think that
vichy did get a little bit of an
advantage and i'm going to be very
curious on this game between shefchenko
and wesley i was analyzing for a little
bit the engine is hating the way that
shevchenko is trying to prove his
compensation he got the knight to d5
targeting this bishop on e7 castle was
played but they didn't really understand
the move c4 but thought okay that's not
bad d6 but this this move bishop d3 was
really bad i'm not really sure what he
missed but wesley played the very
natural move f5 immediately putting in
action his center majority threatening
the move e4 it wins a piece because
knight takes e7 you can always take with
the knight you don't have to self pin
and this net on f7 actually does a great
job it defends e5 twice it defends the
square on g5 in many situations where
you get pinned so you could take on e7
in this particular position i cannot
take with the knight because d takes e5
i haven't played the move e4 just yet
and queen takes e7 just challenges white
to find the comp e4 is coming even if it
doesn't win a piece it's a very nice
move strategically closes down the
center closes down the bishops uses my
spatial advantage so it's not just about
winning a piece e4 is a strategical
threat where is white's threat here
where is the compensation actually the
more you look at it why isn't black also
strategically better exactly because you
have everything going down in the center
you don't have enough pawns to resist
the counter attack by black so the edges
think bishop d3 horrible move shouldn't
have played that there was some argument
that you made for b4 just shoot the b
the b with b5 this knight away from c6
not allow this pawn to go down to f5
don't allow black to mobilize his center
but of course that's an engine move and
after bishop d3 natural developing f5
they're just saying wesley all the way
also huge time advantage for wesley
eight minute difference already wesley
with twenty three shevchenko with 15.
here wesley really proving his knowledge
in the berlin he's the kind of player
that you give him upon he loves gobbling
them up defending a slightly inferior
position maybe with compensation and
then just coming back precisely
neutralizing the comp and then winning
with the extra pawn
man after my own heart what can i say
i'd like to turn our attention peter to
the game between duda and richard again
are all candidates match up and for me
the choices of richard and duda are
going to double gas i mean for me you
don't play h5 for a long long time it's
very yes
it's very famous
yeah for for me the
the bit that i know about the king's
indian is you get in this moves uh
bishop g7 and rook g8 because there are
many times
that you could actually as gary kasparov
has shown us you put you plan a knight
on g3 very quickly like for example the
game of paquette
if in these also just i'm going to put
some moves on the board okay so forgive
me for just a moment
you don't necessarily need to move
h5 to get in g4 whenever the knight
leaves the pawn you can go eat because
of e4 is hanging so
what i understand is put your rook on g7
quickly
it's always good on g7 and then decide
if you need h5 bishop of eight i very
much agree with uh i didn't really
disagree with h5 all that much i'm not
quite sure what king h7 is about me uh
but it's also interesting that young
shisha from the white side went with
this king h1 g3 plan instead of like
your your normal setups they're involved
either bishop e1 f2 on knight f2
sometimes also right they get something
three
out of the uh plans and he does go night
up to now but but with the inclusion of
g3 is very confusing for me i mean
this is kind of peculiar
now you're kind of
encouraging uh
well with the pawn on g3
it's a hundred percent that black can
open up the king's eye
yeah even though
he is somewhat prepared for it and he
made i think enough of progress on the
queen side to perhaps dedicate some of
his time
to uh
to just one other point that if we had
gone
like in the game yeah
this kind of thing this is like really i
think
serious
serious trouble with my gf4 coming in
yeah we're at some point we stopped
caring if we put things
that's exactly right that's exactly what
i want to say that the h5 square can be
useful none of this has happened instead
we've got
i think a very uh original position uh
i don't think that this is really the
way uh people play these positions as
well people also i want to say
it's
like i've been listening to you for like
the the last
a minute and
i've learned more things about this
the these structures than i have
i am not the king's indian player so
perhaps for
somebody official
you know a pedigree in these positions
it wouldn't have been as educational as
it was for me but i also want to say
that these guys are not necessarily like
full-time kings indian players that's
the point and i think they're also
kind of ad-libbing here not just in
terms of not just in terms of not
knowing what theory says but also simply
in terms of like figuring out like what
the plans are which moves are necessary
and which moves are optional because
even like for me i knew bishop federal
g7 was the way to go but i thought okay
h5 still gets included anyway so why not
start with it
and and then i listened to you and i
realized yes absolutely those two moves
are required and the h5 square might be
needed like
nobody is taking away h7h5 from us but
right if you play it knight h5 will no
longer be available for basically the
rest i mean maybe for the rest of the
game
uh so yeah it feels like they're kind of
feeling their way
exactly how to you know in this position
they're not entirely sure what goes
where
i feel that this is a very very
dangerous position for white
things can go wrong very easily like
i'll just make a bad move forgive me for
a moment and you can just start to feel
like with rook g7 i'm going to make too
bad because i apologize rook g7 and a5
and you know you can start to see that
wait a minute you know i don't know i
don't know this i don't mind at all i
play g4 here you do but yeah okay and i
think this is completely fine i'll take
on a4 quite happily i think i think this
is i think you've misplayed this for
black i'm not sure this bishop on f8 um
how do i put it uh does i think this
might be kind of winning for white not
for e5 yeah i think so e5 definitely i
think you've completely destroyed your
position good point you have no attack
anymore but the power nature oh like
you're everything is completely blocked
off i think this is wrong yeah i think
like takes takes a knight of four with
like gfgf and then knight g4 and qh4
check to follow this i would believe in
h4 g4 i'm immediately feeling very very
comfortable with what you you made the
blockade yeah like i don't think i don't
think black black should allow uh that
type of
black blockade to happen yeah something
like this very much is topical yeah
or with the gh
or whatever yeah but yeah h4g4 i really
disliked there i thought that was you
know the one thing i felt very strongly
about yeah i'm getting something i was
trying to break open the position but i
did it in the wrong move order um and uh
sorry c6 youngsters have played
c6 what
okay that is really bizarre i don't know
i don't mind it really yeah i think
maybe his idea is to play c6 and follow
it up like
i don't know how good this how well this
works
but
i want to say maybe at least part of the
idea is to follow it up with g3 g4
and claim that this bishop on c8 will
never have any squares to move to so
we've actually locked out not one but
two pieces on the queen side wow i
it looks kind of elaborate and you know
too good to be true but in particular
like
in particular if black
responds to c6 with i don't know let's
say b6 which is a horrible move which
you shouldn't make i'll avoid that yeah
but but they just did it he actually
yeah now i'm very interested in g3 g4
he's gone rook g1 but that doesn't take
away the idea just yet right but can we
can we just put g4 on the board there
for a second right how ridiculous is it
i'm just saying this is ugly but also
there are two pieces on the queen side
now like a full queen worth of pieces
which you will have to sacrifice yeah
somehow they get get get out yeah you
you will actually have to sacrifice them
to get them out into the game and
without them do you give mate on the
queen on the king side like you can play
knight h4 you can you know return the
king from like it shouldn't be on h7
this much we know the king should not be
on h7 here because we want the rooks
there right uh but okay i will play rook
giovan i will play
anything uh
to be said for an f3 idea some
i mean i've gotta
i've gotta well
i'll return here i will play bishop f3 i
guess at queen e2 and no it does give
you the a6 player for the bishop but you
you can see sort of the strategic idea
of what i'm trying to do here which is
just entombed yeah it might be it might
be the bishop it might be bad but it
definitely contains
a reasonable strategic idea i was
actually afraid of that and i thought i
was going to take on cece yes i thought
yeah but that is incredible
my my bishop just developed my bishop so
that i don't get
as you say i i think that would also be
my reaction because of just how worried
i am i will not forget to move those
pieces ever again but oh and by the way
yeah after including the move b6
rook g1
now that the bishop on fa
has no useful purpose yeah is logical he
defends g5 so that any
takes uh
the g5 pawn is not hanging and now
at some moment you just got to play g5
g4 here yeah
as black white is reasonably well
prepared for it though i just take right
i have more which i have more cup fg i
have more things attacking mgc okay so
let me
should i
do i take right
what am i taking right away
just a second um
do i have anything along the no i i
apologize
i need to play queen f8 it needs to be
further prepared yeah yeah
in order to
somehow i'm trying to blow up the g f
the the
the f file
and it's awkward uh as we're work
working this over
what's happening in lavon's game uh
alejandro lavon against radek voy tashek
in this position weird sicilian you can
see the makings of the sicilian in some
ways you can see the c5 d5 expansions
well what is the bishop doing on eight
yeah to the night not clear a lot of
things that are not in their usual spots
b5 is certainly a move that you can
consider simply showing that the idea of
b4 opening up the c file to me that
looks very logical another way of
playing this position you can see that
white has retreated knight f3 to h2 at
some point he might go knight g4 star
harassing you in the dark squares so
radix said none of that f5 no knight g4
for you you could take on f6 if you
wanted this is a complete change of
structure and lavon said all right i'll
do that and i'll play 92 and i think he
missed this move 92 because it's
actually quite strong uh once you go
back
uh knight c6 which he has played both
the move c3 or the immediate knight g4
they're tough to contend with because
knight g4 not played just yet but knight
g4 is very striking you don't really
have the moves e5 this actually improves
the bishop on a2 much more than it
improves the bishop on b7 and speaking
of the bishop on b7 how do you get it
into the game the moment you play d4 you
structurally destroy everything else
about your position
so it's not easy to see what this bishop
is going to do long term and i like the
way that levon is re-maneuvering his
pieces knight on e2 knight on g4 the
knight's gonna go to g3 and at some
point you start looking at this dark
squares on the king side you feel a
momentum you feel the momentum you feel
the momentum there for the white side so
levon is certainly here with the
initiative but let's go to warsaw as we
have anastasia with more insights from
the play hall
hello everyone once again we are here
from warsaw i just wanted to tell you
that first of all we have really great
atmosphere here and between the games
the players come to the special area
they're chatting with each other it's
really great to see for example levon uh
talking with anand and then gary
kasparov comes in and they have really
nice conversation so it's really
friendly atmosphere here and it's really
enjoyable to stay here and
now that you were talking about the
other games i actually was checking the
game of fabiano and i was a little bit
surprised with the development um
probably if we switch there like at this
moment father played the move c4 i was
wondering that maybe actually white
wanted to play at certain points c4
fixing this weakness on c5 which you
were discussing a little bit before that
it's still not so easy to
win this pawn on c5 so probably fabiano
decided just to give it immediately to
give some space to his pieces but i mean
after a few moves it turned out that
white just took the poem and
i mean i don't see really where the
compensation is for the moment for black
still
the pieces are not developed the bishop
is still in the fade and i wonder also
where the king will go later so i mean i
think at this point we can say that
david
finally got some good chances of this
game against fabiano carano what do you
think about this
back to the studio
we will certainly take a look at that
pawn sacrifice fabby but i really wanted
to draw our attention to vichy's game
because vishy versus anton yeah i mean i
thought it was a strategic uh
slaughter going on here i really didn't
like uh
how uh how anton treated like the
early transition from opening to middle
game and because to my mind this
position is like it's slack it's
horrible yeah but yeah when alejandra
was talking about it like he mentioned
uh that you know
black doesn't have much to attack and
it's comfortable for white but i wanted
to say even earlier like we if we put
the position on move 20 on the board
like rookie 3 here
uh i think the biggest issue for black
in these types of positions is not that
he they don't have enough space it's
that you get mated okay like that sounds
bad yeah 94 94 rook g3 queen of four and
you start getting mated very very
quickly which is why i think he played
knight five rook g3 yeah queen f4 and
then just
direct you just yeah the the ball on e5
cuts the black position the black
position in half so effectively that
it's just very very difficult to bring
enough defenders over to the king's side
which is why you make such an ugly move
as knight five because you you start
seeing that future very very you know
clearly
and you want to do something to to stop
it but yeah the position is just bad and
after e6 yeah it very much doesn't look
like vichy came to defend his plus two
today
anton is in a ton of trouble here yeah
i'm just expecting the move rook e5
no reason to blow up your own king's
side with gf exactly weaken the
pollination at a certain moment we're
crashing through here these positions
are just so horrible but with the only
open file on the board completely
controlled by the white heavy pieces
exactly looks kind of lost now if there
is a criticism i'm not saying there is
it's just that this position oops sorry
right here
it's so good it's so good i mean you
know like there are so many uh
approaches you could take one is to
redirect the knight over to h4 just
pretty much i actually actually like
what fisher did very much because i
still like the breakthrough i think that
the point of what anton was trying to
achieve here if you don't play six here
let's say you uh you make even okay if
you don't play six you don't play
queenie two let's say you play knight
two here yes black plays bishop b6 you
play
knight four black yes g6 yes
even if we disregard the d5 is hanging
like d3 we go rook g8 here right right
and
everything is sort of very nicely
blockaded
but
uh black is not really
sort of giving up g5 and trading the
spawn on e6 for the knight on the f4 is
like best case scenario right so we are
going to start actively encouraging it i
will play like rook c5 and rook dc8 and
just move everything away and and start
asking you to actually take on them
which i will never do right yeah yeah
and i just i i just have the impression
sorry peter dc8 here and rook c4 yeah
and this is a kind of a position where i
mean i'm not going to make an argument
this is not better for white no that's
clear yeah but
it feels like play on one goal though
but doesn't the position in the game
also feel like
i i think you're speeding up the
conversion actually by what fischer has
done very much like the e6 yeah okay
uh do we have this by the way no really
five still hasn't been played he took on
a four this is a bit surprising honestly
uh for me too for me too gf fe fe is a
correct choice i think because if you
take with the bishop i wanted actually
at first i wouldn't take with the bishop
because i wanted to force you to take
one and shakes with the knight but i
think bishop takes just loses to f5 on
on the spot the f5 gf
group g3 is made to happen so you just
never
yeah so you have to take one but if you
take only six twice here i think black
can maybe try taking on h4
absolutely and just g6 rook g7 and
you know those are the conversions yeah
those conversions are those conversions
aren't that easy
because things yeah things have uh
sharpened up significantly here and good
chances of bailing into a drawn ending
drawn rook and pawn end game if i can
get uh the queens off the boards as well
um
uh
yeah but rookie five looked very strong
was there an argument to be made peter
for f5 in this case yeah uh we wanted it
a moment ago i think this
yeah i think this is probably what he
wants and he's got g3 and the idea is to
play rook g3 he's actually started with
registering but also i think it's with
the same idea also very nice queen takes
h5 because like rook takes g6 a threat
it's very easy to auto pilot king h7
there right and king h7 runs into a f5
which might which is what we want yeah
which maybe is even stronger here than
it was in the previous position exactly
essentially what i wanted to avoid doing
mr heading off this bishop i thought
this bishop was so septic
on d7 and by the way if you put your
king on age seven it also
is also questionable encourages a later
later but uh
vishy
okay i'm definitely warming up now i i
see
i see the light yeah
and maybe you like you hate life
with like really really hate life there
but maybe you take on h4 right no so you
play
yeah that's what i wanted to do yeah
after twitter g3 in the current position
so rook g3 in the current mission
without maybe h7 maybe
but if it loses to queen e5 right this
is this is the point we don't even take
on g6 first
we're going to be if we go quickly
queen e5 and then we take on g6 and
everything just starts collapsing yeah
it's just made you can't even do that
yeah yeah there's
yeah there's no way after sorry queen h4
there is just one point that queen takes
f4 does defend the rook
doesn't defend the king yeah and the
king's more important so no queen h4 for
black and anton
on the back foot and looks to be
peddling what is the times by the way
12 against 13
uh still plenty of time for both but
yeah visually visually much much better
but it feels like vichy's got vishy
chest he's got his knight against the
bishop he's one of the rare grand
masters who's willing to give up
his bishops i think most people would
actually be okay with it
it's not a fishy night like it doesn't
get explained tonight every grandmaster
gets to claim that sign me up for this
blockade on d4 thank you thank you okay
so he looks like he's doing good
alejandro take us on the king's indian
tour the magical mystery tour there's a
couple of games where black is just
going all out because strategically our
position is trash this is one of them
this bishop on ca not moving this
riconet not moving we know these things
so this is what black is trying to do
some kind of counter play on this side
of the board trying to hunt down this
king he's just taking on uh d2 take on
d2 and the move h4 played in this
position now what exactly the follow up
is not not clear to me knight h3 is a
very strong move because of the tempo on
knight g5 hitting the rook on that side
and of course the king on h7 and if you
move the king somewhere rook cf1 starts
fighting for the same spots on the king
side remember you cannot bring your
pieces as easily as i can bring my
pieces it's the huge advantage of space
in chess the edge is saying that black's
position is hopeless after both knight
h3 or just g5 and bishop h5 both of them
is a huge advantage also with a huge
advantage is technically here
lesko against fabi anastasia was
mentioning this game to us where white
is currently up upon this important pawn
on c4 is stifling the bishop on a6 not
even clear that you want to take on c4
anytime soon because yes you gain a pawn
but what's your follow-up going to be
you weaken a lot of your squares on the
queens and instead fabi is just castled
on that side of the board said i don't
want anything to deal with that i want
to target the e5 pawn and maybe
g5 h4
g5 h4 in the works getting frisky
because you know
there's no plan that's not this if i
defend this pawn somehow or if i counter
attack with queen f3 and start hitting
f7
it looks attractive it's a very
attractive move you start thinking of d
takes c4 of blowing up the position with
c4 bishop b2 might come at some point if
you take on e5 you can take on f7 it's
risky but you can't do it because you
hit e6 with chuck so black's position
starts to collapse but queen f3 you
could play g5
and let's go let's have a party you're
gonna have all the pawns as white but
you're gonna have seven minutes to
defend against the 2800 hunting down
your king and that is not gonna be easy
so definitely practical chances
objectively gabrielescu in a great
position yeah bishop d2 but i should do
maybe not the best move in the position
but there's a very well kind of breaking
news right stark development in in the
iranian voyager game where iranian
uh did something yeah he just kind of
went off the rails there a little bit uh
we left it somewhere here yeah d3 d4
sorry i'm surprised the square yeah
giving up the e4 square and it's even
worse sorry to interrupt you the
diagonal
maybe the a5 a5 is a very clever move
here by radar creating lady of bishop a6
knight g3 takes stakes
and 92 and now after bishop a6 rook of
three yeah e65 ended the game pretty
much i don't know what he missed because
this is the most this is the most
obvious move in the position and i like
crashing yeah it's just dead right
because i think f takes e5 queen takes
e5 takes advantage of this pin
and you can put it on your board yeah
terrible
just like you just can't hold on to
anything look after 94 was resigned by
the way could somebody just put this
bishop c4 variation to bed i mean this
bishop i made too i've seen it like two
or three games though like it's terrible
the striking thing about it is like five
moves ago well if one was much better
and it's a position you would assume he
will play quite well and yeah g3d knight
of 3g4 just is a very very strange way
to treat it
wow i mean c3 should be one and then
maybe you can consider playing g4 but
actually it was right about here we were
kind of confused by the move knight f3
because knight g4 is so intuitively
obvious you kind of you want to like
disturb this knight and bring you know
invite knight takes g4 but okay uh e5
and this whole sequence just doesn't
work wow doesn't make any sense and that
is the position
it's difficult to make a move really
yeah because fe 525 loses material e5 v4
currently isn't game ending threat
and you you don't have any way really to
sidestep it a nasty nasty pin down the
ear so
yeah things things really have gone
as absolutely off the rails absolutely
off the rails for levon which is yeah
very unexpected considering that he was
he was navigating those kind of weird
you know sicilian slash maybe somewhat
you know
spanish
type position and not really spanish
frenchy type positions very well
and then yeah and then this and then
this yeah yeah and then this uh this
does not look good for lavon aronian
fans if he escapes this one i mean he
really is the modern houdini uh quickly
checking in on anton anthony still think
i reacted to rook g3
and how is wesley so doing um
uh alejandro
he's doing great he has a huge time
advantage still retaining that eight
minute differential between his opponent
kill shift check with four he's got 12
but look at the position still an extra
point fantastic you got this break with
the move f3 white trying to do something
in the position but it's not quite
enough you could take on d5 to control
the e3 square and if you take e3 knight
c4
and then f4 yeah you open up the bishop
but who cares this is very strong the
structure is bad you have a good bishop
but that's about all the compensation
that you get in this position certainly
not enough black with a decisive
advantage on this one so wesley doing
great in round number three he'll need
this one to bounce back from his
previous loss no question about it
and uh again the
candidate matchups uh they're a very
nice move i think by uh g5 a very
logical move pushing that pushing the
knight away and exactly now i think
alejandro was suggesting push page five
it prob yeah it does look like the most
natural move rook df-1 doesn't look
horrible but
allowing h takes on knight four i would
have preferred yet to control the price
100
behind you on that one my goodness
take that knight off the board threaten
to take this and if you take the knight
as you're about to mention you're not
going to f4 because the rook is hanging
because also g6 bishop h5 looks crushing
but
and in the meantime g1 yeah i think the
the gorilla escocarana game has gone uh
very much
i think he may have missed rook takes d5
i think he played bishop g2
and the difference between sort of the
bishop on c1 and the bishop one d2
specifically there which game sorry the
governor let's go game
uh with fabi yeah he played bishop to
two move 19 and after bishop takes e5
suddenly you cannot go knight takes d5
anymore
because rook takes d5 actually protects
the protects the bishop on e4 e5 and
we've blocked out our own
our own rook on d1 otherwise we would
have been playing rook g1 takes d5 here
and taking on e5 maybe it's not great
but it would have at least given us a
chance to win the piece back right yeah
and uh and he had to go knight g2 bishop
c7 which before the position still
doesn't look
horrible horrible but it definitely is a
very large employee i should give me
back my e5
it does look horrible because we can
play five here right yeah e5 hp5 88 wins
a piece yeah give me back my e5 on
police meter this is terrible this is
huge one what wins a piece you're five
no no no
i'm sorry i'm losing my mind well even
that ending by the way it's fine for
black but i thought it was winning and
yeah it's yeah it's clearly not winning
the intention of course was that this
bishop was pinned to the queen but there
is as alejandra is pointing out
a uh white is probably even better in
the same game after like cd5 and knight
of four so fabi goes c5 instead of e5
which is a very understandable move but
at least we got one bishop off the board
yeah but but c5 yeah one bishop but the
remaining one it it was a bad bishop
it's not gonna be
he's not gonna be a bad bishop on b7
he's gonna wake up on the long diagonal
and that's not going to be very
very enjoyable yeah
you can experience unpleasant sensations
as victor korchnoy
quoting victor courtney yeah that long
diagonal even though
it's definitely an improvement for black
compared to
what the position should have been by
this point exactly exactly all right and
finally
where did we have this was the fabby
game richard game we know
[Music]
uh and
we wanted to see what lavon somehow yeah
somehow kept the game somewhat afloat he
played knight c1 rogue g3 it looks
horrible but i mean maybe there's
nothing better 24 rookie 4
yeah he's getting kind of uh
squeezed
yeah
he's down upon here the the extra pawn
is only three
it's not great a queen e5 it looks it
looks absolutely absolutely lost true
true it just doesn't look like you
you're going to be surgical you still
have e2
it's the same trick
right now oh yeah it's the same trick
this is very cute over and over 925 and
yeah
this this pin just costs you the the
piece with the rook c8 coming yeah
nothing nothing spoiled obviously like
yeah queen g5 quincy five but when you
spot it if it comes into your mind the
move e2 which by the way traps white's
queen so it's like yeah that would have
been game over on the spot yeah
then you realize it's just game over he
did play queen g5
oops excuse me not e2 queen g5
and
no the game does not flare anew yeah
yeah but it's still it's still
completely lost of course
yeah
yeah queen takes h4 played after a long
thing in the core of game which does
allow queenie that's kind of a strange
thing like a look that vishy gave him
did you really think that long for uh
queen takes h4 queen e5 don't you have a
move against this oops yeah he must have
missed him yeah he must have missed it
now no i don't see how you even continue
from here it looks designable it's one
of those things that you see it
immediately right
and then you think of thinking thinking
and you you're getting confused by other
variations and then you go to yourself
well why don't i take the h4 pawn the
guy goes queen e5 and you go i saw that
i saw that yeah yes yes i
yeah and uh
the awful feeling is sinking in yeah
this is three out of three for this yeah
you can sort of still make a move of
yeah of this description just 36 king f7
we can also start with knight takes e6
it kind of makes giving made slightly
easier actually i think knight takes six
might be the cleanest way no rook f6
exists no no no no no no no no
just everything rook takes g6
uh i like rook jake's g6 and vishy what
a day
the old meister wish you the king three
out of three to start history
nice
nice very very nice start for for vichy
wow
yeah always very enjoyable to see him do
well because yeah when he gives us all
old fogies uh inspiration absolutely
that but also when he plays well it just
flows right right he's one of those
people where you like you you you see
that the pieces go from you know one
good square to another good square and
like they never they improve and
everything
three for three vichy annan welcome back
vishy grand chester misses you
wesley so uh
upper piece up a piece what's up
f3 he just went c6 i'm
the question there for me is if you want
to play c6 why haven't you played it on
the previous move
like you could have played g6 here
instead of hp6 c6 and g5 here looks like
c6 that's scary just just establish this
really large center and just win from
there
but no particular reason not to do it in
this move order i guess i mean this
looks prettier than it is right
yeah d5 that's a very pretty center
could actually if i could actually go
see takes d5 bishop c8 e5 maybe that
would have given some compensation but
therefore
bishop c8 e5 if you could if you could
do this
maybe you could make an argument but
take stakes queen takes d5 i think puts
put spades to all of those hopes like
everything
that knight on f7 is looking better
yeah for sure and if you have to take he
takes d5 yes it does look very beautiful
but the bones go go nowhere absolutely
and the queen side will get developed
and then you have fewer pieces on the
board yeah
these ponds a bit of an issue yeah
they're a huge uh tank no question but
they got nowhere to go as you're
pointing out c5 hangs the d5 pawn and
black will unravel his pieces knight d7
knight f6 and that looks like uh
wesley all the way alejandro what do you
have for us green that's turning around
a little bit is this game of favi as he
is with the black pieces searching for
that initiative gallery let's go down to
a minute 30 and a king walk happening
remember that bobby long castle well
it's going back the other way king is
going to e7 just to serve saveguard the
f7 pawn you see why it's going it's
because queen 188 kind of flushed it out
to d7 and he didn't want to make a draw
of course after queen f3 king c8 because
at this point he has a strong pawn
center this knight is kind of
and this bishop very importantly is
coming to the b7 diagonal you gotta
defend this pawn on f7 first you could
have played f6 king e7 is also a good
movie just hold on to the pawn bishop b7
is coming next move and gabriel esco
burning time burning time one minute
left against
10 but more importantly bishop b7
between c66 all right you have to play
before bishop b7 and perhaps something
like queen elizabeth
just kind of four immediately
invited which i understand the a5 queen
g5 check and then maybe before but yeah
it's it's bad it's bad it's bad it's bad
i mean
he's just lost that important e5 pawn
and the pawns are gonna roll
let's
jump over to
warsaw and a chat with our tournament
leader
thank you yasser we are in with a man
that needs absolutely no introduction
the five-time world champion vishy anand
vichy welcome to the show welcome to
poland welcome to the grand chess tour
you're back tell us about your initial
feelings about the organization of the
event as well as the first day
uh the organization of the granchester
is always superb um everywhere
it's done perfectly and
that's one of the reasons i accepted
very quickly
i was apprehensive because again i've
come off a very long break but obviously
they went like a dream
just
everything i could hope for everything i
could hope for just
everything nice happened what can i say
how do you usually get ready for an
event like this after such a long break
five months since baku if i'm not
mistaken right um i
i knew that the long
layover was i mean the long break was
going to cause some problems so i
got some friends especially some of the
youngsters uh well
funny to call them youngsters they're
all the best juniors in the world but
anyway since i work with them i
managed to shun guy them into a few
blitz games so that's how i practiced a
bit um
i
played a bit but still
when you see the pieces for the first
time you feel very rusty
but luckily the first game went well and
and that kind of helps with wesley i was
all at sea but then i found myself in a
nice action i didn't get to talk uh
about that game with wesley specifically
because wesley uh i say this novel idea
of taking on d5 queen c to at least uh
he has said it a few times but it's more
or less a novel idea um were you
prepared and it did feel like you
actually out prepared him somehow
um
i was not i i saw that he had played
queen c6 especially against uh shaq
one a nice game here in this position no
no no uh he went queen c2 earlier
queen c2 and um
that's kind of relevant and the idea is
something along the lines of what he did
knight g2 bishop d2f3 and so on he also
played this against sam sevion at the
american cup
i
i had prepared something a few days back
unfortunately by then we got to stage i
mean
you have to think of all the other
things you can do as well so
i could not remember what it is what my
solution was i remember a few fragments
here and there then i just decided rapid
just you just play fast f3 so i'm here
if e4 i will take and play c5 so always
that that is my
condom and i was very very happy to put
the knight on f8 because it freezed the
other night and head 7 is covered as you
saw in the game right
so
but even so after he castled i wasn't
sure exactly if i was doing this right
because at the end white is getting g4 h
for g5 and e4 it's gonna be a race
so i decided
again i don't know in a classical
tournament if i would be
i wouldn't say flippant but just play b5
but in rapid game you think fine i'll
play b5
um as long as you scale your opponent
that usually works as well so that that
was what i wanted to do i played b and
that's one of the things uh that
struck me is that you were spending not
a lot of time while he was burning uh
through most of his time
yes he that reassured me actually that
he was thinking a lot especially one or
two moves later
uh after queen six this is where he
started thinking he thought for a very
long time and then i felt much better
because i thought uh yeah it's
interesting that bishop b7 it didn't
like
i tried my best to find come up with
another move but i couldn't i didn't
like knight b6 but maybe that is the
best move then bishop takes c2 and yeah
you're already taking over yes because
uh this is very typical um in lots of
there's also some lines in the nimzo
where of course the black one will be on
g5 but same thing happens and you get
this fast attack there are lots of
queen's camera declines as well where
white castles long black loses a pawn
but then these rooks it's very powerful
i don't know somehow recently whenever i
looked at the engine this sort of
position gives a
even bigger advantage for black than i
would estimate so by this though i was
happy
but the one thing i really liked about
my position is that the knight is
you know it seemed to be white could
conjure up some kind of fortress but at
the end i'll play 96 and the whole
structure will collapse almost that was
what i was looking forward to i i
couldn't evaluate but i didn't need to i
knew that it's only a question how much
better black is
nice towards uh the end this is uh we
were kind of shocked that he actually
resigned at this point did you expect
him to resign did you feel like he has
any other i didn't see another morpher
and by the way the computer agrees with
you the computer does say that you are
completely winning we just felt like
it's a bit uh too early
i was also ahead of time so the question
is what he should be waiting for and he
just couldn't see a move but i simply
didn't see a move for him because even
if his knight moves i'll go queen if he
checked knight before
i'll probably win the f4 pawn
i'm going to be two pawns up it's a bit
too much
i was slightly happy that i didn't have
to prove it but um not not very much
i
i thought resigns is quite reasonable
actually here vishy congratulations a
perfect start for you we're looking
forward to see you in the next few days
thanks a lot guys back to you thank you
uh christian and our congratulations to
fishy for as we say a perfect story an
absolutely perfect start the games are
blowing up all over the place uh one
game especially duda versus richie
we've just seen yes this was the move
that i had expected uh
rook takes c8
g4 is a nice touch here actually
actually capturing the queen on h4 it's
a very cute
solution to probably all of our problems
on the kings exactly once you you you
once you start seeing what's going on
here you start to
to panic right there's all kinds of rook
f2 and i think it might become unclear
yeah but rook s8 i think solves but that
solves all of it yeah
clear the cobwebs right away rook takes
rook takes and rook t4 you can play you
can play knight h3 check it save some
material but you will lose because your
entire queen side will disappear like i
go knight takes h3 you have to take with
the queen we will trade queens i will
take on d6 if the police if the starts
right here yeah if the policy seven was
still alive this would have been uh
something to discuss with the policies
no
no no no
you desperately look for something else
but there might not be anything else
the pawns go marching marching through
uh
looks like a smooth win uh for white
then the game of fabi uh let me just
check that photo is just much much
better he's got this
this woeful night on g2 we've been
talking about you know
vishy's night on d4 and this is and
alejandra said sign me up for that
but not this how about the knight on g2
come on
not so much can i offer
no
nights
for me this property uh the pawns
dominating the knight on g2 all of the
squares fabi for choice big time going
absolutely and we we're watching the
continuation of bucharest in the game
between levon and and and radek no way
uh i think this is now fine-ish for
white i don't know if it's entirely
equal but
what i mean how did he escape i just i
just i don't know if he's hypnotizing
his opponents like if you go back a few
moves and if somebody can explain the
move rook f2 to me yeah rook f2 is just
i think he i'm pretty sure he thought he
was getting made the explanation is he
thought yes after king takes f2 there is
forced mate with i don't i don't know
maybe knight before check you know he
missed the king goes to h2 maybe he
thought he can play 94 here and forgot
about queen g8 check and queen of f8 and
there's a perpetual there very
comfortably
by the way yeah
well at least
yeah you're better but it's not very
clean right it's it's not it's not clean
but
you kind of have to calculate it out
because the way i mean what's happening
in the game i mean he's upon up what he
chose is also not that bad actually he's
he's going to have very disappointing
chances i've seen the story before
yeah i mean we've definitely we've
definitely watched movies
i would suggest this is actually winning
yes
like properly properly played out i
would suggest this is winning because
queen against queen with knight against
queen bishop i mean with 10 minutes
against 30 seconds i don't think right
yeah
king g7 come on
yeah queen e5 is never a mistake just
centralized play b5 play you know maybe
at some point king j7 knight h5 or
something but none of this none of this
was supposed to happen like you yeah
none of those murders
no contemplation we understood if we go
back to the position where he played
rook after just go rook f4
it's over i mean this spot on e3 is
humongous why would you give it up yeah
just play rook before there
right and and give me eight because the
yeah the rook on e2 is not really
participating in like go knight e4
knight g3 next and just give mate
it's just over the king on h6 with the
rook on the four still alive the king on
h6 will not receive a single check in
this game so you just allow all kind
like you allow queen g8 you'll like
windows 7 you don't care about any of
those things you just play knight e4
knight g3 and win
or something else but like this is the
easiest way yeah
this rook on f4 is so powerful
on e3 he must have he must have thought
he was giving mate with checks basically
wow that's the only that's the only
explanation because otherwise like you
don't care about the bottom b6 there
what a shock what a shock yeah
by the way i'm sorry i mean i understand
what you're saying the queen e5 can't be
wrong but king g7 can you say not bad
either queen c4 is why he didn't do it
just hits
thank you queen c4
he didn't do it yeah well in that case i
can then go check and check yeah sure i
get the same position he's on 30 seconds
and he also clearly is very unhappy
about having to play this because i'm
sure he understands yes yeah of course
of course it's not like it's uh you know
he's a very very strong player he knows
he messed up right bishop b1 after
queenie e5 yeah b5 asc yeah before if
you was thinking bishop c4 though peter
why couldn't he have been stubborn
uh lavonne i mean i don't know maybe he
was actually worried about 94 bishop c4
is it possible he actually like
legitimately thought this was a strong
threat yeah i want to go king h5h4 g3
and give me
that was my point
it's a plan wow it's a plan okay bishop
be one dust up knight e4 yeah
yeah levon i think should be quite happy
about the fact that there is no queen
side left
very much so and that his bishop does at
least
improves his practical chances yeah you
it has to be winning but also you don't
win them very often you i mean
it requires very good techniques that
didn't come out quite right but what i
mean is it's very very easy to mess this
up and not win this position exactly i
like queen f4 because i think the way to
win this is to actually play g5 g4 and
start creating mating threats and queen
four is a nice is a nice start to that
and obviously with queens off it's
completely lost because the white no
question the white pawns are on such
squares that you never get to trade them
and black wins very very comfortably
with it exactly
so i very much like queen of four we
play queen a6 i've been
thinking i've just wanted the kind of e1
this will go on for a while maybe we can
switch okay to the dude again because
that was about over duda is up a queen
oh
okay when we left it richard's got a
couple checks but a couple of checks
does not compensate he's not even going
to give up any any materials you've got
kingy one there rook of fate
yeah this is the bird's eye i don't i
don't know what we're supposed to
blunder here because knight d3 doesn't
like black wants to give mate on f1 but
there are
you aren't actually threatening anything
right now as far as i can tell you can
play c7 for instance
just to have c7 c8 as a kind of a backup
right also play
such a move you know it's like yeah it's
a move that could lose if you're when it
was actually threatening anybody
checking 93 93 or something
but nothing's a threat but when you make
oh well knight takes d5 of course oh but
then i have queen takes g3 yeah queen g3
or queen f3 or you know it is not hard
to play a position up a queen yeah like
the amazing thing about chess yeah uh
you can take this to the bank everybody
it's it's easy to play it when you're up
a queen bishop f3 but also obviously you
can play something like rook g4 here and
and just start trading we don't have to
you know we don't have to fight that
many moves guys
knight takes and wesley did win his game
as we expected just up a piece against
chefchenko for no real reason
uh kirill with
interesting games but i think a minus
one result
yeah yeah of
did he draw the first two i want to say
that he drew the first one did he draw
i think he may have lost in round one
sorry he's a minus two yeah because he
lost
he lost in the first round he lost to
richard that
french where he sacrificed the piece and
didn't come off yet so he lost two games
with white
oh yeah both of them
both of them
fairly weirdly hang on a second
i mean he did sacrifice a piece in both
games i'm not really sure how prompted
either of those sacrifices were
yeah
fair
so by the way that's the uh bobby is
completely winning we don't really have
to go there but five is completely
winning in his game against david
gabrielesko so david is going to have
sadly a somewhat expected very very
difficult thursday it's very difficult
to adjust and he also i think was given
very very little warning that he'll be
playing in this tournament
uh left it to the very last moment to
withdraw and
i mean
some kind of force mature happened there
i mean
it's such a great invitation hi how
would you like to to
play in the grand chess store i accept
and then it the the dawning realization
is like wait a minute am i really
prepared to play these monsters day
after day after day i mean it's such a
jumping level for him right he's totally
he hasn't even completed his gym title
and there's the trick here he comes yeah
richie goes knight g6 which is
one trick yeah cute little move yeah
will he see it he's threatening rook f1
and made on the spot but the most most
things here are quite good yeah like
bishop three knight h4 is actually maybe
the way to become for it to become
tricky but that's the five i think
knight five is probably the the easiest
right knight the five night the five ef
knight takes h4 and then some move i
don't know for me i'm thinking
is the lazy grand master this is lazy
grandmaster work over here take take
rook h6 right yeah
i know i know you're awake not bad not
bad either no no no no not bad but you
like knight f5 and i just go just go
knight to five knight fight
you have to take on a yeah that's what
he does he takes on h4 interesting he
also obviously agrees about knight takes
f5 positions i just don't understand
what the idea is after i take g3 here
not not only that but uh i guess he
wants like rook a2 and there's
knight g2 is a bigger threat than we
thought
what are you thinking because queen g3
whoa
because that is
that is a solid move that is a solid i'm
not gonna give it a boo two no
two solid pawns come on alejandro
when you take on g3 knight takes g3 your
next move is bishop g4
so that you can just make sure that your
coronation is
coming with and i found a very cute way
to actually conclude uh
his game yeah okay we'll switch to that
yeah that's a very cute diagram he
actually found a way to uh sacrifice
sacrifice his queen to to finish very
very cleanly like he's true allowing me
six checks seemingly things have gone
wrong threatening me yeah but then with
the takes takes and yeah he goes rookie
one major
no checks available for the white apart
from queen e6 yeah we see and we see
duda uh conclude his game against richie
with a with a victory
wow nice uh
i must say there that
richie looked out like he didn't really
feel that position very well that king's
indian yeah attacking position felt like
he if he was uh not not entirely on
point and live on one level we'll just
make a draw here like he draws i'm
calling this now yeah because i think i
think maybe uh
radical wants to play queen d5 but then
we take and we take on h7 and the one
pawn will not be enough to win the game
i think that is true
what oh yeah no yeah you just take on h
and if you're
if you play king of six you you'll have
to start running and with the h7 pawn
hanging it means that you basically can
never interpo yet now we just
fabi won this game as we expected yeah
we only have one game left which wow
yeah and one just marks the draw now
yeah yeah it's amazing
he made it look effortless easy as pie
it's just amazing i mean
e2 would have just been this is all
almost f4 would have been lights out i
mean how many ways
almost almost on par with uh with uh
some of his best efforts from bucharest
really this is really insane to survive
this yeah
like you're you're losing you're losing
by force in a number of ways
and also
like if they if raleigh didn't want to
calculate he didn't have to calculate he
could have just you know won it out by
by hand
it's just an amazing yeah levon is just
if you if you watch his failure like
oh my i lost my mind it doesn't matter
how many times he loses his mind he
still saves these games it's insane four
victories one draw as we wrap up our
coverage and this was the dream this was
the drawing
of this one
you can hear the flaws from the
auditorium for the for the players
wow
yeah and vishy and nand our tournament
leader with three out of three
and fabi and duda
fabi deuteronomy and tie for second
we'll get you our current standings in a
moment guys uh we've seen
it's in it all it's been it's been one
day we saw it all wow yeah this has been
a remarkable day of chess and uh some
very nicely played games some some games
that perhaps could have been played
slightly better but
yeah
one of the all-time greats on three out
of three
and yeah 11 out of 15 decisive games
vichy winning all three today
plenty plenty to be very happy about
right i mean i like the way vichy said
that he's been working with these junior
players and he shanghaied them to play
some blitz with them get
get the feeling the pieces
i'm sure i'm sure they did not want to
play blitz against who would ever you
know what 15 year old would like
actually want want to play blitz games
against i would i mean i'd love the
tumble of uh blitz and i've i bet you
those juniors right now are saying see i
did that i did it
i prepped him i drafted him
what do you say
nice hey whatever he's doing it's
working because he's got in good
positions and converted even quite
cleanly he just destroyed korabov and
korobov's pet opening he outplayed
wesley when vichy was the one that was
unclear with his prep
he's doing a great job here in the start
of warsaw super bad rapid and blitz and
i hope he continues because he just
surprises i think that a lot of people
didn't really count him in for the world
rapid championship he won not that many
years ago and he can he shows that it
doesn't matter how old he is what age
what form how long since his last
tournament he can come back to the board
and just kick some butt and that's what
he did today yeah for me it was when he
had lost the world championship match
uh initially in chennai to
magnus then he came back to win the
candidates and say i want another crack
at you magnus i mean i thought
whoa this is a matter yeah there's so
with purpose that was impressive i think
that we're still uh
people have sort of moved on because you
don't really expect
people to actually follow through with
this but i believe there's still some
hat teaching on hold since
2014 i i have a feeling that the
some people went on the record saying
that the only thing they know for sure
about the hunty candidates is that we
should not win it right and then he will
retire immediately after when he win
yeah yeah yeah i remember i remember
this dude granted this one guys here it
is look at our current standings look at
that retired watch stop oh
actually a full point ahead of the field
here uh a full two points or in this
scoring system but yeah nobody nobody on
five out of six
um
as you can as you can see there uh
a couple of people on four out of six
but the one i want to say that our
candidates are actually doing pretty
well uh just a quick point that uh
gary kasparov in that scene that you had
seen in one of our breaks said
the challenger is coming out of warsaw
we were like what
so we've got three candidates and gary
kasparov's picks are the three players
here that he thinks the challenger comes
from this so you're planning to you know
i'm going to call them up
just
scholarships i'll take the rest of the
field or whatever gary what's going on
uh what can we do
but that was an in
in interesting uh challenge and here is
our schedule peter yeah we have two more
two more days exactly like today uh yeah
tomorrow and uh saturday we will have
three days uh three rounds of rapids per
day and that concludes the rapid portion
and then we will play nine nine rounds
of blitz on sunday and nine rounds of
bits so on monday uh with playoffs if
necessary on monday and uh the the
[Music]
rapid cost twice as much as blitz so
yeah as you've seen on your screen these
these games can double and the blitz
games will count uh with the normal
scoring system but we're used to the
tops of tops and turvy
nature of these rapid and blitz games
sometimes you can go out on a massive
score around
days one and two but you can easily
still be caught because so many points
on those last two days yeah it's it's 18
games of blitz which is obviously a very
large distance to
for people to catch up to you but still
obviously it's you you would prefer to
have a
you know a buffer before before blitz
starts and yeah
vishy
uh we should doing really really well
and in a moment we will have an
interview from from warsaw but for now
it's just it's just been a very very fun
fun day of rapid
uh houdini who didn't like escapes
continue
yeah that's just
just so ridiculous
what position can he not say i mean
if you could just pull up that one
position on your board alejandro where
it was that e2 moment
and the rook f4 moment and you kind of
say
lavon survives the this position i mean
yeah it's how is it possible i mean
this is a shorter time control game but
still you're
this is about as lost opposition as
as you can imagine
oh but as you're drawing up that board
will jump to warsaw
as christian is with our guest
thank you yasir we are here with the
local hero yan shishtav duda after quite
a successful and uh day at the office
for him uh yanshi first of all tell us
about how important it is for the
granchester to finally be here in poland
yes i am very happy uh
that the episode of grand stories held
here in poland warsaw it's a very
special feeling for me in the poll of
course
and i also before the first round i felt
sort of bigger pressure than usual you
know
but
luckily for me i managed to play quite a
convincing game and
yeah so right now it's i'm pretty
comfortable spot but
tournament has just begun so there is a
lot of
stuff coming no you're playing in front
of your home crowd you're a home fans do
you feel any extra pressure because of
that
yeah at the beginning uh
something to be honest i mean more
pressure than usual um
yeah but i guess it's just about you
know getting used to it so
yeah day after day it would be easier
you started off with uh a clean victory
against david gavrielsko after that a
difficult game against fabiano but then
you bounced immediately back with a nice
victory against richie rapport in this
wild kings india's uh take us through
this game a little bit and the critical
moments yeah i must confess i didn't
expect uh richard rapper to play the
king's indian at all i mean i mean he
sometimes plays it but also um as far as
i know as i remember he plays a lot of
silence so actually i
kind of expected him you know to play
anything with the main line right so uh
i mean i mean ic6 here like
some queenie a stuff you should before i
mean i guess he played all of it
yeah basically i have totally no
like experience in this kind of
positions with white i mean in king's
indian usually you know i try not to get
checkmated but this time i mean recently
i
have seen a lot of engine games and well
yeah and i always think white is better
yeah it's king's indian for sure and i
just wanted to give it a try and
and see you know but i wasn't overly
comfortable i must confess but i also
didn't quite see that i come coming i
mean series one so and you mentioned
before uh we got on with the interview
that you didn't feel like you had full
control of the position what were those
moments where you didn't feel like you
have full control of the position
yeah i mean
no i i think i was just better
positionary but uh
probably winning but um yeah it's always
uncomfortable because it seemed to me
that he's going to replace
perhaps when the king was getting older
he's like you know uh i mean he needs a
lot of moves to actually get some
counter play and
um yeah here actually i was kind of
thinking about playing g4 one day i mean
i mean
it's a moment yeah
um because just to
shut down this bishop on city and rooney
yeah but in this very position i guess
it's not that convincing for me so i
decided just to play for like
i mean slow move but um yeah and
he's improving open things up yeah i
mean it's sort of natural i guess uh in
such positions with black
um
yeah i was i i thought i was better to
be honest after any moves so
yeah i mean it was very natural when did
you feel like he is uh losing control of
this game and you're fully taking over
now after h4 i mean actually i didn't
expect it for at all
i must confess and um
yeah after knight xg4 or something i
also thought it was better but
yeah just knight takes i think bishop
takes and
uh probably would be a better yeah
yeah and just take sex in king g2 yeah
so i'm
i'm both i mean i'm better positionary
and also have an athletic so
you still have an attack while he
doesn't feel like he has yeah but but
also in long term yeah much better
because of dependency seven of course
absolutely so um
yeah i mean here of course he must have
been winning like but it's always an
issue you know to convert like smoothly
in such positions because there is a lot
of pieces um a lot of pawns in the world
so
there's a fair chance you know that
something goes wrong especially you
knowing faster time controls so
um yeah i wasn't like you know 100 sure
i'm i'm gonna win this so
yeah but i mean his pieces are kind of
stuck
like this on a bishop on c8 that said i
mean bishop on c8 is not the
i mean it's not no normal working piece
of course but uh the rook on eight is an
issue also knight only 80s or g7 is kind
of um
i mean not doing much so it's quite a
stuck piece yeah yeah yeah so
yeah no
i mean i mean
i thought it must
be winning for me but
yeah i mean
still require yeah here here i wasn't
sure actually i mean ruger seven is so
not true
i mean i i had seen queen and trading in
advance but still still decided to to go
for it i mean maybe it's not that
practical in uh but
okay bonang season is a very yummy one
of course and i might as well take it
yeah yeah you know i'm pumped
so um yeah here i mean i wasn't like i
mean i didn't see of course anything for
him but i
kind of especially in this position like
i had a feeling that i must i might i
might be blundering something to be
honest there's a lot of pieces around
your king first yeah there are some
tricks like knight z5 for example here
but after that i guess just going to be
free he wins on the spot
uh for example so um and also here i
mean yeah it's of course winning for me
and i was
you know okay here is like
okay here was funny moments because
i mean i can clean up
and a couple points still play but i
have to i have to move some slow move
you know and there is always some
feeling that you know
might render something and okay i took
the spawn and i thought
or something like that yeah yeah no i
mean it's just you know looking scary of
course it's just an r i mean there is
nothing but concrete but um yeah and
here i
sort of didn't see any g6 i mean i mean
of course everything is winning here for
white but and i had lucky two minutes
because if i had like 30 seconds maybe
yeah there will be a fair chance you
know i would panic here
because uh it's like you have to give up
some material well there's a checkmating
threat on the board so yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you kind of yeah and he's nice you know
just to
uh
yeah rick sacrifice i don't know is
there such a word english i mean i mean
you know give back a queen yes so uh
yeah
yeah uh quite a successful day for you
at the office what are your ambitions
going into this event
yesterday at the opening ceremony i was
saying like i don't know 15 times or
more
of course i'm intending to win this
tournament because that's basically the
point of playing you know to win
in competitions so yeah the start is um
not so bad i guess for me
um at least i you know
met my two opponents in the candidates
so
yeah of course i'm not satisfied with my
game against fabiano
yeah but i didn't quite equalize and um
and actually i actually had lost i mean
such similar games to this one to him
which is kind of annoying to be honest
that he outplayed me in better but
perhaps the neighbor went again
somewhere
um
yeah but um okay
that's what chess is all about so
sometimes you win sometimes you lose
it's alive always in a fighting thank
you very much for joining us we'll see
you in the next few days thank you guys
back to you thank you christian thank
you duda for sharing his thoughts and
yeah i think he had pretty much good
control of that king's indian throughout
one game that i just i i'm still shaking
my head about is the lavon game earlier
there was a one move tactic that just e2
wins the game but if you don't win
tactically you can certainly understand
how you win strategically you drop your
rook back to f4 peter you defend them
but as i said i think it's very easily
explained by simply like he thought rook
of two finishes the game he
there was some kind of a miscalculation
i assume on somewhat low time if we
could just check he was here two minutes
here
the big question for me is why do you
even calculate like rook of two requires
you to calculate something because
you're giving up your like you're
trading a very active rook for a very
passive rook on e2 and you're giving up
your extra pawn on e3 so i assume he
thought 94 maybe his mate and he missed
something in the lines after queen g8
queen of fate
uh that allows white to continue giving
checks maybe he thought something here
just wins
um he's not entirely sure what kid
scamper away from a perpet some kind of
a run against against the perpetual it's
black magic alejandra that's what i
gotta say i'm gonna
uh sticking with that but uh our
predictions uh after day one let's see
who got it right and
nobody picked vichy so
shame on you all
bad commentators back
[Music]
how's wesley doing
50 no that's not bad yeah
you get a participation
i've never heard such insults but let's
jump uh to warsaw for our final thoughts
of day one of this competition christian
anastasia over to you
well uh guys what an amazing day of
chess continuing the grand chess tour
here in poland an amazing day filled
with a lot of excitement i have to say
i'm quite surprised by the performance
of vishyananda after such a long
extended break for him coming into this
event and scoring three out of three in
the first day that that's just a
marvelous performance by vichy anon the
five-time world champion i'm definitely
having my eyes on him and uh looking
forward to see how he's going to
continue uh this trick anastasia how
about yourself yeah i mean because i
didn't pick him up that's why he made so
well today you know that's why he won
three games because normally the one i
pick up doesn't perform well at all you
know after that yes of course where it's
really great that he is doing so well
and it's always great to see him in a
good shape and a good mood actually as
well and what i what i noticed today we
had 11 decisive games and only four
draws have you ever heard of something
like that so much blood that was just
incredible and uh let's not forget in
the first round of the day it was
actually four out of five decisive games
and it could have easily been five out
of five just an amazing day of chase
guys how about yourselves
we can only echo your thoughts as well
uh so many decisive games it was
wonderful alejandro to call today's
action it felt
that's why we like rapping and blitz we
do there's mistakes there's fire there's
action there's surprises i think levon
was the biggest surprise
thrill spills with 11 decisive results
this is why a lot of people advocate for
faster time controls it stays like this
and we're going to have the same
tomorrow so don't worry about what's
going to happen it'll be exciting
absolutely that is right and once again
thank you for joining us uh on our day
one uh join us tomorrow for day two of
the same coverage same broadcast five
days in a row and we'll see you all
tomorrow see you then
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited